input volume maybe just a little smidge
high because we can hear you well but it
was a little bit distorted you usually
sound much better than that
how's this
perfect
yeah this is better
yes
several inches back
okay you're all set representative
mr chairman of the house health human
services and elderly affairs committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covert 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
some committee members are participating
in this meeting from the legislative
office building
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the house health human
services and elderly affairs committee
it may be followed by an executive
session
please note that there is no physical
location for the members of the public
to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and that the public has access to listen
contemporaneously and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
this notice the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
3600 271-3600
or else email hcs
leg.state.nh
dot us
in the event the public as a whole is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that is on
the meeting assisting us and that would
be
christina daya
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
we will start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance
when each member states his or her
presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting and this is required under the
right to know law
would the clerk please call the world
thank you chairman
representative mcmahon
president and i am alone in my office at
my home in windham
representative nelson
present in my home in brookfield i'm
alone
representative acton
president i am i am alone in my home um
in fremont
representative kelsey
i'm present in my home in bedford alone
representative king
here
[Music]
i am here in my home office in wilton
alone in this room there are other
people in the house
representative weber
i am in my
uh second home in concord uh i am alone
in the room but i sharing the house
currently with a friend who is in
another room and leaving shortly
and while i'm here excuse me could i
just relay to the chairman that patricia
tilly and beth daly would like to speak
after the reps and senators because he
doesn't have his phone right now so
thank you
representative mckay
yeah jim mckay i'm a home alone and
representationer
oh how about you
i see you no i'm not muted can you hear
me yeah and now i can okay sorry uh
jerry caner cure i'm home in my uh study
in freedom uh my wife is in the house
but not in the room thank you thank you
representative soloway
representative salloway is present at
his home in lee new hampshire and alone
in the office
representative cannon
representative cannon is here in my home
alone in somersworth
representative nederwell
i'm here alone in my home in nashua
i'm home in my office
alone in keene
representative
woods uh yes i'm here in my study in
beau
um i'm by myself but my wife's elsewhere
in the house
representative merchants
yes i'm here in claremont in my home
and my wife is somewhere in the house
representative pearson
with 18 presents and we will keep an eye
on the other three who i'm sure come
shortly uh how is my volume now is it
better
excellent thank you
i open the hearing on house bill 2
establishing medical freedom in
immunizations
and the chair calls on the prime sponsor
yes he's on screen just needs to unmute
thank you mr chair thank you for
allowing me to testify for your
committee today i'm representative tim
lang
from belknap four
i'm appearing for you to introduce house
bill 220 establishing medical freedoms
i will say that
the title is a little uh
misleading the idea is that
establishing that in the state of new
hampshire new hampshire citizens have
the inalienable right
to bodily integrity free from threat
from or compulsion that person accept
any medical intervention and that
includes any music immunizations
um this bill is fairly simple well it's
one simple paragraph however it's a
far-reaching bill
um but i i would say that this bill has
something for everybody
um that by establishing this principle
um we we look at liberty right the right
of an individual person have bodily
integrity i control my body
so if you believe in that that you have
individual freedoms and and it extends
to your body then you have something if
you're a proponent of my body my choice
then you have there's something here for
you as well
that you get to choose what happens to
your body and the state cannot mandate
uh some uh that you do any kind of
medical procedure and and furthermore
you can't be discriminated against for
this bill was brought forward i serve on
jal carmen my third term in the house
i'm serving my third term on job car and
last year we saw uh last year here
before i don't really call it be honest
with you i think was last year
we saw a rule being brought forward
through dhhs that would require
in order to be foster parents
when the question of religious freedom
came up or individual choice came up
the department basically said it doesn't
matter
um and i felt this was and that the
parents wouldn't qualify to be a foster
parent
um now i can understand in certain
circumstances where you may have a
foster child who might be have some um
compromised immunization system i mean
yeah i can say the word apologize um
immediately compromised immunity and
therefore you may want to put them with
parents who are
um
vaccinated however in this case that
wasn't even the case this was going to
be a blanket statement and some
religions and some people truly are
either they can't do their religious
preference have uh immunizations or by
their personal choice can have
immunizations and if they qualify in any
other way for a state program that
program with the exception of this
immunization based on either their
choice or their religious
beliefs
they would be allowed to have a foster
child but because of their religious
beliefs now they're being exempted from
and discriminated against by the state
and not allowed to be foster parents and
i found this to be reprehensible and and
inconceivable be honest with you a more
nuanced bill was deaf or more nuanced
rule was needed but it was passed and
that's the law that's the regulation now
and i felt that we should not be doing
that so i brought this bill forward um
there's gonna be lots of people i'm sure
that want to talk including uh uh
assistant commissioner tilly who i know
very well for my work on the reopening
task force
um
but i'll leave you with this
we can yeah about this bill to death and
what if this bill to death
but the bottom line is do you believe
that an individual has the right to
choose
what they get poked with what they cut
open with that and that the state can
never mandate
um or force a medical uh procedure on an
individual or you don't it comes down to
that
um and i i believe that i have the right
or every individual state in hampshire
has the right to make that choice and
that the state if i choose whatever
medical procedure i want which or not
choose that procedure the state can't
discriminate against me
again
i'll leave a lot of the questions for
anybody else but i'll answer any
questions anybody may have but i believe
this is a fundamental
right
um of bodily integrity
i mean we require police officers to get
search warrants to search people houses
and yet we're gonna allow the state to
mandate uh what you do medically i i
think that's wrong and i think that um
this bill would correct that problem and
make sure it never is a problem in our
in our in our great state of new
hampshire i'm happy to take any
questions
i
left my
in the car whereby i normally get
appraised as to what members of the
committee wish to ask a question so i'm
going to rely on
representative weber to tell me who of
the committee has a hand up
okay well um representative weber was
first
followed by i'm hoping you're writing
this down representative clerk
representative shapiro
representative woods representative
cannon
and the chair first calls on
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you very
much representative for taking my
question
i absolutely agree that everybody has
the right to control what happens to
their body what about my right if i am
hiring somebody
to come and look after me during an
illness i'm hiring a part-time employee
um
it appears to me that this bill would it
not bar
my saying that the person who comes to
look after me who might look after other
people in their homes as well
has to have a vaccination before they
before i hire them
so if your question is does this extend
into private industry the answer is
written yes it does that wasn't my
intent of the bill and i did it did come
to me and i'm i'm happy to help and work
with anybody on the amendment my intent
was to borrow the state
from uh mandating um and and
discriminating individual businesses i
think have the right to determine their
own hiring practices and should um again
a a as a business i especially see this
in a healthcare field where if i was
working in a cancer ward
then having immunizations would be
extremely important so i believe the
business has the right my justification
to be able to do that however i don't
think the state has the right i should
not have to have a a special card to
show up to dmv to get my driver's
license because the state mandated
something i'm more concerned about the
state mandating my participation in in
society rather than i am the individual
businesses individual business will be
taken care of through the free market
practice and employment practices of a
business makes an employment practice
that a majority of people disagree with
no one's going to go work for that
business the business will adjust its
practices so i'd be happy to work with
anybody on an amendment um to clean this
to make it so it's more clear that this
is intended that the state cannot
mandate um any kind of medical
intervention
thank you
representative canark
representative weber just asked
precisely the question i was going to
ask and it's been well answered so i
withdraw thank you representative
shapiro
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative um
likewise you partially answered my
original question but i have another
if the intention of your bill
[Music]
is not directed at businesses
how would this play out with school
districts or private schools or day
cares
who feel that it's in everyone's best
interest
mandate vaccinations for children who
are attending
thank you representative spiro for that
question again so currently it's kind of
a this is a i want to call a chicken and
egg but i'm not sure what else to call
it um currently we have certain mandated
mandated vaccines for a public school
however we also have a complete
exemption process
that allows parents to exempt out of
that so we in theory don't have a
mandated vaccine program
most vaccinations are given my
understanding i got four kids and some
are my my wife controls the vaccinations
and she's believed in some didn't
believe in others
so we occasionally had to sign the form
that said that our children were not
vaccinated um and allowed them to attend
uh
but i guess what i'm gonna say to you is
again we most decisions to vaccinate are
done at an early age i think majority of
the vaccines are given under the age of
three not at the age of school
um and so i i don't know that this will
have any impact on the percentage of
people that get vaccinated i don't think
any parent when the kids 2 says oh i
need to send my kid to public schools so
i'm going to get them vaccinated they
get a vaccination they get vaccinated
based on their conversation with their
doctor it's a choice it's the decision
between the parent and the doctor having
that discussion and and we have a high
rate of uh of
uh i'll use the word compliance i'm not
sure the word to use
but we have a high degree of
vaccinations in the state of new
hampshire and i don't expect that to
change even if this bill passes
follow up
so just to be clear that
um your the intention of this bill is
not
given that there's an exemption for
schools
vaccinations for students in schools
your intention is not to change that but
my intention is to make sure the state
can't mandate vaccines
uh or actually my intent is any medical
procedure um that the state cannot step
in i'm trying to future proof this bill
a little bit
because i don't like coming back and
tweaking bills if we can help it um
but my uh my intention is to future
proof this bill and say any medical
intervention state can't mandate um and
again uh there's nothing wrong with the
um
with the school district asking for
immunization records so they know who's
vaccinating who's not if they choose to
um but again i i don't necessarily think
we need to mandate this and i don't
think a mandate would change the
percentage of acts which children get
vaccinated or not
thank you
representative woods
uh thank you mr chair uh my questions
have been answered thank you
privacy my machine didn't want to unmute
um
i'm a school board member and we just
recently worked on our policies
and
the
schools actually have
have a requirement for vex providing
information about vaccines this this
bill talks about discrimination i'm
wondering if
just as we have today that they're
special
plans to separate students to make sure
they adhere to the social distancing
guidelines
would that be considered discrimination
i'm not sure i understand your question
um representative cannon but but if i if
i can answer it the way i think yeah and
uh got it
was i don't think it's any different
than a peanut allergy right so yet when
you have a child in a classroom with
peanut analogy there are certain
controls that are put on
and that's not discriminatory that's
that's that's related so
um i i guess
i i would i would align it with a peanut
allergy i guess your answer but
um i i'm still not quite clear on your
question
follow up give it another go
let me do it this way um given that in
the case of the covid it's it's passed
by
um
through the air through
water droplets whereas a pain analogy
would be
someone who ingests something that's
analogy
in our schools currently we're placing
students six feet apart and there's a
piece of plexiglas in between
the seating to protect other students in
the room
so
if a student
is not vaccinated ultimately when
they're available
would it be discrimination
to have a section within the classroom
that is separated from the other
students who have been vaccinated or
have yet to be vaccinated because of a
scheduling issues
thank you representative for your
question and i guess i'd answer it in
i'm going to say no it's not again if
you're following science and the school
district is following science and you've
got your plexiglass and you got your
masks and you got your social distancing
then whether a child vaccinated or not
doesn't have a whole lot of uh to do
with it does it um if you're following
all the other protocols so while
vaccination is a component it's not the
only component we'll hear from tris
tilly later and as i hear on a regular
basis
that um none of these uh answers are a
silver bullet um i think we've read that
vaccines even even now they're talking
about either variants or they're talking
about the fact that you can still even
with the vaccine get covered a second
time
and so again relative to the specific um
virus that's going around um i i don't i
again if you
trust julia talk about multi-layer
threat protection um and that again if
you're following all the multi-layers
and you miss one but you've got the
other five then you're still pretty safe
so i would say yeah
again i i would i would consider it if
you were starting to create the haves
thank you mr chairman but my answer has
been
or my question has been answered thank
you representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
representative
um can you tell me do we currently
implement in public schools any other
kind of separation
between
children who have
some vaccine exemption and those who do
not
for any other diseases that are that
vaccines are
required for
sure having served in the school board
for six years i can tell you that my
school we've never implemented anything
i have a question for the prime sponsor
i remember
when
schools mandated vaccines
they were basically five or six or so
specific back vaccines that
all schools had
and some of them have gone on and i
understand
20 or 30 things some of which
people think some people think are
dubious
um
would you be comfortable with the school
mandating the traditional five or six
uh as long as they did not go beyond
those
i'll leave that to the medical experts
to have that discussion again i i don't
think we should be meant the state
should be mandating what i put my body
with or any child pokes their body but
the parents are the best arbiter of the
medical care of their children
you know in consultation with their
medical providers
and that the state's not the best
arbiter telling me what i have to do
my follow-up is
it seems to me that around the country
not just in new hampshire the whole
question of who educates our children is
now up for discussion again and
charter schools which are a kind of
public school but private schools are
have been operating during the pandemic
in a way different from many public
schools would it be acceptable to you to
let the public schools continue to
mandate while other schooling options
for
have become more or could become more
affordable would that be an acceptable
thing to you
again if the private school is acting as
a private industry as the right to do
and choose as it will uh and let it let
it manage its own student body the way
it chooses to um again this is about the
state mandating something that covers
1.35 million people in the state of new
hampshire
and i
representative is there anyone else um
representative weber from this committee
who wishes to ask a question yes there
is mr chairman i have representative
nelson followed by representative conner
thank you representative nelson please
thank you mr chairman but just like to
know who is discriminated against is the
student that's coming in
or those that are in school
so somebody has a condition
that could compromise somebody is it
being discriminatory discriminated yeah
you know what i mean discriminate
against the student who's trying to come
in because they don't want to tell
or the student that's in school that
doesn't want to get what they could be
bringing in
thank you for your question
representative nelson again my my
my issue was around the um
and discrimination
may be the wrong word that was put in
there it's not the word i used when when
i gave to olss but they stuffed in there
my intention was that you can't be
denied access to any state programs or
state um activities again this is about
the state you know if you go back to
some basic constitutional laws and you
learn that the idea behind the
constitution was to limit what the state
can do not limit what the individuals
can do and so if you believe that that
this is a constitutional issue and this
is about limiting
the state and not limiting limiting what
people can do so
my goal was not to have a person
discriminated from uh participating in
state programs and functions
thank you
you're
yes thank you um
okay i i was going to withdraw my
questions that was quite similar to
representative nelson's but now i am
more confused than i was before
um because we just had a long discussion
about schools and whether they could
require vaccinations
and now you're saying just state but
since schools many of them public
schools are run by governmental entities
as in the towns
in cities it seems like we need to
clarify that language quite a bit
because my concern rests as
representative nelson's that we are
discriminating against the child who
cannot be vaccinated from coming to
school and participating fully if they
are in danger of catching any number of
diseases besides covet measles and other
things it all has to do with public
health and herd immunity so
would you be also welcome then to an
amendment which would say
somehow that it's only state programs
that schools uh can discriminate would
that be a comfortable amendment for you
well i i've been uncomfortable making a
statement that schools can discriminate
um but
in the context of what we're saying here
so again i guess i would i
i would say that if there's just cause
so again if we talked about the fact
that hospitals and people have
compromised immunity so if the school
was had an issue with student that had a
compromised immunity then it may be able
to do certain things that it wouldn't be
able to do otherwise
but again it has justification in that
in with the child but um
again
it's up to health and human services how
they want to amend this bill i my big
amendment that my big discussion point
was that my intention was not to push
this out to individual
um businesses in the community this is
about the state going back to that
constitutional argument the state cannot
mandate and and on its population that
it's a control on the state not a
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
uh representative lang
with this bill um
would this protect against
discrimination for accepting medical
interventions such as
using medical marijuana
yes
thank you any further members of the
committee wish to ask a question
yes i have a question from
representative nutter oppam and i'm
going to request
representative knurk to lower his
virtual hand if he's all set
uh so rep it's representative nutter up
him only and representative knicks okay
at this point representative
thank you for taking my question
um
so i'm in favor of half of this bill
and i've received you know
not quite hundreds of letters from
people who saying they shouldn't be
forced to take an injection
um
and i believe i believe in that kind of
freedom however
the second half uh lines five through
six no person may be discriminated
against her refusal to accept an
unwanted medical intervention including
immunizations so you
kind of stated before you'd be open for
an amendment um
and so i of course would not want to go
into a hospital where none of the nurses
or doctors were immunized so if you want
to clear up that language and an
amendment to
um
take out
this
differentiate between the state part and
individual businesses
i might consider voting for it
thank you representative i i will happy
to look at that um again that wasn't my
intention to do that but i will say that
even right now you have no idea who's
who has vaccinations or not when you go
into a hospital right you have you have
no idea whether i i have i have oh may i
follow up with uh
yeah i mean because i worked in
hospitals and of course i was required
to at least get a tb test every year and
they of course offered i mean so
i
yeah they didn't have my immunization
record but there were certain
diseases such like tb that they had
rules around so everyone who worked at
the hospital had to have the tb test
every year and the flu vaccine was
offered not forced but offered so
anyway
it's a complicated business and
you know there's typhoid mary's out
there we want to be careful absolutely
uh representative up up
another up i agree and again if the
individual business choose to and with
the tb test is is reasonable um
again i don't see people running away
from that but
again this is about what you're
injecting into your body um and and i'd
be con and not only that again any
medical intervention um and and worried
about discrimination or
lack of access again i i never want to
see a situation where the state can
mandate something and say you can't go
to dmv and get your license unless you
got a certain card that says you got
this done
just be bad again but we should not be
mandating on our individual citizens
thank you representative lang
representative
weber is there anyone else
representative woods has his hand up
representative woods
oh thank you mr chair and uh thank you
representative lang for taking my
question uh just uh uh uh following up
uh with uh representative uh nutter
upham's uh question relative to
hospitals uh the state run runs a
hospital
at the the state hospital for
psychiatric care
uh this would preclude the state
from following um the mandates in other
hospitals
of
prevent them from mandating
appropriate
immunizations especially given the
well
again
we're going back to the covid
conversation and again i don't think any
nurse at any hospital is mandated to
have the covert vaccine it's offered as
we heard um
another
uh talk about that again she worked in
the hospital they didn't mandate
vaccines they made them offered and
available to any nurse or any first
responder that wants it wants them and
even in the state of new hampshire we
current we don't mandate our first
responders get the copit vaccine we make
it available to them and many have
chosen i expect that this isn't going to
have a major change on um
the vaccination rates within the state
of new hampshire i just want it clear
that people have if they choose not to
get it that's okay and that's their
choice and that if the state can't
mandate and then definitely not down the
road mandate that you only participate
in certain state functions if you did
that
um that
bothers me that that's a possibility and
i don't want to see that
thank you representative lang anyone
else from the committee with that i see
no further hands mr chairman thank you
very much i will next call as as our
custom any uh elected officials and i
recognize representative juliet harvey
bolia
to speak and i would ask everyone
henceforth pleased to be brief
i do not see uh the representative in
the
list uh representative harvey bullio if
you are there could you please raise
and i don't fear either
the chair recognizes representative
hello can you hear me
yes yes oh thank you for taking my
question mr chairman um i'm going to
keep this very brief
uh medical freedom is the right to
bodily autonomy i can't think of a more
fundamental a right than the right to
govern your own body
i also can't believe that this is
something that we need to codify because
to quote john locke
every man has a property in his own
person
this nobody has a right to but
himself yet it does seem to be necessary
to list this freedom when a government
forces a medical procedure of any type
they've largely eliminated informed
consent which is a violation of medical
ethics in conclusion i urge you all to
vote ought to pass to begin the process
of enumerating this most essential and
i don't see any hands up mr chairman
thank you very much the
chair now recognizes beth daley from the
department of health and human services
good morning uh representative pearson
and members of the committee sorry about
that it took a minute for them to unmute
me my name is beth daley and i'm the
chief of the bureau of infectious
disease control here at the new
hampshire department of health and human
services
i'm here today to provide testimony in
opposition to house bill 220
immunization as you all know is
considered one of the most important
public health achievements of the last
century it's prevented millions of
illnesses disabilities and deaths here
in the united states but despite the
success we know that not everyone gets
vaccinated vaccination coverage is not
100 percent
nor are most vaccines 100 percent
effective so these outbreaks of vaccine
preventable diseases can still occur
when an unvaccinated person becomes
infected and introduces that disease
into a community especially one that has
low vaccination rates
it is therefore critical that certain
requirements for immunization remain in
place such as those that pertain to
employment and health care settings and
those for school in child care entry as
well
these requirements are in place for
immunization to prevent the spread of
communicable disease to protect our most
vulnerable residents
as one example that you've already
discussed some healthcare facilities
require employee vaccination to protect
the lives of their very vulnerable
patients
such as requiring influenza vaccine to
prevent outbreaks in long-term care
facilities where residents can die if
they become infected with with influenza
all hospitals in our state have policies
requiring influenza vaccination for
their staff
now some do allow for certain exemptions
such as for medical or religious reasons
while others only allow medical
exemptions these policies have increased
vaccination rates among our health care
workers from less than 60 percent
choosing to voluntarily get vaccinated
to going above 95 to about 95 i should
say
so if you do eliminate these policies
vaccination rates will without question
decrease substantially
an additional setting of concern that
you've also spoken to
our schools and child care facilities
under rsa 141c 20a
this provides the department with the
authority to require
certain vaccinations prior to school and
child care entry
all states in the united states have
these requirements and many states have
even tightened their laws following
large outbreaks of infectious diseases
that were driven by decreasing
vaccination vaccination rates this is a
major problem in 2019 as one example
there were over 1200 cases of measles in
31 states across the country that was
driven by low vaccination rates
now as you pointed out not all vaccines
recommended for children are required
for school and child care entry we
always balance public health protection
with individual choice and so we only
require those that are most essential
and likely to be transmitted in this
setting
these requirements are developed with
public input through the administrative
rules process
despite our high childhood vaccination
rates here in new hampshire we continue
to have thousands of cases and outbreaks
of vaccine preventable diseases
just that's data from the last decade
so and lastly just to point out that
people do have a choice they do not have
to be vaccinated they only need to be
vaccinated if they want to participate
in certain activities where there is
impact to others who are vulnerable and
they need protection from infectious
diseases relaxing requirements for
immunization will lead to preventable
disability and death and result in
significant harm to our population and
as such the department strongly opposes
house bill 220 and i'm i thank you for
the opportunity to testify and i'm happy
to address any questions you might have
are there any questions representative
cushman
uh thank you mr chairman um is it dr
beth daly sorry
yes i'm a doctor of public health okay
thank you can i ask is there proof that
outbreaks of
these communicable diseases are due to
unvaccinated children
in schools and because consider many
people who get the measles for example
from these outbreaks i know we're
vaccinated
thank you for that question may i
respond
chairman yes
so in the outbreak that i referenced in
2019 90 of those individuals who
were in part of that outbreak were
unvaccinated so no the data shows that
um that people who are unvaccinated are
primarily affected however because
these vaccines are not 100 effective
there are always people who even though
they have making made that good choice
of getting vaccinated are still impacted
follow up
um can you explain to me your reasoning
for believing that hb 220 would reduce
yes because it's our experience and we
have data that shows that when you
implement policies requiring vaccination
one more
so you're saying
that when we force people through
changes in law
where they have no choice but to get
vaccinated that that increases
vaccination rates
yes
thank you
is there anyone else in the committee mr
chairman i'm pleased to say that
representative marsh is with us
and has his hand raised well
representative marsh
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
let everyone know that i am now present
and to be compliant with 91a i am at
home alone in my home office in
brookfield and there's no one currently
in the room
thank you
and for the record representative gay is
present here
in the committee room
anyone with a question from the
committee for dr daley representative
gay thank you mr chairman and thank you
dr daley for taking my question
um i'm curious as to
how y'all are handling moderna's
statement their top doctor is saying
that uh we cannot
uh we cannot say that it's effective at
preventing people
from uh getting sick
and
spreading it it's it's um yeah modern
abbas i'll just read the
headline modern abbas says covet shot
not proven to stop viral spread
what it's saying is that it's supposed
to make you not get sick
so that my concern is
uh
that you know i'm also an adherent to uh
bodily
the right to one's own
medical uh decisions
and uh i personally was vaccinated and
received
shots like dpt as a kid but i got about
five before i started first grade now 75
are recommended and offered that's a big
difference
thank you so much if i may i answer was
that the end i'm sorry the format just
okay i will answer then um so
first of all um
actually so cdc recommends that children
get vaccinated against 16 diseases now
when you take into the number the number
of doses in this particular series to be
fully vaccinated that's where you come
up with those 75 doses but actually
because the way they manufacture
vaccines and they have you know improved
their technology over time you're
actually getting less antigen injected
into your body than in um you know prior
years right they've been proved the way
that these vaccines work over time and
then to your question about the moderna
vaccine
what the distinction is there is
actually that it's 95
effective at protecting you from
developing covid19 that is very highly
effective and we're very pleased by that
it's going to protect you as the person
who's received the vaccine what they're
still studying is whether that means
that you whether that means you can
potentially have the virus if you get
exposed go up into your nose and into
your mouth and um
the vaccine doesn't prevent that virus
from being in those spaces
it prevents you from getting sick but
that but is it possible for that virus
to be there and that you could spread it
to other people even though you're not
sick right because we know that this
virus is very interesting
disease that's made it very challenging
that you can develop asymptomatic
infection and transmit it to other
people so that's what they're trying to
study and it's a distinction it's
absolutely protective for you if you're
vaccinated they're still studying
whether or not it can be transmitted
though from you even though you're
vaccinated to other individuals so
hopefully that makes sense how i've
described that it's a little bit of a
complicated topic and one that they're
follow-up
because that is exactly my point though
that we're we're discussing
it sounds like please correct me if i'm
interpreting this incorrectly
it sounds like we are concerned
about mandating it
mandating the covet shots
because we don't want to spread it
whereas
my point and question is
if we're not sure
that it's prevent spreading then what's
the harm of letting people
opt to not take it and just take their
chances which
sound pretty good with other medicines
like ivermectin
well i'm not sure that we're talking
about mandating covet 19 vaccine
currently the state's position is that
we have no intention of mandating
covenanting vaccines so if you're if
you're interested in applying that to
other vaccines we do already know that
other the rest of the vaccines are very
effective at preventing transmission and
covid19 vaccine is also effective at
preventing transmission they're still
studying some features of that can they
say it's 100 effective
no but we know from science that
whenever you're symptomatic with a
disease you're going to spread that
disease more readily because the virus
particles are coming out of your nose
and mouth as you cough and sneeze so
even if people who are vaccinated have
the virus inside their nose and in mouth
they're much less likely to spread it
because they're not actively sick
coughing and sneezing those virus
particles around now is
they can they still transmit it perhaps
that's what's being studied you can't
say 100 that they won't but it's they
the majority of people will not and
that's
very makes it very effective
thank you
is there anyone else from the committee
who has not asked a question of dr daley
acton
yes representative acting
uh thank you mr chair and uh thank you
dr daley for taking my question
uh my question is regarding the
uh
our natural immune systems um certainly
there's there's vitamins and and
a lot of techniques to improve our
natural immune systems my worry is that
the reliance on
so many vaccines
could be
damaging our natural immune systems do
you do you have any um
knowledge of of the reliance on vaccines
where it may be reducing
our our natural
ability to fight off things like the flu
in in which case we're we're heading
down
not a positive road by being relaxed so
reliant on vaccines
so thank you for that question that's a
great question and one question we've
certainly been asked so remember that
your body is actually confronted with
millions of bacteria and viruses every
single day so your body has the
opportunity to develop lots of natural
immunity to all kinds of different
bacteria that live
in our environment that we're exposed to
on a regular basis these are not the
ones that we vaccinate against for so no
you um there is no impact regarding that
these vaccines have prevented millions
of illnesses and deaths um since they've
been you know invented and
okay thank you
representative king
thank you mr chairman and thank you dr
daley for taking my question
is preventing people to attend school as
an example
or to travel on an airplane as an
example potential example
so i'm not quite sure i understand the
question we that is we do have mandatory
vaccination requirements for school and
child care entry
um we there's no requirements for
boarding an airplane nor do we have any
intention of developing those
follow up follow-up
so there's been talk about uh with the
covid
vaccine in particular
of um
having to have a vaccination
record with you when you board a
plane that to me sounds like mandating
i'm not aware of any conversations in
new hampshire around that subject if
you're talking about nationally i can't
speak to the national policy that's
being discussed on uh travel
requirements or if those are being
implemented by you know
by private companies but again um people
still have a choice they're not being
required to receive
a vaccine if they don't want one there
just might be implications from that
decision so that they don't put other
people at risk for not choosing to be
vaccinated
thank you anyone else from the committee
i see no one mr chairman thank you dr
daly uh there is someone else from
health and human services
uh miss tilly i believe is is
here and and has
um
been
admitted as a patent list good morning
chair and members of the committee thank
you thanks for uh patricia tilly
good morning chair um i think i'm
unmuted
yes you are great thank you so much
thank you again my name is patricia
tilley i'm the deputy director of the
division of public health services here
at the department of health and human
services i only want to underscore dr
daley's testimony and remind the
committee that we also share
representative lang's intention that
indeed individuals should generally have
choice and informed consent but dhhs
opposes this bill due to the broad
language that may have a negative impact
in particular the broad use of the word
discrimination raises questions as we've
heard about school and child care
vaccine requirements private industry
health care settings it may also have
implications far beyond communicable
disease
it should be noted that the communicable
disease statutes in new hampshire
protect and support individuals to make
choices for example 141 c 20 c
provides opportunity for religious
exemptions
but our laws also protect individuals
from the decisions of others as noted
vaccine requirements protect those who
are compromised
but since much of this conversation has
focused on vaccine i just want to close
with the notion that vaccine gives your
family freedom freedom for elderly
patients to go to the store without fear
freedom for your children to learn in
the way that works best for them and
freedom for your spouse to work without
the fear of bringing illness into the
home
for my time on the reopening task force
i've learned vaccines also make good
business sense a vaccinated workforce is
not only healthier and more productive
but allows employers to focus on their
business freeing employees from
quarantine and travel restrictions at
times
the concern dhhs has with this
particular bill is the broad use of the
word discrimination we believe that this
may open us up to unintended
consequences so thank you
and i will defer my time thank you
yes representative pearson
we will now be taking questions from the
general public and we will go to the one
minute rule
this is a rule that has been established
not just this year but in the past
when there are multiple multiple people
wishing to testify
and it is the position of the house of
representatives that the citizens have a
right to be heard
it is also the case
that we have to do an awful lot of work
in an abbreviated amount of time
so therefore when i call on somebody
from the general public you will have
one minute to speak
at the end of the one minute you will be
muted and i will call the next person
this is as i said an ongoing policy and
it is for situations like this
the chair calls from the general public
i do not see her in the list
if you uh miss edwards if you do
if you are online could you please raise
your hand
i'm working off the list christina that
i was just given about a half an hour
ago i'm starting on page one at the
okay i do not see ms edwards thank you
hello this is eric power can you hear me
yes we can thank you go ahead yes this
is eric power i'm a 26-year resident of
brookline i've also served as a school
board member for the hollis brookline
cooperative school district for three
years
and um i am very concerned about
mandatory vaccines and i do not believe
that i i'm in support of this bill
because i believe that vaccines should
not be made mandatory
for
anyone in the state i think that
everybody's bodies is their own the
children
decisions for them need to be made by
the parents
and
vaccines you know there is risk there
there's been you know there's there's
there's some safety problems with some
vaccines and so with there is where
there is risk there needs to be a choice
and so i would recommend passage of this
bill
recommend ought to pass
because i think it's very important for
new hampshire to maintain its live free
or die
motto and to maintain our personal
liberties thank you very much thank you
and well done
hello can you hear me okay yes we can
okay thank you
my name is maria nardi i'm a resident of
hollis new hampshire um i did provide an
email testimony i'll just read it so
because i need to be brief um so just
wanted to point out that you know i've
never been against vaccinations uh we've
all had our vaccinations in this family
but i am completely against any
mandating of any vaccination especially
the one for covert 19 which i understand
is is not you know considered to be
mandatory but
um
so vaccines you know they come with um
there's always a health benefit risk
there so you have to weigh the health um
benefits versus the risks and for you
know a vaccine like covid19 which you
know the data from the cdc by and large
you know clearly shows that is it is not
um a a dangerous virus for you know
healthy
people under the age of 60 60. i have
supporting evidence for this if you if
you need it um it's in um in the email
that i uh the email testimony that i put
forth
um also uh this has been listener what's
up you should have been muted
can you hear me
yes
you can hear me thank you my family and
i just moved to this beautiful state we
came here from new york in september
because a half a year and a half ago new
york removed the religious exemption and
my son was kicked out of school along
with 26 000 other children
we moved to new hampshire seeking
freedom and the ability to make health
decisions for our family without the
state forcing us to submit to medical
procedures that we don't want
new new hampshire stands as a beacon of
freedom and we fled here because we
believe the live free or die state will
stand up to tyranny and defend and
respect everyone's right to make their
own medical decisions about their own
bodies regardless of their political
affiliation or personal beliefs as a
registered nurse i understand the
science and what i know to be true is
that science is ever evolving at one
point we were told by science that
cigarettes were beneficial that ddt
should be sprayed directly on the skin
of children that vioxx was safe
this latest shot according to the
manufacturers themselves is still in the
thank you very much uh the chair calls
good morning members of the committee my
name is dr david strang i am an
emergency physician with 32 years of
practice experience
one of the most basic tenets of the
practice of medicine is that of informed
consent informed consent think about
what that simple phrase means we as
health care providers inform the sick
the injured the patient and they give
give us their consent to proceed or not
to
in the process of providing informed
consent we are obligated to present the
patient with the risks and benefits of
the treatment whether it be a medication
a surgical procedure or any intervention
to which they are being asked to consent
even immunizations
if after being presented with those
risks and benefits they decline the
treatment that is their inviolate right
as human beings government plays no role
in this decision
if you dare to vote no on this bill you
are by default voting yay to eventually
allowing a big brother police state one
where there is no individual freedom no
right to self-determination and one
where there is no control over your own
body
dr strang now the chair calls dr randy
hayes
can you hear me all right you can
thank you i am a family doctor 35 years
retired and 25 years the founding chair
of the concord hospital's ethics
committee
immunizations are one of the crown
jewels of science-based medicine
between 94 and 2013 730 000 deaths of
children and 21 million hospitalizations
prevented
there is a long history of u.s courts
allowing states to legally mandate
particular vaccines for particular
populations where there exists
overwhelming public health risk i along
with the medical society strongly oppose
hb 220 which overs over emphasizes
privacy rights of a person
at the expense of minimizing compelling
public health benefits of such treatment
it is not a state versus individual
right it is working through the
complexities of modern living thank you
thank you dr hayes
the chair calls christine stoddard from
who is identified as a lobbyist from the
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee
for the record my name is christine
stoddard and i work for bi-state primary
care association
we advocate for expanded access to
health care services and also represent
community health centers
across the state of new hampshire and
vermont
i would like to echo what dr daley said
and what patricia tilly said and also
focus particularly on
the discrimination aspect of this bill
sorry i was just walking in my office
and i'm out of breath
um when healthcare
community health centers are required to
follow cdc recommendations on
immunizations and have policies on those
if one of their employees chooses not to
vaccinate or to receive a vaccination
they might be required to wear
additional ppe
or stop their clinical work does this
mean that they would be discriminated
against by their employer and i think
that's an unanswered question in this
bill that would be important to address
and also
i would echo their concerns on the
state's facility licensing requirements
on pb testing and
thank you very much dr eric schestler it
hello can you hear me we can thank you
yes i'm dr eric sethler i'm a general
pediatrician that works in manchester
i'm also the president for the american
academy of pediatrics um and we strongly
oppose this bill um for a lot of the
same reasons dr daley had mentioned
previously i'm one of the individuals
that gets to give out a lot of these
vaccines and we do a great deal of
informed consent with families and
families who ultimately have the
decision with regards to what happens to
their kids
but we do want to protect everybody and
i want to offer that protection to
everybody consistently and i have a
large population of kids who can't get
immunized and the best way for us to
protect those kids who can't get
immunized for various health reasons is
to make sure that as a population we are
doing everything we can to keep
everybody as vaccinated as we can and we
know any laws that decrease or
improve
or i should say expand the non-medical
exemptions decreases immunization rates
thank you dr schestler
i believe he's already spoken
perhaps that was the last bill let me
bring him on and see thank you
the chair is recognizing dr wendy
gladstone
you you have dr hayes on mr chairman
yes
dr hayes i'm afraid has spoken before
he's listed here
twice so we're moving on to dr wendy
gladstone yes good morning my name is dr
wendy gladstone i live in exeter i'm a
retired pediatrician and former
president of the new hampshire chapter
of the american academy of pediatrics i
am speaking today on behalf of the
chapters membership which consists of
hundreds of board certified
pediatricians from acro across the state
as dr schestler our current president
mentioned we strongly oppose house bill
220 for many of the reasons already
given
i would like people to think about
medical freedom as freedom for children
who are unable to be vaccinated to be
protected from contagious diseases which
are spread by unvaccinated other
children
of course nobody in the state wants to
be able to demand whatever medical
procedures they like
but there are some situations in the
preservation of the public health where
requiring vaccinations is essential and
passing house bill 220 will weaken our
current situation
which is to have a very robust vaccine
program to protect our children thank
you thank you
yes thank you mr chairman
my name is thomas mccloud i'm a resident
of mount vernon
i'm the chair of the liberty defense
fund in new hampshire and a member of
the leadership group of health freedom
in new hampshire mr chairman in 2019
our family left our home state and moved
to new hampshire in search of medical
freedom
we support this bill i have prepared
more extensive remarks on the ethical
principle of informed consent but due to
the one-minute restriction i will now
submit my prepared remarks as written
testimony thank you
thank you sir
if you are online could you please raise
i don't see here online
the chair recognizes irena walsh
[Music]
i do not see miss walsh
the chair recognizes paulina sayes
your email address ends in md so i
i do not see miss a.s
hello can you hear me now yes we can
okay
my name is laura kanya and i'm from
bedford and i'm a volunteer advocate
with the national vaccine information
center and i work to educate be a
resource and advocate as needed and i
support the informed consent ethic and i
support this bill
i note that there is no mention by dhhs
of the risk or harm from vaccines but we
know
that through the vaccine injury
compensation program then over 4.5
billion dollars has been paid out to
those injured and killed by vaccines
there are now reports coming in of
adverse effects of covert vaccination
including 501 deaths including one of a
44 year old new hampshire woman there is
also serious injury and illness
following covered vaccinations reported
by the cdc including higher rate of
appendicitis
heart attacks and strokes
the beers report is essential um part of
reporting these vaccine injuries i call
on everyone to fulfill their obligation
we do have immune systems the evidence
of mild or no symptoms and the majority
of those infected with covenants covet
is evidence of natural immune systems at
work
thank you miss garden
i do not see miss
tatenov
the chair recognizes holly stevens a
good morning chairman can you hear me
yes i can thank you uh uh good morning
uh dear chairman and members of the
committee um
my name is holly stevens i'm the health
policy coordinator at new futures i will
let you read more about new futures in
my written testimony to
save some time
um new futures uh is testifying today in
opposition to house bill 220.
um you've heard a lot of uh
discussion from doctors and
dr daley from the department regarding
why
mandating vaccinations in certain
situations is so important
i do just want to caution you that this
bill as introduced is very
wide um you know and covers a lot and
could have a lot of unintended
consequences and with that i'll conclude
my uh oral testimony and you can ask
me any questions if they come up as
you're contemplating this thank you very
much
and finally on my list we have holly
ruoko
i do not see ms rocco
christina do you have any late signers
i do have some hands uh i do actually
see rebecca kischinevsky whom you had
already called but if she appears to be
online now
all right i didn't quite hear the name
rebecca kischinevsky
okay the chair recognizes rebecca
kushnevsky
thank you so much i appreciate
your time and consideration
our family also moved here recently from
new york state we moved to this
beautiful country this beautiful state
for
increased freedom and the only preordai
state and i just want to say that it's
so vital when there is any risk involved
that they're being formed to consent we
learn this the hard way through world
war ii and in other times and spaces
in history and
just really call upon new hampshire to
be leaders to empower the state of new
york and new hampshire excuse me to be
able to
make informed consent for our own selves
and our children and trust in the
individuals to do the right thing for
our families and for one another
thank you
thank you is there anyone else
yes we have
marie ramos from the new hampshire
medical society
thank you very much
thank you mr chair
my name is dr marie elizabeth ramos i am
a family physician that's been
practicing full scope family medicine
including surgical obstetrics for almost
a dozen years now
through my career and in with the
medical society we are speaking in
opposition of this bill
and partly because of what has been said
but i'd like to add additional
commentary
one i want the i would like the
committee to be aware of the difference
between
personal
personal choices
regarding
non-necessary procedures versus public
health
necessities that have been shown to
prove to save lives i would like to
quote the world health organization
that says that quote in 2018 about 86
percent of the world's children receive
vaccines that would protect them
against polio diphtheria tetanus
pertussis measles immunizations
currently prevent two to three million
deaths per year despite the success
however more than 1.5 million people
worldwide die from vaccine preventable
thank you very much is there anyone else
i have christine mcpherson
yes the chair calls her and she has one
minute
hello can you hear me
yes
hi thank you um with one minute i have
i'd like to share that i also move my
family from new york state as i
understand this bill um it is about not
whether vaccines are effective or um
useful for public health but about
whether the state has the right to
impose their will and you as a group of
legislators have a very difficult
position right now you don't have the
right to make a medical choice for me my
family or anyone else in the state of
new hampshire you only have a right to
inform
public health
practices and decisions which take a
variety
of
a variety of forms not just vaccination
so
we could argue for days and days about
whether vaccines are wonderful and
effective but the point is is should you
as a legislator decide for other people
please do the right thing and don't try
to decide for other families
i can tell you from my own devastating
experience i had three top doctors in
new york state new york city behind my
family and it didn't make a damn bit of
difference and i lost everything
everything my home my mother my
community everything please don't put
yourself between doctors and children
and families and parents and schools and
jobs and income please i beg you
thank you christine is there anyone else
uh i have wendy
the chair calls wendy and first start by
letting us know whether you're for or
against the bill and then you have one
minute
thank you can you hear me again
okay i strongly approve of this bill i'm
hearing a lot of big corporations and
organizations opposing this bill and and
while i appreciate everyone getting a
voice to their opinion there is no data
or science that you can present to me
that can convince me that anyone has my
loved ones best interests and mine more
than me
so i urge you to approve this bill this
is not about our choice of vaccinations
this is about our freedom it's about our
choice to make our own choices and
nothing else
i appreciate your time today and i
strongly urge that you approve this bill
uh i don't see anyone else we do have
rebecca kischinevsky she's already
spoken actually we have john schmidt
who's just raised his hand
okay
i just let you know
uh
no one's ever gonna vaccinate me i'll
fight to the death before anybody
the other thing i would ask you reps to
do for your own good and for you for the
sake of the people that you represent
do some research on the germ theory of
disease versus the terrain theory the
germ theory has never been proven all
these vaccines are based on the germ
theory it's bull crap from that
fraudster pasteur
and it was debunked by the chomps a long
time ago all these vaccines
there's no need for them thank you
unless you're planning on hearing a
second round there's no one else
with that the chair closes the hearing
everyone who wanted to speak got a
chance to speak once
now i would make this suggestion um i
would i was hoping to exec the bill but
i would like to hold it briefly or a
couple of weeks and ask representative
yes he is thank you representative lang
i would suggest
that the various members of the
committee who had suggestions
communicate with you we are being told
that there's just
not a lot of time for subcommittee work
however if people who said that they had
suggestions maybe to make the bill
acceptable would communicate with you
directly
and then you could craft an amendment
and get somebody on this committee to
uh sponsor it for you uh we could
present that when it's time to exact
would that be acceptable to you
mr chair thank you yes that would be
completely acceptable feel free to email
me at my legislative email address and i
will be happy to take any
recommendations in play and do all the
legwork and get the uh amendment written
up and drafted so it can be presented to
the committee and we'll do that thank
you for being willing to do that is
representative marsh uh on the meeting
uh yes i am and i'm sending an email to
representative lang so we'll work this
out
i'm asking representative marsh if you
can take the next bill
my cell phone which is my lifetime
lifeline to the sensitive universe is
out in the car and i've got to go fetch
it so would you um
run bill two two one
for us please uh yes i'll be glad to do
that
list of people
well i can start it anyway
we open the hearing on house bill 221
making the state vaccine registry an
opt-in program
the
chief sponsor is representative lang and
i will call in representative lang and
as he starts to speak representative
marsh if you would take the meeting
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr vice chairman and thank you
committee members for taking my
testimony today i introduced house bill
221 an act making the state vaccine
registry and opt-in program
as many of you know the state vaccine
program was voted in the database was
both within
a few years ago
and in the initial
legislation it was made as an opt-out
program however all of the information
i've gathered is the opt out program is
is
fairly non-working um and that people
aren't informed they have the right to
opt out
or if they are informed it's small print
on the back of a form that they sign
when they go get their vaccines and it's
not a verbal opt-in or opt-out um so
people are unaware the fact that they
can uh choose to opt out of this
database and state control state um
database so what this bill does and
i bought the bill into alignment if you
if for those who were in the house again
i'm representing tim lang from belknap
four um
i'm in my third term and back in 2017 we
had a constitutional amendment
about the right of new hampshire
citizens to
be safe in their information from the
state and collection of information from
the state this was a constitutional
amendment that passed the house with
greater than required amount it was
two-thirds and went to the people of new
hampshire for a vote in 2018
and the citizens of new hampshire and i
think it was 85 percent of the citizens
in new hampshire agreed that um the
state should be um
that the right of the citizen to be
protected in their public their data
from the state is is important enough
that they put it in the constitution
that is now article 2b um and so this
bill is to align our current statute
with article 2b so instead of this
opt-out provision that is not clearly
informed to the
people getting a vaccine we've chosen to
invert this and make it an opt-in so
again the
the health care provider just like an
informed consent would have to ask the
uh the person getting the vaccination
whether they can uh have their data
stored in the state database again i
think this brings the
the program into an alignment with what
the citizens in new hampshire want as
evidenced by that 85 percent vote on
protecting the privacy of their data
thank you representative i recognize
yes thank you very much for taking my
question representative lang
you write you made a comment about that
patients were not getting the
opportunity presented to them to opt in
and i have a question since the registry
is very important for the communication
back and forth between
let's say a pharmacy and a provider or
to the dhhs to help look at where we
need better vaccine coverage
would you be amenable to a an amendment
which would
require a sorry which would
require a
information sheet be given to a patient
for them to read to understand what the
rationale is for this program
and require their signature
for them to
be able to uh decline opting in in other
words it would not be an automatic
automatic opt-in but they would have to
decline that and acknowledge that they
are aware again informed consent of the
impact upon their health care that may
come from them not opting in would you
be comfortable with that
i understand your question is your
question is as long as there was some
sort of written informed consent that
was explicit um for the opt-out that
they were informed they could opt out
again i i guess i don't see
i'm i'm putting this in alignment with
the constitution i guess if that's the
only way you guys will pass the bill
i'll take that better than nothing but
um but again you know as you read um our
the constitutional amendment to 2b that
says an individual's right to live free
from governmental intrusion and private
or personal information is natural
essential and inherent
that's what was passed and that's what
the citizens of new hampshire wanted so
i think that it's more appropriate to
ask can we keep your data rather than
ask is okay
uh do you want to opt out of having the
data i think it's um it's more
appropriate to ask permission to get the
data first
representative kenner you're recognized
for a follow-up
i yes i appreciate that but is it not
important as part of informed consent
for the individual to understand the
implications of them not opting in in
other words uh
informed consent requires a two-way
street it requires education as to what
the implications are if you do or do not
do a procedure or in this case signing
in
thank you again representative for your
question again
my answer is i if the choice is do you
want to opt in and if you don't opt in
then this is the potential then i'm fine
with that um i'm not i don't want the
inverse i don't want to
force them to opt out and oh by the way
if you opt out this is what happens i
want the citizen to make an informed
decision and say yes i want my data in
thank you are there any other questions
for representative lang
thank you mr chair uh
representative blang is the underlying
concern here is that data is going into
a state database and the data would be
shared outside of the reason for being
in the database and we have many
databases within the
state itself and i think a
constitutional amendment was to try to
prevent the state from releasing the
data
without the patient's approval is that
kind of the intent behind the bill
again the constitutional amendment
doesn't talk about sharing data at all
the constitutional amendment just says
that again as i go back to it it's an
individual's right to live free from
governmental intrusion into private or
personal information
and so i i think that's a very broad uh
statement and it says that anytime the
government's going to collect data on me
i should know that it's collecting the
data
mr chair if i may follow up uh yes you
may
you may follow up representative
merchant okay thank you
so
it belongs the patient is aware of the
fact that there is a way for them to
prevent the data being released
would that not suffice as well
so again
so again the the the constitutional um
to be doesn't talk about the sharing of
data it's about the collection of data
um and so my my statement would be that
again
if the person opts in
then
then they've given consent to the state
to use the data as it chooses but if the
person never has a choice to opt in um
and it's an automatic uh you have to opt
out and somehow you're supposed to
magically know that you're supposed to
opt out um
then i i think that's inappropriate and
that's in violation of our
the constitutional amendment the will of
the people 85 percent of the people do
not want the government to collect their
private data and we're talking about the
most
you know one of the most sensitive data
we're talking about medical data um and
so even more so we should be even more
stringent and so if the state's going to
collect this data i think we need to
have
uh sign off by each individual citizen
that chooses to
to have to allow the state to do that
any other questions for representative
lang
representative marsh i will do what you
did for me and that is if someone in the
room has a question
uh i will text you and i just texted you
representative gay has her hand up
i i recognize representative gay
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
representative lange um um how would you
feel about the handout sheet
that
uh representative
snerk is talking about is recommending
but use that sheet as an opt-in
i also don't like the idea of having to
opt out papers can get lost people can
miss knowing that they have dropped out
and i don't want my data collected by
the state so
but i think the informative
sheet sounds really useful so how would
you feel about using the same sheet that
representative
is talking about but choose it to opt in
so thank you representative gay and mark
thank welcome to see you again ma'am um
so again if you read the language of the
bill on a second sentences no patience
immunization or vaccine information
shall be entered into the registry
without explicit written opt-in consent
of the patient or the patient's parent
or guardian so again i i think an
informative sheet that that the person
can see the patient can see
choose whether you know they can write
on there what is the reason why the
state has this database and then the
person can choose to opt in
to opt-in if they choose to
um i think that's appropriate that's
exactly what's written in my bill thank
you
are there any further questions for the
representative
seeing none i will ask representative
pearson if he wants to take the chair
back or if he wants me to continue with
this hearing i'd love you to continue
representative marsh thank you
[Music]
all right very well
thank you representative marsh and
members of the committee my name is beth
daly again chief of the bureau of
infectious disease control here at dhhs
i'm here to provide testimony
in opposition to house bill 221
the immunization registry which we also
refer to as an iis immunization
information system is an electronic
system that tracks administration of
vaccines they offer many benefits to our
public health agencies as well as health
care providers and individuals
they prevent duplicate immunizations
they increase our immunization rates by
promoting up-to-date
immunization recommendations and helping
to remind patients when immunizations
are due it also benefits patients and
families when they want to access a
complete electronic copy of their
immunization record
that would include information from all
of their healthcare organizations
regardless of where the vaccine was
provided
and then finally we use that information
to assure accountability of our publicly
purchased vaccines as well as to target
communities with low vaccination rights
to prevent and respond to infectious
disease outbreaks
new hampshire is the last state in the
country to implement a registry and
every other state has one in place
under rsa
141c20f this
statute directs the department to
establish and maintain a state
immunization registry
this statute expressly states that
patient participation in the registry is
voluntary and the corresponding
administrative rule outlines a process
for patients to opt out of participation
which already includes asking people if
they want their information in the
registry and
in fact the rules explicitly say that
the opportunity to opt out of the
registry shall be provided in writing in
a clear and succinct conspicuous manner
in simple language
and it to that patient
or the patient's parent or guardian if
the patient is a minor
we have not provided information to the
public yet on the opt-out process so
it's true people have not heard about
this yet and that's because we're not
collecting
any non-coveted vaccine data yet we're
just standing up our registry now and
when we are ready to begin collecting
that vaccination data information on the
opting out process will be very broadly
shared and available quite easily on our
website this bill seeks to change our
registry to one that is opt in which we
oppose
for a number of reasons first and
foremost our current opt-out approach
approach already protects an
individual's ability to choose not to
participate
while not adding costly burden to
providers and patients
nationwide almost all of the states have
opt out policies rather than
opt in
and there are just three states that
have opt-in policies in large part
because of the lower cost lower burden
and increased public health benefits
of the opt
out model so texas i want to tell you
about really quickly it's one of those
three states that have an opt-in policy
it's been in place for many years
they're actually now working to
implement a change to become opt-out
after they conducted an evaluation of
the cost associated with their opt-in
model and they found that it cost them
1.4 million dollars annually to obtain
consent for texas's opt-in model
another point i want to make is that
nationally the proportion of patients
who opt out of iis
participation is just five to ten
percent
so requiring that providers
ask in writing and with a signed
document that every patient opt into the
registry when 90 to 95 of the population
do not opt out this creates substantial
unnecessary burden and costs for our
health care providers
so keeping our registry opt out will
reduce administrative burden and free up
the time of our health care providers to
engage in appropriate patient care
activities and allow health care
providers to efficiently document their
patient records for immunization
if we allow an opt-in registry it will
result in incomplete and low quality
information that will significantly
decrease the utility of this system and
national public health experts recommend
these opt out consent policies because
they do respect an individual's right to
privacy
while also maximizing the availability
of the data that we need
in new hampshire these individuals who
do not want to participate already have
a process in place to opt out and as
such the department strongly opposes
house bill 221 and again thanks for the
opportunity to testify and i'm happy to
uh thank you dr daley uh do we have
questions for dr daley representative
shapiro i recognize you
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
when the representative
um initially introduced the bill
instructions about opting out were in
small print or not readily available but
it sounds like
that hasn't gone actually gone into
use yet
so i'm wondering
as well as having instructions
about opting out on a website
what would you think about
either in written form or oral form a
discussion about opting out occurring
as the immunizations are given in the
thank you representative for that uh
that that question and suggestion so
that process is already outlined in our
administrative roles the provider as
they're providing that immunization to
the patient does need to provide them an
opportunity already to opt out of the
registry
so that is accounted for there
the providers are the ones who
ultimately have the responsibility for
carrying out this process of of opting
out their patients and the ones that
have to provide information about the
registry and so i'm not aware that any
providers in our state are providing
this information yet to patients uh
because we have not requested any
immunization data from them other than
we are currently using the registry for
covid vaccine
tracking
thank you
the chair represent recognizes
oh thank you very much mr chair mr vice
chairman and um thank you dr daly for
taking my question
um i'm just about to look up the
population of houston
because that's just one small part of
texas i'm from texas and you could put
new hampshire in there multiple times
just in the city so i'm expecting that
the
1.4 million
to opt in in texas would be negligible
in texas in new hampshire and as a
proponent of keeping my
medical records
separate from any state registry
i think that's pretty pretty low price
yes does she respect the right to
privacy
i certainly do and there's a process for
you to opt out of the registry
i i thank you are there further
leah cushman has a question
uh representative cushman you may ask
representative
representative kushner has a question
yes thank you
excuse me mr uh representative cushman
you've signed up to testify and i was
about to recognize you so i do not
recognize you for a question
are there any other questions for dr
daley
in that case the chair calls on
thank you mr vice chairman uh members of
the committee
i have sent you an email with a policy
memo on this bill i strongly support
this bill
um i've supported it before it was even
a written bill i
lived in massachusetts for a while when
they implemented their immunization
registry
and found the problems with their their
system
um
they also have an opt-out system
and
in their law for the immunization
registry it's actually required that
they inform you that your information
will be going into it and that you may
opt out
however in practice this is not taking
place and i was going to ask
um
dr daley if she had ever researched the
the real reality of whether
patients were informed by providers
that they have the right to opt out we
have seen problems with opt-out forms in
public schools when it comes to
medical and dental clinics
where parents receive a form and it says
if you don't want your child to
participate then fill out this form and
then the forms are lost
um and they end up getting treatments
um
sorry this is my testimony
so
my um
as a nurse i i really i am a strong
proponent of informed consent
um self-determination is a basic human
right um you know this
this this is our our medical information
and under hipaa we have to
we have to give consent to everyone else
for them to have our
private health information government
should be no different it should be an
explicit outright consent and not a
easily obscured
and missed through human error opt out
process
and i would just ask that you all
support this bill thank you are there
seeing none i thank you representative
cushman and call on holly stevens from
christine is holly stevens still on the
call
uh thank you chairman and
although all of the committee members i
was still on the call that i raised my
hand to make it easier for christina um
the futures appreciates the opportunity
to testify in opposition to house bill
and i always forget this part i need to
say for the record my name is holly
stevens i'm the health policy
coordinator
of new futures
i don't want to repeat
anything that dr daley said because i
think she said it a lot better than i
ever could
but i did want to reiterate that you
know she um
talked about things such as
children that are potentially over
immunized
or under immunized
when their parents want them immunized
um
you know when we're monitoring community
immunization rates to know you know what
the spread of a disease may be
identifying coverage gaps
and things of that nature
and
we know from
history i mean even looking at the
the provider medical provider
surveys
when those were an opt-in
survey to participate in
the response was
so low
that the data collected
[Music]
wasn't even usable they didn't know
where anybody was they didn't know where
they were practicing they didn't know if
they're in retirement didn't even know
if they still resided in the state
um
so
we know from our own experience in this
state that when we make things opt-in
people rarely will
do what needs to be done
in order to overcome that barrier to
opt-in
whereas we know that when we make them
opt out
people that don't want their information
in there
absolutely make sure that they
uh make it known that they want um an
opt out
and so i think you know when we've got a
lot of individuals that might move from
one primary care office to another
um
and if they have small children
they may not know what immunizations
their children have had
so they go to the new doctor's office
and that doctor's office has no way of
knowing without
having releases signed and obtaining a
full medical record what that child has
or hasn't had and um i think it goes
without saying that representative
merchant could
easily speak to the fact that
the pharmacies uh seem to send
information to the doctor's offices that
never gets
recorded in the
electronic medical records so
you know
any vaccines that may have been
obtained in a pharmacy which i know
children's vaccines right now you can't
get in pharmacies but we don't know what
the future is going to bring
um we do know that the pharmacies are
looking at tr um trying to expand into
at least influenza pd vaccines
and you know just in an effort not to
end up over immunizing children this is
extremely important
or as i said under immunizing them if
they've if they have a vaccine that they
need to receive three doses of in a
certain amount of time this is a very
good tracking system
families that have
a lot going on it's very difficult to
track these these kinds of things um
and it would make it much easier if this
information was right at the fingertips
of any doctor that they brought their
child to see
um
you know i know that
representative knurk mentioned having a
form that says you know when the doctor
or the pharmacist
is going to give a vaccine somebody has
to check a box and sign it you already
have to do an informed consent
when you receive the vaccine
that there's no reason why you can't say
that that has to be you know information
about the registry has to be in a
certain
font uh size bolded
you know whatever maybe they need to
initial by it that they've read it you
know you can make that informed consent
crystal clear that you know that
somebody understood that it was an opt
out
registry and if they wanted to opt out
they would check a box
um so with that i think i've taken up
enough of your time i know you've got a
very busy morning
um
but for all of those reasons new futures
does oppose this bill and we urge the
committee to vote in expedient to
legislate
or look at
doing an amendment
such as the one that representative
knurk had mentioned
if you have any questions i'm available
to take them now or in the future thank
you
thank you ms stevens are there any
questions for mrs stevens yes
go ahead representative gay
thank you
chairman and thank you
miss stevens for taking my question um
if i'm going to opt out
uh does that mean at every single
provider i go to
i have to tell them not to submit my
information
it's my understanding at least when my
or at least i say it's been my
experience
that every single time i go to my
doctor's office if they're gonna give me
a vaccination i have to sign a new
informed consent for that vaccination
because they're administering something
so um
i i think that that
can easily be added to that informed
consent form so you don't have to tell
them anything you just keep checking the
box it's it's just a little box that you
would check right when you sign the form
you have to sign the form anyway so
it's not
as as though
the doctor can forget to put it in front
of you because they can't give you the
immunization
without
seeing none the chair recognizes
patricia tilly from department of health
services i don't believe tricia tilly
was able to stay on this is beth daley
and so you can proceed
okay thank you very much uh
hello can you hear me now
yes we can
okay thank you
um my name is laura condon i'm from
bedford i support this bill and i urge
you to support it too
this um chapter 141 c20
f um has been on her book since 1998 and
has never been changed this bill
actually doesn't change the law it
simply reaffirms the intent of the
current law that the state vaccination
registry shall be voluntary and
clarifies the process for ensuring
voluntary participation in fact
provisions of that chapter indicate that
it's voluntary and i i direct you to
paragraphs two three
six e and in fact i'll read succeed
procedures for the registrant or the
registrant's parent or guardian if
they're registered as a minor to
withdraw consent for participation at
any time and to remove information from
the registry consent can only be
withdrawn if it was given in the first
place indicating this is an opt-in
registry
this bill affirms that
participation will be voluntarily
actively given and not presumed let me
remind you that this program is a
redundant program
doctors pharmacists schools and you
already have vaccination records the law
requires that all of these individuals
have vaccination records this is an
addition to those records
in addition parents have no access to
this registry this they can you can not
access it only medical providers can so
to represent the parents could use this
as a tool to look up their children's
vaccinations is not true
although this law has been on the books
for a long time there is no active
vaccination registry even though over
4.6 million dollars has been allotted to
this program since 2014
there have been two bills that have
attempted to change this registry into a
mandatory opt-in registry i mean excuse
the opt-out registry that is not the new
hampshire way and both bills failed
if one is swept into this registry
without consent
getting out of it is not as easy as one
might think you require the signed
signature of a vaccinating physician in
order to be removed from the program you
cannot unilaterally remove yourself from
this registry there's a surprise in this
registry too
by rule vaccination events are recorded
in the registry now i understand one
might think that vaccination event would
mean being vaccinated
but in fact the rules defying
vaccination event to include even
refusal of vaccination so even those who
refuse a vaccine and think they might
not be swept into this registry will
also have to complete an opt-out form
because even those who decline
vaccinations become a part of this
registry
obviously there are con security
concerns with
any sort of database and you know we all
see hackers you know hacking into
hospitals banks um government entities
and so the the security um protection
there is important we must ensure that
this registry remains active
and that this um
is an opt-in program with your
affirmative signature i know some people
have said well there could be a little
check box this is currently not being
used i have and i'll send it by email a
hannaford pharmacy vaccine informed
consent form they've used for years in a
teeny teeny teeny tiny print buried in
the middle of the paragraph in the
middle of the page there was language i
authorized the information to be
forwarded to my primary care physician
authorizing physician or local
department of health slash in tiny
letters registry
so no one's ever gonna see that there's
not a check box to consent for that or
not i urge you to please pass this bill
into reaffirm and confirm that this is a
voluntary opt-in registry thank you so
much
thank you are there questions for laura
condon
seeing none i thank you for your
testimony and call on paul amenham from
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee can you hear me i think you
can yes i can thank you for the record
i'm paula minihan senior vice president
state government relations with the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals in the
state
the hospital association is opposed to
house bill 221 i have submitted written
testimony which i will not read for you
but i do want on the record to state
that um and i think dr daley did a
really good job so a lot of my testimony
kind of reiterates what she had
indicated but we do
have very big concerns about the opt-in
process which would be very cumbersome
for both the individual and the health
care provider creating barriers to
producing a comprehensive immunization
record for individuals and impede
sound clinical decision making if the
health care provider cannot rely on
complete information for their patients
i did provide you with a number of
resources in my testimony
that i would actually i would encourage
you to review i think it's um it's
interesting information from the cdc and
other national um
resources um and
i just would like um to have you look at
that later
the hospital association wants new
hampshire to develop a stable reliable
and comprehensive vaccine registry that
can be used by and for health care
providers and individuals
our hospitals and health care providers
have been advocating for years to have a
functioning vaccine registry in our
state
as a reliable tool in their toolbox and
we ask that no changes be made to the
registry structure before it even truly
gets off the ground
and for these reasons we the hospital
association does not support house bill
221 and we ask that you find this bill
in expedient to legislate i'm thank you
and i'm happy to answer any questions
thank you are there questions from paul
monan
seeing none at the suggestion of
representative pearson i'm now calling
in to play the one minute rule and all
further testimony will be limited to one
minute as we are way behind schedule
the chair calls on representative jess
edwards
yeah hi i'm representative jess edwards
uh representing
rockingham district four
the last four or five years of my career
i was a privacy and security officer for
medical device manufacturers
one of the times that i was uh the the
bad guy in in the corporation was when
marketing people would come to me and
say
hey we need to get away from this
corporate policy of uh opt-in
because if we make it opt out it tricks
more people to give us data that they
wouldn't want to give us otherwise and
if we have their data then we can do
more things for them we can make better
products we can give them better
information
so
um at a uh
international associate of privacy
professionals conference about five or
six years ago
uh a representative of the of the obama
administration got up and and advocated
strongly for the privacy community to
switch to opt out instead of opt in
because the rate of getting data was
vastly higher but it completely ignores
the concept that your data is yours
it should require an active
permission by you to share your data
thank you representative edwards the
chair now recognizes courtney tanner
good morning
my name is courtney tanner i am the
director of government relations at
dartmouth hitchcock dartmouth hitchcock
is opposed to house bill 221. i want to
draw your attention to written testimony
that i submitted electronically
from dr keith loud dr ladd is the chief
physicians at dartmouth hitchcock's
children's hospital the only children's
hospital in new hampshire
i just want to highlight a couple of key
points from dr ladd's testimony kova 19
has served as a reminder of the value of
immunizations vaccine registries are a
tool to increase and sustain sufficient
vaccine rates
a systematic universal registry allows
citizens to seek and obtain
immunizations in a safe and convenient
way while keeping providers informed
dartmouth hitchcock believes that house
bill 221 would be a step backwards this
would hinder new hampshire's work to
improve the health and the safety of our
children and our communities thank you
very much and i'm happy to be a resource
for the committee
uh thank you gordon dinner um the chair
recognizes
mr mcleod
thank you my name is thomas mclaughlin
president mount vernon the chair of the
liberty defense fund and member of the
leadership group of health room new
hampshire speaking as member public
in support of hb 221 mr chairman in may
june
of 2020 my organization submitted right
to no request to dhhs seeking documents
on precisely how the department would
implement opt out in the vaccine
registry it is clear that even as the
department brings the registry online it
has not yet implemented software
features necessary to
guarantee even opt-out procedures
mr chairman the vaccine registry is not
just for tracking vaccinations also
available for research in new hampshire
today at dartmouth college vaccine
registered data from vermont is being
used by professor brendan nylen but his
research is not medical research
professor nylon is a political science
researcher and his work involves using
people's private medical data records to
study how to step up to influence them
politically and how to bring their
political views more closely in
alignment with public health goals
professor nylon's research has formed
the basis of political attacks on
so-called vaccine resistors in new york
uh thank you mr mcleod the chair
good morning this is wendy gladstone i
am a retired pediatrician i live in
exeter i'm a former president of the new
hampshire chapter of the american
academy of pediatric pediatrics
i'm speaking behalf on
today on behalf of the chapters
membership which consists of hundreds of
board-certified pediatricians from
across the state the new hampshire
chapter strongly opposes house bill 21.
uh we are in agreement with the comments
made by dr dailey and i will not repeat
them however i will emphasize to the
committee that although the question was
made as to the cost for individual
practices
for implementing an opt
in or an opt-out strategy
medical practices are already very
pressed for time and the administrative
burden of requiring signed form consent
of an additional document to be
printed and scanned into the medical
record as would be required by this bill
would be another reason to oppose it
we believe that the passage of this bill
would result in an impaired ability for
the state to
adequately
follow immunization status for public
health perspective
and
uh thank you doctor the chair now
thank you mr chair
my name is marie ramos i'm a family
physician and speaking on behalf of the
new hampshire medical society um in
opposition of this bill
um i want to
share and echo many of the sentiments
that were shared within our public
health leaders of the community but i
wanted to share specifically my
experience as being a family doctor in
the state of california
working in a rural community
at the time when i started my practice
of a town of 3000 the immunization rates
for the children were 30
after the state of california in started
a vaccine registry i was able to not
only help our practice increase the
vaccination rates up to 80 percent but
also i was able to reduce the risk the
amount of unnecessary repeated
vaccinations for our patients it's very
important to remember that during a
certain time in california
there were there was an outbreak of
measles and that was very true within
the little town that i worked in if it
wasn't for vaccinations not only myself
who was pregnant at the time but also
many of my patients who were sick and
ailing and couldn't get to specialists
within an hour
would have been at higher risk i strong
thank you dr ramos the chair recognizes
the last person who signed up in advance
can you hear me all right
yes we can
thank you i'll be very brief
i'm a retired family doctor and
appreciate
the testimony of everyone who's spoken i
speak on behalf of myself and the new
hampshire medical society as well
in opposition to hb 221
the registry programs throughout the
country and there are 49 other states
who have them
uh essentially will
assume that the public health benefit
and confidential confidentiality
safeguards that these programs provide
uh allow the states to safely and
ethically assume an implied consent to
people who
to the general public's enrolling
in what is essentially op out programs
in this time of coronavirus pandemic our
country is all too aware of the
importance of having a robust informed
accountable public health infrastructure
to help us deal with any public health
emergency
thank you dr hayes uh
christina are there any other members of
the public who have their hands raised
uh yes we have eric power
well this is eric power i'm a resident
of brookline
and i'm in support of house bill 221.
i think it's a very important
bill to have an opt-in
there's a lot of good reasons that have
been stated for it
it's very difficult to get out of a
uh out of this process
and i'm also very concerned i heard one
of the speakers talk about the
vaccination event a vaccination event
could be a refusal to have a vaccine i
was asked the doctor's office do i want
the shingles vaccine do i want the flu
vaccine
i'm concerned those those refusals will
be recorded and be part of this database
to be used for whatever purpose
i think that there's a small cost for
this but i think it's a very small price
to pay for our privacy
and i think our privacy is very
important
i don't like the idea that we're having
implied consent i think we need to have
explicit consent to be having our data
be put into these databases to be used
by the state and others
and without our consent i think it's not
appropriate so i would urge ought to
pass for house bill 221. thank you very
much
thank you christina are there any other
members of the public who wish to speak
uh yes we have quite a few uh we have
representative melissa blasek
um thank you mr vice chair thank you
members of the committee i just wanted
to make a quick point currently as we
speak the registry is not active meaning
no vaccine or person is currently being
tracked by this system
and i don't see the health of the public
of this state suffering at all so i
don't see the issue with airing on the
side of freedom
we cannot trick the public into consent
and people can be responsible for
transferring their own medical records i
actually resent the uh implications of
some of the opposition testimony that
the public cannot practice personal
responsibility
thank you
thank you uh christina who else has
their hand up
representative marsh uh if i may
interrupt here we're making a change in
the person who is wearing the muting
device that would now be representative
weber because christina dyer is uh
trying to help multiple committees
and mr chairman i have alexandra
manala
is manila i think you need to unmute
it says you're i'm speaking in support
of this bill
we should absolutely have an option to
opt in here
my message to the physicians the
hospital association dartmouth hitchcock
um the department of health and human
services
um
i understand your intentions to help us
but our privacy is more important than
your objectives
okay we have an inherent right to live
free from government intrusion
all right so we're not interested in
your registries um so to the
representatives i asked you to support
this bill and allow us to opt in thank
you
thank you representative weber who else
has their hand up i have somebody whose
name is kelly and i have just brought
her up
thank you kelly if you could please tell
hi i'm here can you hear me
yes we can
okay uh my name is kelly potenza and uh
resident of new hampshire i live in rye
um
basically
yeah there's a lot of testimony here
that's talking about something that is
truly um non-existent at this point so i
i think the point and i think the
speaker was laura that was talking about
it is this is something that's already
in place we are just supporting this so
it is basically this bill simply
clarifies and explicitly states that the
vaccine registry shall be an opt-in
program so it's already
you know the law is already there the
bill doesn't change the law it just
clarifies it so i think that's the key
point here there's a lot of testimony
going on but the point is that and i
sent you guys an email that just clearly
states this this bill just ensures that
the intent of this law is
thank you for your testimony
representative weber can you tell me who
else's hands are up i see no other hands
at this time mr chairman
thank you as there's no further public
testimony coming before the committee i
will declare this public hearing closed
and turn the meeting back to
representative pearson
it gives me great pleasure both to thank
representative marsh for filling in for
representative day
match
mr chairman if you are in the room and
it appears to me that you are
uh you're going somebody in the room is
going to have to unmute house the room
so that we can hear the people in the
room
um
and mr chairman if you can hear me
uh
the other issue that i have is
i
am without enough different pieces of
electronics to
see the list of people who have signed
up to testify so if you can call people
from the list and then i will be able to
uh promote those people who are not
already on the call
and i have the list representative
webber uh as of 8 30.
well if we go down through that list and
then i can promote
and i will promote people as you call
them and then
uh you can uh i i can see the hands up
from other people who might not be on
the list
to quote the great actor from the
television show mr t
i love it when the plan comes together
well it's a plan anyway the execution
may be
marginally flawed but we'll we'll do our
best
i take by the way everybody i just want
to make a quick announcement for those
who may not be aware
just a little while ago in our email
came an amendment to
hb601 the next bill that we're hearing
that is a replace all amendment
oh god
yes exactly
so
um it's important that we have that
since that is actually what we
will need to be discussing so i should
have looked up exactly when it came to
help guide you everybody
uh from whom did this come
i i i yeah i'm trying to find that right
now 601 god here it is it came from
house and which would be ann fitzgerald
and house committee services
um actually it came from hcs so look for
hcs
in your search it came at
a.m
the hard carpet was delivered to the
room shortly thereafter
exactly yeah ann fitzgerald sent an
email that she made copies and they were
going to bring them down
so you guys should have them and
everybody else should be able to find
their email again at 10 19 from house
committee services it usually identifies
thank you representative you stole my
thunder
oh okay sorry well actually though i
also make one other thing too that i
have sent this to
uh chair pearson and everybody else
should have it i know that we may or may
not do it in the executing of bills
later today
we just this morning received i just
received amendments that i had submitted
for hb 2 4 0 and h b 1 6
a couple of hours an hour or so ago i
emailed those to the committee members
also again asks hcs to bring down about
eight copies for the room
i do not know if we will get to those
but i wanted you to be aware that those
just behind the scenes work
thank you very much
you're welcome
all right with that
i open the hearing on house bill 601
and for the benefit of
not just committee members but all of
those
whose name is on my sheet
interested in testifying
you
will need to know that
the bill that you prepared to testify on
has been replaced
and it's one of those amend the bill by
replacing all
which doesn't mean every single word but
it just means a lot of them
and so with that the chair recognizes
representative ammon to speak to the
bill of which he is prime sponsor and
please go out of your way
to let us know the differences because
we've all prepared on the old bill so
representative amman please
present your
new bill new amendment
i am not seeing representative ammon if
he is on the call if he would raise his
hand
that would be helpful okay got it
thank you representative amman and
thank you mr chair and thank you members
of the committee
for the record my name is keith ammon
representing hillsborough district 40.
i live in new boston i represent new
boston mount vernon milford and hollis
i'm the prime sponsor of house bill 601
which seeks to address a problem that
needs legislative attention
we have a new state database being built
and
you've probably heard similar testimony
in the last hearing
a new state database being built for the
social services system
but we do not have informed consent for
individuals receiving services in that
system
house bill 601 in its amended form
proposes to legislate
informed consent
by way of background i agreed to sponsor
house bill 601 after i learned about a
state contract awarded during the state
of emergency
that would create a new closed-loop
referral system
for social services at the department of
health and human services
the new system is meant to link social
service providers including state
agencies
not-for-profits and private providers
into a database that allows them to
share and retrieve personal information
about new hampshire residents seeking
and or receiving
social services
the data the purpose of the database is
to help with coordinating care
while this is certainly a worthwhile
goal
i think the legislature should
understand how this system will work
and what privacy protections will be in
place in the database
for individuals seeking services
before the state created a vaccine
registry or prescription drug monitoring
program privacy issues were discussed
this database should not be different as
you may recall in 2018
new hampshire voters adopted a privacy
provision
to the new hampshire constitution
they did so
by 81 percent of the voters
and that reads an individual's right to
live free from governmental intrusion
and private and personal information
is natural essential and inherent
those words don't protect themselves
it's up to the legislature the executive
branch the judicial branch to make sure
that those words adopted 81 percent by
our our constituents have effect when it
deals with their personal information
we all have constituents who may be
going through tough times and need
social services that could range
anywhere from food assistance
to housing assistance to other services
for child welfare and so on
these constituents will now be added to
a database that will house their
information for other social service
providers to see and share
a loosely defined network
from what i understand a person may sign
only one consent form and that will
allow their information to be shared
beyond the agency actually providing
them services
this committee is well versed in privacy
issues as they relate to health and
human
there are questions that i think the
department should answer that would help
us as legislators
understand the new database program and
what it may mean for our constituents
and their privacy rights
here are three questions i hope the
committee will have answered
question one
does the person seeking services know
what information is being shared about
them to other organizations
for example is it household income
description of their issues or what
other information
question two does the person seeking
services know when and how often their
information will be looked up
and which organizations specifically are
accessing it that question deals with
searchability of their information
question three could the person seeking
services be turned down for services
if they don't want their information to
be in this database
could they be denied services because
moving on my intent is not to impede the
work of the department or the services
provided to individuals needing
assistance
my questions are raised by the
implementation of this new database
system
and how it affects the services and
privacy protections of our constituents
in light of some of the concerns raised
about the bill as presented
in light of the
concerns
and i emailed this last night to the
committee about 7 p.m the draft
and it was it was finalized uh a few few
uh 15 minutes ago or so by ols
to address these concerns i had an
amendment drafted by ols for the
2021-0253 h
0253h
the amendment replaces the bill
to specifically address two issues so
here's the differences
first it would require an informed
consent form for individuals each time
their information is shared
so they can take control of protecting
their
privacy second it requires that services
can't be withheld if they choose not to
and the the draft amendment was sent to
the committee
i know our legislature and our
constituents take privacy very seriously
we set parameters to make sure agencies
government agencies across the state use
private information in limited ways
i appreciate your expertise in reviewing
these issues
there there are others who will be able
to speak more specifically to the
language in the amendment that will come
after me so in conclusion i hope you
would look favorably on house bill 601
and i thank you for your time and i'm
are there any members of the committee
who have a question of representative
ammon
representative shapiro has his hand up
on screens representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um
as you
know most medical practitioners
operate under the
the um
health information portability and
have you
the informed cons the specific informed
consent in your bill would align or not
that's an excellent question uh it's my
understanding i'm not a medical
professional
that hipaa
it's a federal
federal
requirement
but it deals with patient privacy
uh this
this bill deals with
uh a person's information in the social
services system so it's
uh i guess there would be some analogies
between the two but i think this is a
simpler issue
as it deals with
a person receiving social services
which which may or may not include
require hipaa compliance which would be
a separate issue that's my understanding
follow-up
follow up
um maybe i'm not
understanding completely but it does
seem
that in the
on page two
on line 16 to 18 and 20 to 22 where you
talk about a very specific consent form
um
that it includes health information as
well as social service information
and i am
specifically um concerned that these may
be overly broad in giving permission to
share information
um they don't seem to um say
specifically what organizations you're
could you comment on that
yeah i could try i mean so the intent of
that form is any time uh a a new person
comes into the system that their
information
uh
before their information is shared
because we know once it's shared it's
hard to put it back in the box that they
would have to sign a consent and
the the differences between the two
um
section
i'm sorry i'm looking
uh
the forms are identical one one section
deals with if you're presented in paper
form the other is if you're presented in
electronic form
the uh
the for the consent form would be filled
out before that information went to
other agencies including the the ability
to opt out
so your question about hipaa i think is
interesting because
there
might be some overlap depending on what
information is stored in this database
that some of the information may also
have a hipaa component to it and i
couldn't answer the specifics on that
but you might want to ask
thank you
any other members of the committee
yes mr chairman representative knark's
hand is up
representative
thank you um i actually had a question
also about the uh forms that are printed
since that says verbatim what the form
has to say
i was concerned about the reading level
since we usually think about trying to
write
documents for people at about a sixth to
eighth grade level and the question
would be do we think that a the average
person will understand what a searchable
database is particularly if they happen
to perhaps be a little older with a gray
hair like we see in our committee
uh that's a great question and i think
readability is uh
should definitely be as broad as
possible
um
i'm a i'm actually a database
professional so
i have a lot of experience
designing and administering databases
so maybe that was an oversight
do you have a suggestion for a different
term the idea is that
the data can be stored but if it's
if it's searchable
then lots of agencies can access it
because searchability means
it's not just their name or some
identifier
it could be searchable based on income
level or
what services they've received in the
past right so
you know harvesting data from the
database
if it's not searchable then there would
have to be
a specific
point of contact about that individual
and that agency
uh in order for that data to be shared
may i respond
or
i would just say that it is always a
difficulty if you are expert in this
it's difficult to bring it to the right
level we might want to get somebody else
to look at it who doesn't understand it
and see what word would work for them
but that's a different issue thank you
mr chairman i have representative nelson
and then representative woods
and then representative cannon and then
representative merchant
the chair recognizes representative
nelson
thank you mr chairman i
reading is over i just want to double
check on something
personal information in the past we've
had committees for example have studied
such things as
somebody that has had an abortion not
the name of somebody but just
information to try to track how many
abortions are done in the state of
new hampshire
would that
number not the person's personal
information be counted or be used or
would prohibit them using the number of
abortions
as an example that's a controversial
example but let's say it was some other
issue like visiting a food bank or
something right
this
amendment
deals with personal personal
identifiable information
so
aggregating data across town county or
whatever way you want to aggregate it
if you aggregate it high enough you kind
of
it becomes non-identifiable
and that would be a different issue that
this bill is not trying to address
that's your
the chair recognizes representative
woods
uh thank you mr chair and uh thank you
representative amman for taking my
question
i'm trying to get my arms around just
exactly how this
process would work
under this bill
and
the down perhaps downside and thinking
about
an individual who
applies for a particular program
a state program
and then by chance
wants to apply
someplace else for another state program
does that mean they would have to
go through the same process again
if the agencies couldn't speak to one
another
sort of like going to the doctor's
office
you were just there two days ago and
they want you to fill out all the forms
again
in this situation sometimes the folks
that need the services don't have access
to
ready
online
filling out forms and we've seen the
confusion with the covin program about
people trying to get on so i'm trying to
get my arms around how this is gonna
play out in practice
so we're trying to find a balance
between two things one is uh
the
the people receiving services their
their rights is particularly the right
to privacy
and the efficiency of the system right
those two things
are at odds and this bill
uh puts a spotlight on the privacy issue
because before now it hasn't been
addressed
and so
i think just on a higher level that's
kind of what we're trying to look at
here
and
as legislators are both of those needs
of our constituents uh
are important
so
that that's not just a high level like
introduction uh to
how i think we're approaching this
the the
the consumer of the service
basically can opt in
to this network
and there's an issue with the definition
of the network the network of providers
that it's kind of loosely defined
you know it can change over time
and so
you might the network might have
a certain number of providers in it
in at the current uh
time
but then over time that network grows
and changes
and
if there is there are no privacy
protections
not only don't you know who has your
data
currently but over time more and more
providers or different providers can get
access to that data
so this bill is trying to put
a brief pause
when that data moves that if you're
uh
consuming a service that you are at
least informed and are given a chance to
express your willingness to have your
does that make does that answer your
question
that's the privacy concern that we're
trying to address here
the exact implementation
it's difficult to predict i think you'll
have the
someone from i.t of health and human
services
come behind me that might be a question
for someone that uh understands
better the implementation
uh
because i'm not familiar with that
directly
the chair recognizes representative
cannon
thank you mr chair and
thank you
representative for taking my question
um
as i was reading through the your this
immense
amendment there are 17 mentions of
health
and so i raised the question again
about hipaa requirements as i just
filled out a form
um for my a therapist and
psychologist to send information along
and i had to identify
these
specific things i would allow to be
transferred from the their office
and who they were and who i was
transferring that information to
and there's no way there's nowhere in
this particular document
that is as specific as the hipaa
requirements that were on that form were
met
so
i'm i'm wondering if another amendment
would be coming
for this bill that would let us know how
this differs from what our
hipaa
requirements are
yeah that's a great question this is not
as
as granular as the hippo requirements
this is more of just a
catch-all opt-in or out
so there's three versions of this
i i give my consent
share share my data with who you will
the second is i give my consent but it
should not be searchable
and the third is i do not give my
consent
for my data to be shared and it's
specifically talking about this new
database
uh this closed-loop referral system that
uh
the data will be centrally housed by
health and human services
and i don't know the extent that it's
going to be shared with other agencies
but
the you know the central store of the
data uh will be with health and human
services and
they will be
in my understanding controlling access
to that data by other
organizations
thank you
uh thank you mr chairman and also thank
you representative
for taking my question
uh more of a practical side
when i see things that are in statute
language dealing with a foreign
specifically
what history's
shown me is that once something gets
into statute it's very difficult to
change it and over time things do
change and it's very difficult to keep
up with the change because it's in
statute
any reason to why it's in statute versus
requiring the agency to have rulemaking
authority
to create rules around the particular
consent forms
as an option versus putting in a statue
that's an excellent question um
one one of the reasons why the language
for those forms was kept very simple
and and uh you know targeted to the
point
um dealing with privacy
and efficiency
those two things being at odds um
it's sometimes in the interest of a
bureaucracy
to
put privacy
uh secondary to efficiency because it's
less work it's less less things to do
right
and so that's why it's important to have
this
in statute because it gives the
legislature control over
that balance between privacy and
efficiency
and you'll see that there's language
that says
those words uh
that the the the agency can't
try to talk a person in or out of
any of those options
so that it should be
up to the individual to make the
decision and not be coached
one way or the other
when they make that decision
mr chairman
thank you mr chairman also thank
representative again
the legislative branch does have sort of
an oversight
legislatively on agencies with
rulemaking authority
so therefore that agency has some
control over how the rules are written
i just concern myself with something in
the statute i hear you concern about
the government overreach but there is
checks and balances i think built into
the process through gel cart to allow
for an agency to write the rules and
also for legislative branch to review
those rules that are written
it's just more of a comment than a
question but would you be opposed again
back to the issue of um knowing the fact
that jail car is there to protect the
legislative body in the public at large
if if jail car would
have the option to approve the specific
language of the form then i would not be
opposed to that but if it's something
that
you know disappears into the fog and
never gets seen again
and can change without oversight then i
would be opposed to that so
thank you
this is uh chairman
mark pearson i chair the new hampshire
commission on deafness and hearing loss
and it seems that at every meeting
people are asking we don't know
how many deaf deafblind hard of hearing
people there are in the state how do we
collect that information
on the other hand i'm aware of an
individual
who is a constituent of someone else
who is totally blind has a dog has a
white cane with a red tip and really
doesn't want anybody to know he's blind
um
how does your
amended bill
strike that appropriate balance so my
commission can start to get the data it
needs to make its decisions while
protecting
individual
well if if the person and and i'd
imagine the form would be presented in
braille for the for the blind um the
person
would have a chance to opt out of having
their data shared
um
is it is it in a central location uh in
in one location just not shareable with
other
uh providers in the network i'd i'd have
to ask dhs
about that but
the question that you're asking again i
think deals with aggregated data
which if you you know if you aggregate
it
if there's only one blind person in a
town and you aggregate it to that town
then you're pretty much identifying that
one person there's no
you're not uh you're not protecting
their privacy most people in that time
uh but well
they're not government agents
most likely you're right
okay so um
so um but if you aggregate it to a
county or some higher level then
it protects the individual's privacy
um
[Music]
and so i think if you wanted to know how
many blind people were in the state it's
you can do that while protecting privacy
would your bill follow up with your bill
help or hinder that or is it neutral to
that
i believe it's neutral
and again if if your constituent who is
blind
doesn't want to tell anyone that he's
um
and doesn't doesn't
want people to invade their privacy
what what job is it
of the government
to invade that person's privacy
right
like in a free society you don't get
perfect order you get
uh
you get people complying
voluntarily and you do the best that you
can with the data that you're able to
collect
thank you for your answer before you
go
you had mentioned the word amendment
since i
decide when bills get exact or
um not
are you open to us waiting on this
so that an amendment might be offered
yeah i'm not a post and i'm sorry if i
overstepped i meant draft amendment um
no you didn't no
you didn't um
i i'm not opposed uh i guess if we wait
too long then the horse will be out of
the barn right so
i think i think we need to address the
privacy issue up front before the system
gets going
because uh if you wait until
the data is flowing and you don't know
exactly who it's being shared with then
it's kind of hard to put that back in
the bottle so i think we have some time
but
i wasn't planning on waiting very long
we have to get everything out the door
by the middle of march anyway
no the opposition then thank you thank
you representative canark
uh
yes
yeah
just a very quick question you commented
and my apologies if i missed the name
earlier you've commented about this
database what is the name of this
database that we're discussing that
you're concerned about
uh the name that i have uh that i was
made aware of is the close loop referral
system uh
now i don't know if that's the specific
project name for the database there
might be some uh
some other name that they're using
internally but that's that's what i'm
referring to it as
a follow-up
follow-up
just a real quick thing i got an email
and it was a little bit unclear there
was some kind of a company called ant
bertha that sounded like they were
weighing in on this have they been
involved in this uh effort of yours or
not
no i i do not know
that company you might want to ask them
thank you and see no additional members
of the committee
except
for representative gay
thank you thank you mr chairman and
thank you representative i i have
actually two questions one i'm trying to
identify
what data we can keep totally separate
and what data can go on the database so
that's my first question can the social
worker or whoever else is providing a
service
send a person's records to another
provider
i'm assuming that they can
send it as a packet rather than
oh here's the database just look them up
so that's question one
and then question two
would be there's some way to put a
column of shareable data that like for
aggregated accounts like blind this
person is blind so that it's not tied
at all
to the person maybe it's going to be
tied except
if somebody's not honest
but those are my two questions can you
you do have to share the data about
people because they're usually not taken
care of by one
one service it sounds like it's linked
to others so is it possible to do that
without just putting them in the
database and
making the database accessible
to the other service provider
yeah that's that's the the first part of
that or the for your first question is
interesting because um
if you have a central repository meaning
that there's one database
maybe there's a web portal or some way
that's one point of failure as far as
the data being hacked even so the
if you're
sending the data copies of the data
to different organizations and now
they're housing the data
you know you see what i mean that now
there's
copies of of the data all over
with different providers now your
attack surface
for that data to be exposed to the
internet or the dark web grows
because
now you don't you don't have a
control over
the security of that data it could be
you know in emails
or documents on hard drives that might
be accessed so that's another concern
that's the way i hear your first
question is that what you're asking
oh
follow-up
it says you one of the options is you
may share my personal information with
any other public or private health or
social service agency in this or any
other state you just can't include it on
a surgical database so that means
somehow
somehow we have to make it possible
to
share the records with another provider
so
is is it possible
just to give people permission to
certain
certain data i mean they have to get it
it says i give you may share my personal
information so how do you protect that
when you share it with another provider
without making the database open to
everyone accessible
you know i don't have a great answer to
that because i don't know the specific
implementation in mind um
[Music]
you know what i mean it depends on how
the system is structured
this is more coming from like the
the uh consumer
viewpoint you know how they interact
with the system and that's why it
focuses on those consent forms so i i
couldn't answer but you might want to
ask someone from it and they could have
with no further questions from the
committee
the chair recognizes dr jonathan ballard
good morning mr chair and committee
members my name is dr jonathan ballard i
am a practicing family physician and the
chief medical officer for the department
of health and human services
if if it's permissible to you i would
like to speak in tandem with a couple of
our uh experts
who may be able to answer some of these
questions mr david weeders our director
of information services
and jenny o'higgins are a senior policy
analyst with the division of behavioral
health um
speaking first
thank you thank you mr chair
um
first of all dr ballard i need the
second name again so i can find it
first of all i believe i've promoted
both of them thank you
when we were reviewing this piece of
legislation it was unclear to us exactly
what it was aimed at initially
it's very broadly written and it applies
to every health and social service
agency private for-profit
or non-profit
and it refers to the sharing of
information between providers that could
include any hospital social service
agency pharmacy
uh insurance company when it in and as
written and as including the proposed
amendment would apply to the entire
health care system and not as is not
directed at department of health and
human services
we already have a
fragmented disorganized health care
system and efforts are obviously trying
to be done to decrease the burden on
citizens to have their health care needs
met
this bill will further
fragment the system and therefore dhhs
is opposed to this bill
we believe it would increase cost to the
state decrease the coordination of care
among health care providers and social
service agencies and it conflicts with
other laws and mandates both state and
nationally
it impairs our ability to respond to
emergencies and there are a number of
provisions about this bill
that would cause significant harm to our
most vulnerable citizens
i will defer to
david weeder as a director of
information services regarding
this
reference to the closed loop referral
platform not a searchable database
and
you also recognize that the committee uh
has heard testimony
that the
um
sponsor of this legislation does not
know how this the specifics uh
of what this proposed platform isn't
being interpreted at or implemented as
therefore we have not been involved with
this discussion about how this bill the
intent behind this bill
came about
a few very specific situations that i
read when i first read this bill that
made me very worried mainly as a medical
provider
i am a doctor for children and adults
and when i see children if for example
i had a child that i was seeing with a
broken arm
and i was suspecting of child abuse
if this bill were implemented my
interpretation of it would be that i
could not report this child's potential
neglect or abuse
to a social service agency without the
potential abusers consent
i felt very concerned about this bill as
britain
also i was concerned about the ada uh
compatibility of this bill
requiring written signatures and no
other options available
also in the era of covet 19 a
hard written consent as well as more
paperwork
was
written paper and touching of surfaces
in close proximity made me more
concerned as well
i was also concerned about fraud
the abuse of this law
how does how would these signatures be
verified and how would they be
interpreted
when there's an open investigation of
neglect and abuse that's happening if
it seems like it would be an impediment
to provide services and coordinating of
the no exceptions rule there's no
exceptions at all written into this
legislation for emergencies or harm
to a person
if the information is not
shared
it conflicts with our state laws for
mandatory reporting of infectious
diseases
it also conflicts with other mandatory
requirements for
i think with that i would like to defer
it to mr david weeders our director of
information services to
potentially respond to some of the
thank you mr chair and
and members of the committee
and
dr ballard just to add on to his
comments as a overarching nature
the
the other components of this is the
increased cost to not just the one
system that were referred to in the
conversation today but since this is a
broad legislation it would impact all of
our systems of sharing of information
for both in emergency as well as
continued sharing with our federal
partners as well
so those systems costs would need to be
contemplated and are not funded in this
in this bill at this point
those costs could if if left at a broad
state could be more than a million
dollars in general funds to the various
of systems that we would need to
accommodate the three different options
of opt-in opt-out functionality
as it relates to the closed-loop
referral system
that we are moving forward to increase
the care coordination across our state
it is definitely our intent and to have
a very solid data governance strategy
which is a strategy
in
in its speak
to really maintain the privacy of the
data and the security of the information
so we have partnered with our our vendor
to have informed consent
at the time of service so
if someone shows up at
the emergency department or at a food
pantry and is seeking services there but
then also needs additional services
somewhere else they would be able to
leverage the system to do
a consent process to share on the
platform as well as follow any
required processes that they have for
sharing that data
to be specific
the platform has an acknowledgement
document or consent document that all
clients will sign to support to support
the sharing of information on the
platform
it does describe what how their data
would be shared across the platform and
they would be shared within the network
for services specifically being referred
that they're being referred to
it does not take the place of any
provider specific consents
authorizations or privacy notices that
must be used by providers based on their
specific privacy practices
and in the case of
commune mental health centers they have
very strict process processes as it
relates to 42 cfr part 2
substance use data that they would still
need to have their inform their consent
documents
also to share that information for
referrals to other services
so we definitely see this as a a primary
part of that closed-loop referral system
and it was already being established as
as rules and policy for moving forward
this this platform will allow for
clients to seek services across um
locations or services and it basically
does address the ability to share data
in a consolidated manner and to address
one of the comments from representative
hammond
was that
if we were using a paper process which
we are currently today
and sharing either via phone email or
fax that data is shared in multiple
locations it is not
always consistent and it certainly isn't
in a timely manner our goal is to use
this platform
to maintain consistency
with the data
as well as make sure that the data is
accurate and is in a secure location
in compliance with federal and state
laws
and i will defer
over to jenny o'higgins for any specific
examples that she wanted to bring up as
well
so hi there um thank you mr chair and
members of the committee i'm jenny
o'higgins i'm the legislative liaison
and senior policy analyst for behavioral
health at dhhs and my work is often
focused in the substance use disorder
system in new hampshire so i just wanted
to briefly look at two specific examples
of how this impacts a vulnerable person
in the community
so both our doorway system and our
maternal opioid misuse model would be
examples of programs that could utilize
better care coordination and the ability
to sort of close that loop so when i see
a client being able to understand that
they made it to the place that i
referred them for the services that were
needed and better monitoring outcomes
are just those two programs as you know
there are nine doorways across the state
that act as access points offering a
connection to substance use treatment
and recovery services and people who
access doorway services often have very
complex needs the doorway may serve as
an access point for substance use
disorder treatment but to get there
people need to be connected to housing
and food security and job opportunities
mental health services and other social
supports and we know this to be true
from our ongoing doorway work
so in addition to the doorway program
new hampshire has been awarded a federal
medicaid funding under the maternal
opioid misuse model and that model is
really addressing fragmentation and care
for pregnant and postpartum medicaid
beneficiaries who are experiencing
opioid use disorder
the mom goals are to improve the quality
of care and reduce the cost of providing
care to mothers and infants
it pays special attention to enhanced
coordination of existing reproductive
health maternity opioid use disorder and
mental health care services so this bill
would make the coordination of care for
these moms and babies more challenging
including our response to and treatment
of neonatal abstinence syndrome
the doorway program and the mom model
were both an outgrowth of identified
gaps in our systems and we really can't
afford to move backwards or slow down
our approach to addressing substance
misuse in new hampshire
so the good news is that people often go
on to get well
the reality is that people often have
many barriers to achieving their
recovery goals and people find recovery
through many pathways but it's not often
that they go on to get well on the
street they need housing and it's not
often that they go on to get well while
experiencing food insecurity and so
sharing this information across
providers really allows for a
comprehensive and a collaborative
approach to a really complex issue and
when we treat people in silos we
continuously are left wondering why we
don't see positive outcomes
so in new hampshire we see that a
majority of medicaid's highest need and
highest cost beneficiaries really have
multiple physical conditions
co-occurring mental illness and or
substance use disorder and most of these
individuals are in fragmented systems of
care with little to no coordination
across providers what we're trying to do
is really to
decrease those the
poor quality and high costs and better
coordinate their care for the population
that has the potential to really improve
their health outcomes and to control
spending
so i hope that was helpful and i think
all three of us are here to answer any
questions that we can the chair
recognizes representative marsh with a
question
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question i'm i'm not sure
which of the members from the department
this is best voice to and you can use
choose for yourselves who's best
it's my understanding that there are
various procedures in place to prevent
people from fraudulently accessing
services or accessing duplicate services
would this bill affect those systems
that you currently have in place to
this is jonathan ballard david do you
have information about the systems in
protections with verifying fraud and
waste
abuse noise
certainly this is david leaders
information services director i
we do have several systems in place for
third party liability and fraud fraud
provide waste and abuse
this bill as it as it is right now
i don't know if it would impact it
directly however having the ability to
share and have a platform in which to
see the services that are being provided
potentially would address that but that
there was never the intent of this
platform to be involved in the fraud
waste and abuse component
so that was not the goal the goal was to
provide services and care coordination
for our clients so i don't believe that
this bill would impact that we would
have to do further research on that
representative marsh
and members of the committee thank you
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you all
all of the people who may be answering
my question
um my question is outside of the
platform that's being created now
i know that i have many constituents who
interact
for example with the one-stop
application
for various welfare
housing food benefits
provided by the state across several
programs
and i'm wondering
if you know
how this bill is going to
implicate
the
functioning of that system and all the
other systems i know that ms o'higgins
talked about the doorways program but
i'm concerned about other platforms that
are designed to take away silos for
people whose access to service is very
much
limited by their
ability to access a computer access a
thank you representative weber this is
the system you're referring to is called
new hampshire easy it's simply a website
that connects individuals
with the different services that they
are eligible for
the
multiple
state agencies
and so therefore it depends on how this
bill is interpreted uh is dhhs the lone
state agency or as divisions the agency
david weeders has a lot of information
knowledge around the behind the scenes
mechanics of that website david can you
elaborate
sure so so that new hampshire easy
system or the one stop application for
housing food benefits and
medicaid eligibility
um shares information
specifically internally
so that we can see the eligibility but
then once it gets internally it's shared
externally with our housing providers
and food pantry services so it certainly
would indicate that we would have we
would need to that is one of the many
systems that we would need to modify as
this bill is written to
inform the people
that are applying for those services and
benefits of their choices and so they
would require us to update that system
and how it communicates on the back end
and then out to those provider services
that is one of the larger systems that
we would have modifications to
thank you that's very helpful
are there any other questions from the
committee
yes yes
yes representative cushman thank you
thank you mr chairman
um
so this is for
either one of the information system
um either the
the liaison or the
information system experts
does the person seeking services
currently know
what information is being shared about
them to other
so in the case of all of our systems
when it comes to
like the new hampshire easy that we were
just referring to and
um
that system certainly shows the data
that you're sharing upon an application
and what that information will be shared
in order to provide food
housing and medicaid services
in the case of the closed loop referral
system
again there is a
it's a either digital signature they
could do it by phone or or they can they
they can do it in person without if they
can't sign themselves they would be able
to see a copy of the document of what
their what they're consenting to share
and they would know the information that
they were sharing on the platform itself
and and where that refer where that
information would be shared with in
follow-up
um
so each time that their information is
accessed from a different organization
do they get alerted that their
information is being accessed
and reviewed
thank you mr chair
and representative cushman
they would not be alerted each time that
they would be sharing information
each time a provider accesses their
information
they would be they would be alerted when
they were
initiating a referral so in the case of
a person stopping in for
housing supports
getting a referral for food services
they would be alerted at that time that
they would have a referral for food
services
if there was an additional referral for
sud services they would they would be
notified by their case manager
that they were getting a referral for
those services as well
so from that perspective they would be
it's when that
they would be notified upon referral not
thank you welcome representative gay
thank you mr chair and um this is an i.t
question uh but i guess all three of you
would have an answer how is someone
authorized to access a person or
family's records
i think if i were
if my records were in there
i would certainly know that people are
going to help me need to see them
but
my my personal concern is that if the
database is just open and anybody can
access anything
that's a violation of privacy
can you use keys
so that the people who are authorized
thank you mr chair um and members of the
committee that's a good question
i would say right now
it's very similar to the way you would
sign a consent when you go to hospital
to share your information with your
family member on behalf of yourself
once you sign that consent that person
could request that information at any
time
it's the same with this where we we
would have that consent at the initial
to say we're sharing your information
with these providers for these these
services
and they would be able to request that
information to be able to provide those
services at any time
when it comes to
open access
to
a client's information
that was not referred for services i
will need to reach back out to make sure
that this is addressed however i believe
that it is not open unless you have an
open referral for services
one follow-up okay so if i understood
you properly
there is or will
will be
access authorized access required
so that anybody's records cannot be
accessed just by anybody who can reach
the database it has to be
you have and maybe it's multiple
organizations but they have to be
authorized
to access
that person or family's records that's a
question
thank you for the question
i believe you are correct i will need to
research and validate that 100
however the
the
in the cases of like for many of us i
have i would have access to the system
but i would not have access to
individual records
i would only be able to look at the data
in aggregate as representative hammond
was referring to earlier to a question
of how we would report data we would be
looking at a high level we would not be
able to see the individual record
information because i do not need access
to that so we use a policy of minimal
use which is part of hipaa
to ensure that
if you don't need access to the data you
should not have access to the data
and so the care coordination
team so if you're a case case manager in
housing supports in your case manager
and food services
and you're a case manager in
behavioral health services or mental
health services
and all three of those agencies are
providing services to a single client
all three of those agencies would have
access to the data
however
if you're not providing access to that
individual client and you are another
food service or housing service
you would not have access to that
individual's data
thank you representative cushman
uh thank you mr chairman uh
one final question could could the
person seeking services be currently um
as the system is without this bill being
passed could they be turned down for
services if they don't want their
thank you for the question um the the
answer there is absolutely not no they
don't they do not need to participate in
the platform in order to receive
referrals however it would go to the
secondary process of
making referrals through the system so
they would the individual case worker
depending on which
social services that they're working
with
they would have to take the name and
information and still
get a consent from that individual to
then share the data either by fax or
phone or email
with the other agencies to provide those
services
so though the only difference is that it
would not be on the platform and it
would not be digitally transmitted so
it'd be dependent upon the manual
processes that are currently in place
today
that we're trying to resolve the um the
time to delivery of those services with
representative kelsey you had your hand
up
i did thank you mr chairman um
representative cushman actually asked
the question that i was going to ask so
thank you
um would it this is chairman pearson
would it make it more difficult
to help people
who seek our help
if there was
much less
data
in the system
mr chairman this is jonathan ballard
chief medical officer of dhhs i believe
absolutely
this bill if if passed even as amended
would make it difficult
for persons to receive help obviously
this bill is not targeted towards
the specific services that
uh mr weeders is referring to for
closed-loop referral services for
individuals that need assistance from
dhhs it's much broader it would affect
everyone
and it would
cause
additional barriers to
receiving help if a person were doing a
telemedicine visit and needed services
this bill obviously makes no provision
for
that type of referral to happen without
an in-person signature
there there are many different
facets that this bill would cause that
would stop persons from receiving the
help that they need throughout the
thank you very much
the three people from dhhs
we are we do not have very many people
who wish to speak so i want to press on
we will be taking a half an hour break
when we finish this but i do not wish to
continue it
only for about a 20-minute continuance
at another date
the chair recognizes
uh former senator
robert clegg
who identifies himself as a lobbyist and
is
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i'm here to represent carolyn
virtue
who is from
case management
i'm sorry granite case management
she's a
member of the medical care advisory
committee and they were meeting this
morning so she couldn't be here herself
she does want you to know that the dhh
contract
that this is trying to amend and fix
was put in place
to add a closed-loop referral platform
in new hampshire
using care monies or care act money
and was passed without approval of the
counselors
the contract was a sole source to a
vendor which is not hipaa compliant
and there are many closed loop referral
platforms available many are hippo
require compliant
and that we need to understand that some
of new hampshire's mcos and larger
hospitals utilize their own hipaa
compliant data sharing platforms already
the move to create and endorse a system
of non-medical providers to share new
hampshire's citizens health information
requires further study in her opinion by
the legislature
new hampshire currently does not define
social service agency in law or rule
and she asks that you carefully consider
creating and defining social services
agency
without further delay
the sponsors are likely referring to the
information and referral systems service
link and 2-1-1
these systems are not health care
providers or social service agencies
they do not employ the trained staff
which would rise to using the definition
provided in the bill
as filed or the amendment
at the very least if those systems are
to be transformed into actual health
care delivery systems careful
consideration should be given to the
establishment of the same
the bill turns them into something they
are not without guidance for the
transformation
closed-loop referral systems begin with
the management of physician practices
and patient referrals to coordinate
medical care
this is outside the capacity of the
current service link system
carolyn would urge the committee to
leave health care delivery to qualified
professionals
and care providers which are governed by
state and federal guidance including the
federal health insurance portability and
accountability act
hipaa privacy rule creating social
service agency and statute
allows for quasi provision of health
care outside of existing state and
federal government
the bill seeks to codify an idea which
adds yet another layer of bureaucracy to
new hampshire's health care
infrastructure
without removing layers of similar
services which may result in further
duplication of systems
while carolyn agrees there may be some
merit to a closed loop referral system
new hampshire is ill-prepared to move
into a state of state-run system at this
time
we do not possess the necessary
framework to implement it the whole
program should be suspended until the
legislature has legislated their will
and the will of those they represent on
the initiative itself
creating a form for a program the
legislature has not endorsed for
implementation
in effect creates the program more than
a form is needed to effectively
legislate
and create this system a system with
proper privacy protections in place for
those individuals served
data storage information sharing and
referral management solutions are
powerful tools
streamlining process through in the
cloud referral routing tracking for
health care delivery system with
multiple care locations
hospitals clinics specialists practices
site care can produce efficiency however
we must keep in the adverse
we must keep
in the adverse
a system is if not properly managed or
maintained it may duplicate other
practices and be subjected to
breaches
the legislature should consider
the value of information once collected
how will it be or not be shared how long
will information be stored
and how can an individual revoke
permission for sharing
can the information be sold how costly
will a system be
once the current money is not available
to fund it she wishes to point out that
right now the care money
would would provide the the the money to
to make this happen
but what happens when there is no care
money
she thanks you for your consideration
and i can answer any questions that i
can but she will be available and more
than happy to speak to anyone who would
like to understand and i hope that most
of you know carolyn has been 40 years
helping the elderly who are
who stay at home rather than in nursing
homes so she's well aware and well
versed in
how dangerous this this system could be
to them
thank you senator clegg
representative gay
thank you mr chair and thank you
senator clay
i guess i'm coming
[Music]
i really have a question because i'm
really lost
this bill was
as i understand it the attempt was to
give people an option to restrict how
far their personal information would be
disseminated
by using a common database
from what you're saying it sounds like
you're addressing the whole issue of
whether we should have
a closed system which i assume is a
database
um
is that is that right that you're
talking about we should not
right now without knowing more we
shouldn't be adopting a closed system
whereas i'm coming in here not knowing
not thinking i'm agreeing to it i'm
trying to restrict access to it
are
trying to restrict how the data gets out
am i am i lost here
thank you representative gate no you're
not lost representative ammon saw a
system that suddenly showed up
that had no privacy protection
and he did
the right thing in the sense that he
went out and said let me see if i can
protect the privacy
we're hitting it from the fact that
we've adopted something or we have
something in the state of new hampshire
that nobody knew about somebody walked
in and said hey i think this is a good
idea
and under the current system
the governor said yeah okay let's do it
it hasn't come before any legislative
body yet to see whether or not it's good
and as i understood it from
the
previous speakers from the department of
health and human services it obviously
didn't have their input before it was
started because typically
some of the things that they were
talking about would have been corrected
before it ever hit your desks
so we're hitting it from the fact that
while i i think what representative
ammon did is a lot of well i think he
did a great job
he's trying to fix something
that is so broken i'm not sure it should
any other questions
saying none thank you for your testimony
and
we uh i did not get this notice until
just now but uh senator uh sorry about
that representative jess edwards
um
was in the queue so senator golly am i
promoting you representative edwards
you're free to testify before
thank you
this is representative jess edwards
representing
rockingham district four
last term i was a member of the mental
health and social service business
process alignment and information system
interoperability study committee
which shows that uh legislatures can run
on two long naming committees but um
i i i think we did some really good work
there under the leadership of senator
khan we recognized that
that there's this tremendous opportunity
to manage community care
through the state and we saw that
psychiatrists were precluded by federal
law or excuse me state law in a way that
was too restrictive relative to federal
law
so that psychiatrists couldn't really
participate as full members of this core
this care community coordination
community so we submitted a bill to
change ad i think that bill passed i
lost track of it but so i'm coming at
this letting you know i respect the need
and the value of coordinated care
but one of the things i i think we've
picked up on on several
of these kind of bills over the last
couple years
is that
we don't have enough respect
for
the privacy rights of our individual
citizens
and we end up getting these communities
uh
entities together that say it would be
easier it would be better if we could
just uh
take this information and use it to help
our patients
and they do that from a goodness of
their heart and a dedication to their
mission
but the patients the individual patients
who own their own
data are not usually at the table
so so i come at this and generally in
support of 601 i don't like the the fact
that the form got put in there i think
representative merchant talked to that i
think it's a mistake to put
forms into legislation um that's a good
jail car activity but even more to
represent shapiro's earlier point
the intent i think of 601 is to be
consistent with hipaa
i don't think we should be making
redundant documentation for health care
providers
to the extent
that
opt-in
would be required i think it should just
become integrated in all the hipaa forms
and that's
and the way to do that is not to put it
in this legislation but to to
to write the legislation in a way in
which
the legislature reaffirms its um
commitment to our newest
constitutional amendment to protect
privacy
and uh to make sure that the entities
that work for us while they're trying to
do great work for our citizens but they
also do it fully respectful of the fact
that citizens own their data and it
isn't the property of the state until
the citizen actively agrees to give them
their data
so um so that so that's really the end
of my uh testimony thank you for
allowing me to speak mr chair would you
take any questions representative
uh
would you take any questions
representative in anticipation of your
future demotion to the senate
yes i would
no hands are up sorry you're on your own
yes yes my hand oh betty uh
representative gay is wishing to ask
the
future senator a question
thank you mr chair for not hitting me
and thank you representative edwards
i you know i'm in full agreement with
you so what is your recommendation about
601 since we're we're offered what we're
offered is this going to
help
uh if we took the form out
um
because that will
you know hopefully the wording either is
or can be made more in line to support
hipaa for
all these social
social needs
what do you recommend
what do i recommend uh i would never
step on the
chairman's toes and i don't know how
busy you are
i i don't think this the bill is well
intentioned and as much as i support it
i don't think the way it's written it's
ready to pass in its current state so
what does that mean to the committee
does this mean you want to retain it do
you want to work on it do you want to
you know it feels to me after two or
three terms of hearing about privacy
issues
it may be a good time for us to take a
study committee that just solely and
only looks at the extent to which um our
health care system is working in in in
collaborative ways to uh protect the
right of privacy of patients and the
right to consent and the right to to uh
share that consent amongst the community
of providers i if this if this became a
study committee that only looked at
systemically what are we doing overall
to protect patient privacy that that may
not be the worst idea i've had this week
thank you representative for observing
my where my feet are they're about 30
miles away from you but thank you
uh what you just said sounds like a
wonderful thing that you could work on
over the summer and file this
legislation in the fall and i've already
said to um representative ammon that
we're really jammed up here and study
committees
to make a bill better
we're not going to use a lot of them
however i also told them that while
we're having a big exec session next
week i would be happy to wait an extra
week should an amendment be suggested to
him
so with that uh let's see no hands are
up thank you representative edwards
and now the chair calls on my
predecessor as the custodian of bad
jokes and awful puns in the house
and by that i mean of course retired
mr chairman can you hear me yes mr kirk
good morning to you sir and to members
of the committee for the record i'm neil
kirk i live in where and i support this
bill however
after hearing the testimony from
former senator clegg
and the testimony from
the folks at health and human services
i think this bill is not ready for prime
time however
simply itlling it or turning it into a
study committee is not going to solve
the problem that we're currently faced
with
therefore this is my conclusion i'll
support it later
therefore i think we need to have a
moratorium
on this particular
closed-loop system
which was funded by the cares act
through the executive council and is
with a company or an organization called
unite space us
that's the organization
that the
department is contracted with to provide
this system
if there's a moratorium on that we will
have time to
do the right thing
with respect to privacy and that is
focus not as broadly as apparently this
bill does but focus on that particular
system um
here's the situation we're currently
faced with
we've just passed a constitutional
amendment on privacy
and this is the first time that i'm
aware of that a new
database is being created
the pdmp
and
the vaccine databases were created years
ago before the privacy amendment this is
the first one that's being created
afterwards and as senator clegg
mentioned there is no legislative
authorization for this
it simply went through the covet process
so the legislature i need i think needs
to take back ownership of this put in a
moratorium to give it an opportunity to
determine what kinds of privacy
protections should go with this new
system consistent with the
amendment
now
there are two kinds of people seeking
services in this system people for whom
the state is paying like on medicaid and
the entire self-pay self-insured private
pay group they're all included under
this bill excuse me under this system
and the state seems to be expanding its
interest in collecting information not
just on the medicaid people and other
people for which it pays
for everybody else in the in the state
who are paying their own way or are
having private insurance pay their way
that's an extraordinary expansion
of
activity on the part of the department
the key thing about that this bill is
trying to address and it was i think
intended only for the unite us system
not for 911
not for
any of the other systems that the state
may have
was to make sure that the consent was
real
that it was in very clear language what
you were consenting to and what the
consequences were and it was also very
clear this is the second thing that
informed consent not only means that you
give your consent
but that if you don't give your consent
you are not subjected to penalty that is
a denial of services or some other
penalty without both of those two things
you don't have i think you would have in
this case a clear violation of the
constitution
um the reason for putting a number of
you have raised this question the reason
for putting the specific
um
nature of the consent form into statute
was that when the legislature has not
done this as in the case of the vaccine
registry in the case of pdmp
the kinds of consent forms that the
department comes up with and that are
indeed approved by gelcar
don't really reflect legislative intent
and don't meet the two criteria that
i've just indicated
fully informed consent and
acknowledgement to the individual that
if you don't give us consent you can
still get the service if you don't have
that
what do you have indeed i checked in
north carolina where unite us is already
in play and they have consent forms out
there and i believe you should have
received by email a copy of the north
carolina consent form
it's very clear or it's not very clear
what you're consenting to and it's also
very unclear what happens if you don't
give your consent
that to me is exactly what we don't want
to happen in new hampshire
there is a reference in that consent
form to the privacy policy but that's
four pages of dense legalese and of
course we all know that no one reads
that
so
in summation um
the bill as presented to you including
the amendment
uh does not deal with all of the issues
that have been raised by people who
opposed to it and even though i support
the concept as representative edwards
does
um the bill is not i think ready for
prime time
if you do not put in a moratorium if you
simply retain it
the system will go ahead the department
will go through the rule making process
and so forth and the legislature will
have no input into the system and when
in fact the retained bill
is brought forward next year the system
will be in play and as representative
ammon said the horse will be out of the
barn
so my request to you is that you
or that representative ammon rewrite
this in a way that there is a moratorium
and that um
the uh committee will act on this or
other legislation will be placed
into into the hopper for next year thank
you mr chairman i'd be pleased to answer
any questions
i have one representative uh kirk it it
sounds like from is it true from what
you were saying that you would be
willing to help
representative ammon do this
yes that is true
any other questions representative gay
i thank you mr chair and and thank you
uh your honorable her very much for
calling
how do we
place a moratorium on a project that we
didn't initiate
i mean it's fine with me i'm ready to do
it but how do we do it
um thank you for the question
representative gay you simply ask
legislative services to draft it and
any other questions of
former representative kirk
seeing none thank you and good to hear
your voice again thank you mr chairman
the chair recognizes lucy hotter
um
if miss hotter would put up her hand i'm
not seeing her in the list
our list is alphabetized by first name
which is not always helpful but that's
okay
but i don't see her in the list mr
chairman thank you should she pop up we
can come back to her i also see
erin e-r-i-n-e with apologies if i
mispronounced it last name gray aaron
gray
and i just had aaron gray
and
she was she's the third one on the list
hi uh good morning okay yep it just it
just came up to the top i had her
without her hand up
and she is now
permitted which makes me think that
maybe
uh christina is back but anyway go ahead
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is aaron gray and
my company aunt bertha runs findhelp.org
the largest referral network for social
services in the united states we are a
public benefit corporation based in
austin texas and we have earned the
trust of more than 300 customers
including the states of florida south
carolina pennsylvania and more than 200
health care organizations including many
that do business in new hampshire
when we learned that the state of new
hampshire was interested in implementing
a statewide referral network we were
obviously delighted we met with the
state but they decided to move in a
different direction because our solution
did not meet their specifications
i'm not here today to complain about
that decision or ask you to somehow
reverse that we have our relationships
in the state and we plan to be here for
the long term
the reason why i'm here is to support
hb601 which in no way based on my
experience dramatically changes the
direction the state is heading
but will ensure the protection of
individual privacy
there's a stigma that comes with needing
social services and it's important that
we all recognize that that stigma exists
for example on our network we see search
activity in new hampshire for food and
housing but we also see a rising need
for addiction services mental health
counseling even domestic abuse support
we certainly believe the ability to
quickly refer people to help is critical
during an economic crisis
with a growing need for electronic
access to social services comes a
corresponding need to make sure people's
information is protected on our networks
we do not share personal information
unless the person in need knows who has
access to it
right now that's not the way new
hampshire is heading in fact the state
identified it was looking for a company
that embraced an all-in-consent approach
i would quote reduce the number of
informed consents needed
to connect clients with services
the approach outlined in the contract
would then create a master client index
in which members of the network could
indeed search
and retrieve people's personal
information now some would say that's
perfectly okay since the person in need
is agreeing to an informed consent
the trouble with the all in consent
described is that not only
is it truly informed since the network
of individuals and organizations that
could have access is not defined the
term network is vague the person has no
idea who can see their information now
or in the future
who makes up the network the network as
currently defined can be anybody who has
been trained in works or volunteers at
any non-profit healthcare institution
or government agency in the entire state
of new hampshire so this imposes ethical
important ethical considerations would
people that receive this help in this
manner worry that someone in their
church might find out that they were
survivors of incest or domestic abuse
what if the person needing help worked
at the state and they were going through
some tough financial times would they
worry that their coworkers might know
that they can't feed their family
public health agencies are spending a
lot of time and attention addressing the
social determinants of health because
studies show that if people's basic
needs are met they tend to be healthier
some may say that all in consent is
needed to perform care coordination of
our neediest among us
our organizations has set up these types
of networks with over 300 customers and
millions of people and in no way has
care coordination been hindered by a
truly informed consent model as it
currently stands the consent process
does not appropriately consider these
ethical dilemmas about information
sharing
that's why we would support a better
approach like the one outlined in hb 601
that should create the right balance
between the state's interests and which
are very important interests outlined by
the department and that of your citizens
thank you for your testimony
the name of our company
uh would you repeat the name of the
group that you are representing or
speaking on behalf of uh yes i i'm the
founder of anne bertha which is uh runs
the
organization findhelp.org you're garbled
a bit would you spell the name
a-u-n-t
bertha as in the name b-e-r-t-h-a
oh i was going to ask you to say hi to
your aunt bertha for me it's in your
email address
it's inspired by my mother who uh was
disabled at a young age but she was very
much the person in the neighborhood
helping others so thanks for asking
thank you
oh okay
we represent we we welcome
representative snow to the meeting and
would you tell us uh where you are and
thank you uh thank you mr chairman this
is ken snow i'm in my apartment in
manchester and my wife is present
elsewhere in the apartment
and i'm sorry i'm tidy but i had a
doctor's appointment
welcome to the meeting
and we have
christine
stoddard who's interested in testifying
would you put your hand up please so we
i am not seeing christine stoddard
and do we have lucy harder um i have a
message from representative kirk
who says that
lucy hodder was is not able to attend at
this time
i have no one else on my list is there
i see no other hands mr chairman seeing
that none then i bring this hearing to
i beg your pardon sorry
um i have a gary cahoon whose hand has
just gone up
he just got in under the gavel drop yes
uh mr cahoon you'll have to unmute
i'm sorry can you hear me
yes we can now
okay
uh thank you mr chairman uh members of
the committee for the opportunity to
speak very briefly on house bill 601
um
much of what i wanted to say was was
encompassed in dr ballard's testimony
and um
mr kirk's testimony
but i would simply like to make the
point that i understand from
um
representative ammon's testimony that
the intent of the bill
was to require a consent form to have
one's name entered into a registry being
established by the department of health
and human services
however the plain language of the bill
doesn't say that anywhere
um and by the plain language of the bill
it's very broad as dr ballard pointed
out and very general and would apply to
all health care as i read it to all
health care providers under any
circumstances
what that would mean to me as the
owner and operator of friendship manner
in new ipswich which is a residential
care or assisted living home
is that if i had a resident who came in
and opted out in other words if they
said no i don't give my permission
by the plain language of the bill it
appears to me that if mrs jones who came
in and opted out later had a stroke and
i had to send her out to the hospital
without her specific commission
permission which she might not be able
to give i couldn't tell the hospital her
name
her address her phone number
her social security number her insurance
number or any other demographic
information that the hospital would
require
um so my point is simply that the bill
as written doesn't really address what
it's trying to achieve and is britain
much too generally
thank you very much would you take
questions mr cahoon i would be happy to
does anyone have a question for mr
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman
mr cahoon are you aware that there are
provisions in the health information
portability and accountability act
for giving information in emergency
situations to providers who will be
continuing here
i am
and uh upon admission we have residents
sign uh
a release of information in an emergency
it's it's also true under the hipaa act
for example that the fact that a
resident is a is at friendship manner is
up
i bring this hearing to a close and we
have a half an hour break we will
oh this was the fastest lunch i ever
made
you've got you
you
foreign
i'm getting a message from ms dyer
saying if somebody in the committee room
ugh
it appears to me that the committee room
is still muted
i think he's waiting for a couple
minutes until lunch is officially over
okay no problem
or who was in communication with whom
here
thank you so much because you said
you're 25.
now
i
i feel like can't living in that
commercial can you hear me now
yeah i'm going to encourage i'm going to
encourage that from now on when they
recognize somebody they say please on
you
because we waste
20 seconds every time
waiting nobody says nothing
it's it's not that easy it takes me that
long for them to be moved over from the
list
that's waiting to testify to the
uh list of people who are
authorized to testify so most of them do
actually unmute quite promptly once they
have gotten the ability to do so
i mean it only takes a split second to
say please unmute
this is the continuation of the hearing
on house bill 246 establishing
a protective order for vulnerable adults
house bill 246
and we have what i see to be only
six
people signed up to testify
on today's list
christina do you see more than six
they're actually uh closer to 12 but i
do think that some folks from the prior
hearing may not have signed up this time
so there may be some hands that come in
i did see some as late as
people signing up as late as noon
at this point since there are only 12
we will allow each person testifying
two minutes and after two minutes the
individual will be muted no one will
hear anything else after two minutes and
we will go on to the next person
we do this to allow everyone who wishes
to speak the opportunity to do so
and so that we may finish our schedule
because
of the covid virus we
are way behind in the work we need to do
with that the chair recognizes
representative
an island republican attorney who moved
i do wonder if we do have a phone number
um with a hand raised i'm wondering if
that might be representative silver i'm
going to check the number on the remote
testimonials
i don't see that that's the number
listed
for that chairman would you like me to
allow the phone number person to talk
and see who it is
no let me go through the names and
then ask people once they hear their
name immediately make sure that your
hand is raised the chair recognizes doug
mcnutt who identifies himself as a
thank you
mr chair can everyone hear me we can
okay great i won't take up much of your
time but i just wanted my name is doug
mcnutt for the record and i'm the
associate state director for advocacy
for aarp new hampshire
and we represent over 220 000 members
statewide in new hampshire
in a past life
i was the director of elderly and adult
services and
i was responsible for the adult
protection program
and have been involved in a series of
pieces of legislation related to elder
abuse and neglect
and exploitation
so i wanted to just comment on a few
things and then i'd be happy to answer
any questions first of all
a lot was raised at the hearing about
you know due process issues and i guess
the one thing i would just like to point
out is that a lot of this bill is based
on the domestic violence statute which
has been in effect for many years i
think perhaps 20
and has worked fairly well and the
courts are quite used to it
with regard to some of the other pieces
related to firearms and pieces like that
it's my impression that people might
have been really kind of testifying to
previous versions of the bill it's my
sense that the bill has been
dramatically
um
altered since that for those first
couple of sessions and i'm not sure that
that stuff remains relevant
uh at this point
so i think it's really important we
focus on the bill and its current
iteration and not be focused on what
what it was at one time and lastly i
just let me just say that
in my experience in working with adult
protection
a lot of and also with the criminal
justice system a lot of the justice
happens after the fact and particularly
when you're talking about things like
exploitation
once the crime has been committed it's
fine to prosecute
the perpetrator but if the money is gone
and i think it might be that
representative weber testified to
something like this the last time
that's a problem because i certainly
when i was
working in the department of health and
human services as an attorney
there were many instances where we had
people who were victims of exploitation
who ended up
being
on medicaid and nursing homes and in
thank you are there any questions for mr
seeing none i don't see any i don't see
any thank you
i'm going to have to rely upon you
representative i realized i
was just relying on silence
representative marsh is uh on another
hearing
can you hear me yes we can
okay well thank you very much for
allowing me to
uh
testify
uh i want to thank you for the
opportunity um as a senior citizen
uh
i've witnessed abuse aimed at seniors on
two occasions
the first involves a senior
granddaughter who
who was a power of attorney and tasked
to help him um
with his regular daily things and
because a man suffered with epilepsy
instead she withheld his medication of
pension
and uh social security benefits to
extort cash from him
he felt his head on the corner of a
coffee table
when the emts arrived she was present
and he withheld the information about
his lack of medication
short time later she came to visit and
bragged about his spiky about spiking
his drinks he fell twice
the second time he opened the large cut
one of the neighbors called 9-1-1 the
emts came and notified the police
they searched her apartment and found
cash and medications
that he was she was holding back
i don't know how she managed it but her
punishment was a restraining order
prohibiting her from coming any closer
to him 200 feet from his apartment
he passed away a month later
but
it was no key whether they did had no
teeth
a few days later i asked one of the
policemen that was involved
uh what what happened to her and he told
and um
the second one i'd like to talk about is
uh
not it's it's
about old lady who drove regularly no a
very good driving record
but had a son who just decided that her
car belongs to his son
and he took the car
she reported the car was slowing through
local police
the officer questioned her health and
her age
he also made remarks
related to her age
and may be
forgetful
he
intimated that she just didn't know
where the car was
seeing as there's no public
transportation
she now depends on neighbors
senior abuse isn't just referring to
physical damage which does happen
but it includes last me forgery illegal
use of credit cards
the laws regarding that action should be
taken by victims
the the law regarding what actions
should be taken by victims and law
okay you've hit your two minutes um
thank you for your testimony in those
those stories
the chair now recognizes
michael
thornton to speak for no more than two
uh if michael thornton
is on the call could he raise his hand
please
and you need to unmute please
michael thornton 561 north river road
milford new hampshire
chair
state representatives fellow citizens
speaking today as a private citizen and
on this k occasion
as a representative of the new hampshire
firearms coalition
i am and we are opposed to hb 246 and
ask you to find it itl
earlier registration or legislation
deprived accused of many of their rights
including immediate seizure of property
and it presumed guilt unfortunately then
they would have 30 to 40 days or more
and could be found guilty
without jury and only on preponderance
of evidence
in
response to the representative and
attorney who maintained that firearms
are not mentioned in the proposed
legislation
the official pdf
2 43 a.m on the morning of 26 january
line
page 3 lines 20 and 21 quote order
defendant to hand over firearms or
deadly weapons
this does not allow a defendant an
accused to tender their firearms to
another
private individual who could maintain
them safely
at what expense
and to what accountability shall a
person's private property which is
seized
be safeguarded and
damage compensated
the language in the bill requires a
plaintiff to attest that they realize
they're accountable for bearing false
wisdoms
an incompetent person
can provide no such attestation by law
therefore the accused had no protections
under that clause whatsoever
career criminals
yet
due process
can have an attorney appointed at no
cost
none of these
protections seem to apply to a person
merely accused
your intent on your intent on face value
is laudable
as a senior i
appreciate your concerns but please
don't protect me this way
thank you sir
the chair recognizes paul marcus
hello yes
yeah i'm i'm looking over the bill and i
very much agree with uh
what the previous um
testimony
um
i i'm a senior and uh
i have people in and out of my house as
i i have a uh
one of my sons is handicapped and he's
considered a vulnerable adult and we
have uh
aids that uh
are in and out of the house
on a regular basis
um
foreign for issues where
my rights would be infringed because of
of some action
on the part of one of his aides
that um
i don't see how this bill addresses any
of that
uh for the most part
the the bill starts out with a list of
rsas that that uh
already cover
everything that is in this bill
and this bill does not seem to offer any
of any
additional protections
i
noted that the only place where it
mentions firearms in this in this entire
bill at least the copy that i have is
the
rights of the
seek remedy under under other
rsa
if he feels that he's being threatened
in that way
i don't see where that benefits a
vulnerable adult
um
thank you sir christina could you uh let
let us know who else is in the queue to
testify
uh it's representative weber and um
i have
hands from
a telephone number
and from penny dean
uh i know that um
buzz sure was in the line was on the
call
um and i thought it's signed up to speak
but i don't know if he has or not the
hand is not up the hand is now up so
i've got a telephone line penny dean and
buzz sure with hands up
let's try the telephone number and see
what who's there
okay uh telephone ending in 276.
um
you are going to have to unmute yourself
uh and you've done that
can you folks hear me yep
um
my name is james gaffney i live in
warner and uh
this bill should be itl this same bill
has essentially come up now three years
in a row and the same people keep
pointing out the same issues with the
bill and nobody seems to be listening
i really wish that folks would
would
pay attention
and address the low-hanging fruit i.e
addressing the the exploitation
you know of of financial issues and and
take the rest of the the bs out of the
bill because it would be
non-controversial then right um the new
hampshire constitution article 19
already guarantees
that
in cases where there's more than fifteen
hundred dollars of property involved in
the case that a person in a civil case a
person has a right
to a jury trial
this bill goes against constitutional
guarantee
furthermore it has an a point in it
where it says that they will be
important
yeah thank you may i get my time back
please
no you haven't started talking over you
representative weber will let me know
when the person is muted
and i i believe we're all set i hope we
are all set and i have stopped the clock
so uh your time's been added back i
think they say in football please add 15
seconds to the clock
thank you this bill is i mean we already
have rsa 631 one through three for
assault and reckless conduct criminal
threatening is under six thirty three
four sexual assault is six thirty six
thirty 632 a2 through 632 a5
interference with freedom is defined in
633 1 through 633 3a destruction of
property is 63 634 1 through
four six thirty four two unauthorized
entry is rsa
635 one
and two harassment is six forty four
four cruelty to animals is six forty
four eight we can go on and on down the
line as far as protections that are
already in place for people that that we
don't need another bill to do
what we need the bill to do is to start
next time
thank you very much
and ms dean you need to unmute
sorry i unmuted mine but not the one on
the screen i'm presuming you can hear me
now
thank you my name is penny dean i'm from
concord new hampshire i'm an attorney
licensed to practice in maine new
hampshire and massachusetts and admitted
to the federal courts in the united
states district court for the district
of new hampshire maine massachusetts
first circuit court of appeals the
united states supreme court and the d.c
circuit and i ask that you itl this bill
um for those who have suggested that
those calling in to ask that the bill be
ital have not read the current version
i can most certainly assure this
committee i and many others have read
the current version and just because the
authors took the term firearms out does
not mean that firearms will still not be
taken from those accused here and i can
tell you that if i made those
representations before a judge with this
language i would very quickly be fined
and sanctioned because it's disingenuous
to say the least
the author had admittedly
in the initial testimony that they had
copied federal law and that is
absolutely correct and i think what's
most important to know
is if you look at federal law which is
18 usc section 922 g8
that is a federal prohibition
from an order that basically says if a
person is subject to a court order that
restrains a person from harassing
stalking or threatening an intimate
partner or child of such intimate
partner but before you say well gee
we're not just always talking about
intimate partners do you have to look
further to 18 usc
921 a 32 because the definition of
intimate partner is not what you might
think it is
furthermore if one looks at page five of
the spill line 16 through 18.
if a person is granted relief
the person who they're granted relief
against
it makes it statutorily explicit a
finding of abuse exploitation or neglect
shall mean the defendant represents a
credible threat to the safety of the
plaintiff or physical mental or
financial well-being that is exactly the
federal language that requires they take
your guns away
so for someone to say oh we took all the
guns out of here yeah you took
um
the term firearm out of the bill
but what you did is leave the results in
wow
nope two minutes is for everybody
thank you counselor i'd like to call on
joseph
is it a bayer or ebert from the new
it is uh joseph ebert eb ert and i am a
captain with the new hampshire state
police uh thank you so much for giving
me the opportunity to talk this morning
or this afternoon this case may be um i
want to say first that clearly the state
police is interested in
any way of reducing
harm to our elders
i think as we reviewed this bill we did
have some concern attorney dean was
actually referring to a
portion of the statute which caused us
some concern uh in that it seems to uh
take away the statute of limitations and
that's under 173 d colon 6
subsection 6
roman numeral 2.
so it seems to take away the statute of
limitations
and it also puts in there that standard
of mental well-being
in in review and conversation about this
our concern was that uh if 20 to 30
years had passed uh and somebody was
bringing this vote it would be very
difficult for some a member of law
enforcement to determine what had caused
the intervening
issues in an individual's life we're all
impacted by a number of different
factors
so when we stretch out over a
significant period of time it becomes
very difficult to determine what was the
what is the true factor if only one uh
that is causing a person mental uh
well-being stress
so that's what we wanted to bring
forward today and i'm certainly happy to
representative gay has a question to
clarify your testimony captain
and i would ask the captain to unmute
because i am afraid i muted him when i
thought there were no questions not not
a problem i'm back
absolutely
are you for or against this bill
yes so the uh the division of state
police has not taken a uh a stance on
the bill itself and i know that uh can
be disappointing um to both sides
but the direction i got was to look at
this procedurally and not to endorse or
oppose this particular bill
thank you
thank you that's helpful
thank you uh mr chair and members of the
committee my name is uh albert buzz sher
i'm a professor at unh law the opinions
i expressed today are mine only not
those of unh law or unh
in durham
i testify in support of
excuse me hb246
um i really all i want to talk about is
there's been a good bit of hyperbole uh
from what i've heard about the concept
of due process and how this violates due
process in so many different ways i
teach in the area of due process i
practiced in
the new hampshire criminal justice
system i'm familiar with what due
process is
this statute does not violate anyone's
due process rights due process is not a
fixed entity
um it is a sliding scale entity
depending on the nature of the right at
stake like if we're going to violate
your parole you have very significant
due process rights if we're gonna you
know take away
uh you know a piece of candy you have
far less due process rights um and um
this you know i'm very familiar with
these kind of statutes i i was opposed
to
legislation last session on
red flag legislation
which i think
which took away
potentially took away someone's
constitutional right to possess a gun
under the new hampshire
constitution
and i was opposed to that legislation on
due process rights
this statute does not have due process
problems
uh it it
it it is uh much more moderate than the
red flag legislation which had very
significant due process problems uh this
statute uh does not have uh due process
uh problems i'm looking at my notes
it is very similar to domestic violence
statutes all of which have pro have
survived due process challenges
so
given
the rights that are at stake here
as compared to those rights at stake
when more significant due process is
given
i don't think as a constitutional matter
thank you professor sure for your
testimony
the chair recognizes uh former state
representative j.r hull
good afternoon chair can you hear me yes
i can jr representative
thank you
i am
i am speaking on behalf of myself as
well as the new hampshire firearms
coalition we are adamantly opposed to
this bill it is good to know that a
number of people have brought up the
fact that firearms issues are in fact
related to this bill
both the proponents for the bill as well
as the opponents of the bill recognize
the fact that this has real issues
regarding the firearm the
the
for the firearms owners in the state of
new hampshire as well as for the elders
those who want to pass this bill claim
it's about financial issues however they
have not written a bill that does that
this bill is verbatim with house bill
1660 as vetoed by the governor less than
a year ago
i would ask that the committee fined
this bill itl until the the issues
um that were in the bill last year are
resolved
minor tweaks are not sufficient
it is clear from the language that you
violate numerous protections in our
constitution both state and federal
till that language is corrected please
kill this bill thank you
thank you
representative and we seem to have
representative norm silber back on the
line
can you hear me okay yes we can
uh sorry that i was delayed my schedule
is all messed up uh i'm speaking for
myself
uh i'm opposed to the bill i call this
bill
as a zombie bill because it was killed
in the last biennium in a different form
a slightly different form
it's been brought forth in another like
i said a slightly different form
even though
the proponents would like to say it has
nothing to do with second amendment or
firearms issues
it really does that's the undercurrent
here and this is just a a a disguised
effort
to without very much due process
seize firearms from people that someone
else thinks are vulnerable and it's
something that is really
against the constitution so i would urge
that the committee find it inexpedient
to legislate thank you
thank you representative the chair calls
uh hello uh good afternoon members of
the committee my name is joe hannon i'm
a former state rep and also i'm a vice
president for gun owners of new
hampshire
uh i'm testifying in opposition to this
bill and we ask the itl it i don't want
to repeat what everyone else has said
like penny dean about
the
legal implications of why this is wrong
but i do want to just reiterate one
thing the it does
even though the the authors of the bill
have claimed that it's removed the words
firearms and i believe the original
versions this bill had firearms
mentioned 30 plus times in it
uh taking the words out and changing
some of the language does not remove the
fact that this would trigger a federal
prohibition to own firearms for many
people
and there are ways to do that in cases
of domestic violence and other abuse and
other crimes but this expands that even
greater in an area that i i don't think
people are comprehending um from one
side of this debate so we ask that you
itl this bill and um
that's about it i appreciate it thank
you
thank you
the chair recognizes john
schmidt
yeah i just like to say that i agree
with a whole bunch of others here who
have
i think correctly said that this could
be used for gun confiscation
but my concern is not just gun
confiscation it's confiscation of
anything
i don't believe the government should be
able to
confiscate life liberty or property
without due process and constitutionally
due process as a trial by jury of your
peers
not even
by just a ruling of an unelected judge
and i think in new hampshire all our
judges are unelected
thank you
thank you sir
the chair recognizes someone calling in
from area code 617
good afternoon mr chairman
and members of the committee
my name is jay simkin
20 cabot drive nashua new hampshire
uh i offer points that i have not heard
anyone else make
first point is
that
someone who is alleged to have violated
this
enactment if an act minute b
faces
an uphill
fight
most folks think of litigation as judge
judy
someone who is alleged to have violated
the terms of this enactment
faces tens of thousands of dollars in
attorney's fees and costs to contest the
allegations brought against them
very few new hampshire residents can
without
much thought write checks
note the plural for
six eight ten twelve thousand dollars
thus
this bill should be itl'd unless it has
put into it
a provision
that any person alleged to have violated
the terms of this bill
should have their
attorney's
fees and costs
reimbursed
by the state from taxpayer funds
in full
at their attorneys
and
the experts that their attorneys may
choose to hire
normal hourly rates
without that
a person alleged to have
done something wrong within the terms of
this law
is simply going to be railroaded
i speak from experience not in new
hampshire but in massachusetts
a lawless licensor
in massachusetts who wasn't as an
attorney
determined that he was going to revoke
my license to carry firearms he did sell
it costs
well over a hundred thousand dollars for
me to get back my license which was
restored to me by order of the supreme
judicial court of massachusetts from
which you can reasonably infer i had
i did not give
people the chance i didn't look around
the room i didn't look at my phone
i think there may have been a question
for uh penny dean a lawyer who had
testified before and
i miss dean wishes to come back um
what i'll do
uh is give you about a half a minute for
a rape raise or an additional point and
then to be fair see if there's a
question for you in your professional
capacity so please unmute penny dean for
this dean is unmuted
thank you chair yes and i want to
apologize for speaking so fast i had
many many more points to make but given
the allotted time i could not make them
i respectfully disagree with my
professor that due process is
solved in this particular bill there's
been different iterations but the way it
is now because it mirrors the language
of federal law
i think that
the state police has also identified one
of the many many flaws in the bill and
because i'm given 30 seconds i can't go
through them but i'm happy to answer any
questions that committee members may
have and point out many other defects in
i'm going to allow one question and
again that is because this is a bit
unusual so i'll allow one question and
if
representative folsom would pose her
question thank you mr chairman um thank
you ms dean
my question is um
acknowledging that you did talk really
really fast and i was not able to jot
down some of the things you said
would you be willing to submit some
written testimony with the information
to the committee
email
she's muted i bet if she's muted you can
unmute her
for her answer to that question and that
only
he is available i can't unmute her she
has to unmute herself i did on mute my
can you hear me because i did unmute
myself
so the question is and this is all we're
recognizing you for is will you submit
written testimony to the committee of
everything else you have to say
um with all due respect i don't think i
have the time to do that in order to do
that properly in a lawyer job would
probably take about six hours because
there are huge flaws
and i started to write them down just to
prepare for this hearing took a couple
hours thank you you have
used your time
is there anyone else
in which case
i uh
closed this hearing on house bill 246
and i do have a question for my
predecessor i have several bills in my
exec file
but none of them was from today
and am i correct in believing that
while i may exec any bill from today
in order to exec a previous bill that
must be published noticed uh much as i
hate to admit it no no mr chairman what
the
notice says is that executive session on
pending legislation which is all pending
legislation
may be held throughout the day time
permitting from the time the committee
is initially convened
so um that is the notice and under the
notice that has been given
you are free to take up any bill that
has finished its hearing
with no disrespect to uh your yourself
or
your wisdom
i would like to uh put everything on
mute for about five minutes so i can
call the clerk for confirmation of that
i would be i would feel safe for myself
i'm entirely happy for you to do so it's
it's a policy i disagree with but i
think that that's what the policy is but
by all means be guided by the clerk
thank you
uh actually
mr chairman i bring up something though
about the last one and i'm sorry i i
missed this
during the testimony there was a person
named mike thornton who had written in
an email to the committee stating that
he had waited to testify before and
wanted to be able to testify today but i
do not know if he resigned up he had
apparently signed up i see him still
listed in the attendees
and
i asked him to raise his hand at the end
if he had not been called upon and i
didn't act quickly enough to let you
know i do not know if you could go back
representative canark he uh last time
you remember they got a minute this time
mr thornton was given two minutes so yes
he did testify too he did i'm sorry i
actually missed it then okay sorry
no no offense taken
[Music]
bye
so hey everybody
well he's hard at work
i had to present one of my bills in edna
last week
i must say they were nowhere near as
warm and friendly as this group is the
comments we got about that were
astounding and um it was just there
wasn't any nice chit chat they would
they didn't seem to be
particularly
friendly and actually i i have not had a
chance to do it yet but i will send you
all
those who are old-timers will remember
gina powers
gina powers is a lobbyist um
and uh she had a baby about 14 months
ago
and we haven't seen her here but she was
in one of the committee hearings she
sent a picture of her 14 14 month old
daughter standing watching entrance as
we had our session she said the only
thing that would get her daughter quiet
was listening to our committee hearing
so we now have a new thing we can add in
this one of our skill sets is pacifying
toddlers
we're boring
yeah
she thought it might have been the in
utero exposure that she had listening to
us before
that made it feel all soft cozy and
cuddly for her daughter
um i'll try to remember to get that
picture i got her permission to send a
picture
oh
we are set
and the ruling from
the um
cleric is yes we can exec
anything
uh
i would really rather exact the things
that
won't come out 11 10 from before i
really wouldn't
i want to do the things
just to burn up some exact stuff
that i think we could all pretty well
get our minds around
yet again representative canaric an
illustration
of what you've discovered over the years
this is the best committee in the house
well on that happy note do you want me
to uh um
present a couple because i did a couple
of the amendments on the cannabis bills
and i can present those
well i would but i want to do one first
oh go ahead if i may thank you very much
and this
house bill 247
oh wait a minute
we are now in exec session
this is house bill 247 relative to
treatment alternatives for opioids
and
dr
lundgren a chiropractor who also
represents rockingham district 5 and i
had a lengthy conversation about the
bill
and
we
if you remember most of us found there
was some really good ideas and certainly
great sentiment in this but it sure
wasn't ready for prime time
nor could we probably get it ready on
the on the fast
so what he suggested
is that we retain
this bill
he will work on it we will send it out
for a fiscal note and um
that would be the motion that the bill's
primary sponsor is comfortable with over
the summer we would get
some folks together and work on this
bill and come fall we would see it in a
much improved version
so i would entertain on his behalf
the
representative gay so moved and
representative king
seconded it
and
we thank you for representative
soloway's enthusiasm as always
so any question on this bill
i see no hands up mr chairman i would
just state for myself if you would care
to recognize me i recognize
representative webber thank you um i
would just say i think that that's a
very good resolution i think there's
some some excellent policy in the bill
but i also think that the execution is
going to be really difficult as written
so i i think that working on it some
more is a very good idea
marsh waving his hand representative
marsh
yes thank you mr chairman first of all i
wanted to say that i am back and second
of all that i concur with representative
webb
i told my wife how we are a group of
people who like to fix things
and she says oh
a room of doctors clergy social workers
nurses art therapists counselors and the
like
are fixit people really
that's new york sarcasm coming from her
any other discussion on retain this bill
then would the clerk please call the
roll
representative snow had his hand up yes
i had my hand up can i just ask i
comment i think also this this motion
would satisfy the department of
corrections which was very concerned
about it and i think they would probably
be somebody somebody that should be
consulted when you look at the bill in
more detail because it did cause
considerable problems for them
i'm sure those who will later volunteer
over the summer to be part of
representative lundgren's rewrite
committee will forward it would forward
a variety of things from a number of the
agencies thank you for that
representative snow now we are in the
voting mode and the clerk will please
call the roll
representative marsh
votes yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative nelson
yes
representative acton
representative gay
yes representative cushman yes
representative folsom is yes
representative kelsey
yes
representative king yes representative
representative weber yes representative
mckay yes
representative snow
yes
representative
representative soloway
yes
representative cannon yes
representative
nutter although yes
representative shapiro
yes
representative woods
representative merchants
yes
you don't have to do reports for a
retained bill
we just have to send a list to the clerk
okay thank you
and now representative canaric
house bill 240 relative to
identification of cannabis strain for
therapeutic cannabis i was would have
normally asked you the question is it
okay with you for us to proceed here but
i believe you have been in consultation
with
either representative conley or
dauntonville or both and you have an
amendment to satisfy many concerns is
that correct
that is correct um and i sent it out
because it's important you all have it i
do presume that they have brought it
down to the committee room in addition
um
sorry there's my copy of the bill i lost
it was on the floor anyway in addition i
uh sent it to all of the committee
members by email and i announced that
just before lunch so you could find it
we'll give the minutes uh representative
um just in case it's it's a very few
words
changed and incorrect well bill but
still we'll give a few minutes if they
wish
one of our uh
has a bad cause
i'm sorry i have a visiting dog as well
i think we're good as long as we can't
see them right
i almost asked representative neil kirk
because i've inherited the punster
mantle from him if he watched puppy bowl
on the animal planet yesterday which was
their run-up to the super bowl there
must have been four dog puns per minute
over three hours i thought of him
throughout
because of the puns not the dogs
right
okay representative knurk would you uh
let us know how your amendment um speaks
to
concerns we raised earlier
yes first of all i should say that this
is not purely me
i did process this with the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board
and we went through this bill
i also need to speak up for one of the
advocacy groups because there were
concerns they wanted to make sure it was
properly represented
and give you just a very quick summary
of how it evolved to understand why we
made the changes
um what it was is advocacy groups are
concerned that the uh using the fancy
names like hindu kush and stuff
were
names that might sound appealing to kids
and it was on the social media
the rule was set up that these names
could not be used at all on the products
on the websites on the social media
that was the problem for the patients so
this uh the goal of this is to overturn
that rule and indeed uh the that
particular advocacy group was present at
the hearing as well and we processed it
through first we wanted to change and if
you look at the amendment you will
notice
um
and it's in bold
it says specifying is line sex and the
amendment the commercial strain name of
the cannabis that was instead of the
word the words full name because full
name is exceedingly vague chemovar is
actually one the proper names but that's
a little bit confusing commercial strain
name is what is used in the therapeutic
cannabis rules so it was most consistent
so we changed that to that comment the
other thing which is uh
did not get well sorry there's a second
place we change that and that is in line
nine to ten it also changes to
commercial strain name
in line five we continue to keep it with
shell that means that the um
atc must put on a label on the product
so they know what the name of the
product is
and we did continue with the language
that said that that commercial strain
name this is line seven and eight will
be listed on the public internet website
we continue to not allow it on the
social media because that is the part
that the kids may get directed to with
algorithmic uh social media feeds
the website
allows the
the patient to be the certifying patient
to be able to go to the website find out
if that particular atc carries the
product that they're looking for and
they can also be able to remember the
common name instead of a series of
letters and numbers so this is vetted by
the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board
they were happy with it
i can't remember what the vote is but it
doesn't matter we we passed it and in
addition to that uh the sponsor was
comfortable with this too
so i guess i would like to move
amendment number
uh
where is it here amendment number
2021-0237
h
representative mckay second
is that correct yes yes all right um any
i just want to have a question
shapiro has his hand up
i have a question for um representative
knurk um
since these names
seem to me to be somewhat homemade at
least at one point are there ever
competing names for the same strain
as far as i understand these are
basically say we call them commercial
strain names because they are used in
the commercial business of therapeutic
cannabis and they are uniform throughout
the country um they've been for they've
been names have adopted for
uh decades for example hindu kush was
named that way because apparently that
strain was either identified or
developed in the hindu kush area that's
a geographic area so to be a little like
you know
saying you know some other kind of um
name from uh for a for a wine and
terrier name for where it comes from
so
the yeah these are basically accepted
names that are used in commerce and have
been for decades but yeah of course
they're all made up
thank you
any other questions representative gay
you had a question
thank you that was really my question
was this a terminology that was
universal
and
did they ever make up medical sounding
names for them
i kind of guess not
may i answer
yes go ahead
i have looked at some of the names and
that we were directed to leafly.com and
kind of i scrolled through some of those
i they generally don't seem to have true
medical names or medical sounding names
they're usually cutesy names you know
bubble gum hindu kush that kind of stuff
which is why they were considered to be
perhaps difficult or not good to have on
social media feeds with algorithms
directing kids to
them representative merchant you have a
question
or statement
thank you mr chairman
representative knurk
on the commercial strain name is that
like a proprietary name that is
trademark protected or is it something
more like a generic name that
anyone can use
that i do not know that um
i could say these i i do not know that
but i don't think so because these uh
okay i just better not say anymore i
anyone else with a question
representative gay with a follow-up
thank you uh thank you very much
are we supposed to
me where we supposed to see or not see
you may mention
that there are
uh prohibitions where these names can be
used i don't see them in the bill but
that they're somewhere else
that they can't be used in social media
yes representative that's already in
rule indeed the purpose of this
legislation is to overturn the rule that
was promulgated by the therapeutic
cannabis program that prohibited the use
of the commercial strain name on the
package label on the website and on the
social media so this would take this
would allow back on not allow it but
force it back onto the product would
allow it on the website but the rule of
prohibiting uh the
social media would still be standing
thank you
anyone else with a question for
representative canark or a statement
because this is an exact session
make a speech
i see no further hands up from
i suppose we're the peanut gallery
representative for giving me a walk down
memory lane and we can provide an answer
to the young members later what that
means
uh it has been moved by representative
knurk and seconded by representative
mckay
2021-2
h the amendment the clerk will call the
role please
representative marsh
votes yes
represent representative mcmahon yes
representative nelson yes
representative acton
yes
representative gay yes
senator cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative kobalt
yes
representative weber
yes representative mckay
representative mckay you have to
representative mckay
yes
thank you
i read his lips representatives know you
yes thank you
representative knurk
yes
representative salloway yes
representative cannon yes
representative nutter upcoming yes
representative shapiro
yes
representative woods
yes representative merchant
yes representative pearson yes
21.
21-0
now we have
house bill
2-4-0
as amended i need somebody to move and
second
make a motion
uh yes
okay
make your motion make a motion to pass
out to pass with amendment 240.
otpa representative merchant
do we have a second america
second
any further discussion
we basically just did it
so now see
i don't see any on the um thank you
gallery
which bill are we working on with the
would the clerk now please call the roll
we just voted on the amendment mr
i'll just make one uh quick comment i
think that'll be meaningful
um on the very day that my um that we
had this hearing my wife came home that
night from seeing patients as a home
care physical therapist
and she didn't even know that we had
that hearing but she had a story from
one of her
patients that he had he was suffering
from um
a
condition that he was able to at one
point obtain a named strain
in maine that that helped him so he went
ahead and got went through the whole
licensing process here in new hampshire
and went to uh domestic
to the um
dover the dover atc was unable to find
he tried to request specific name but
they wouldn't give it they didn't have
that information so he spent a thousand
dollars just kind of trying various
things that never worked for him and
then he never used it
and uh so it was a failure for him to
even go and get the card so that's just
we're fixing that problem right here
thank you
okay saying now the clerk may call the
roll saying not
representative marsh
votes yes
representative mcmahon
yes
representative nelson
representative action
yes
representative gay yes representative
cushman yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king yes representative cobalt yes
representative weber
yes
representative mckay yes
representative snow
representative snow on mute yes yes you
representative
yes
representative cammon yes
representative
yes representative shapiro yes
representative woods
yes
representative merchant
representative pearson yes okay
21-0 any objection
to consent
representative merchant will you write
the report please
yes what does the report do please
soon
we normally have the um
custom that you may not leave the room
until the report is turned in
work
while this could
be the start of a new custom i'm not
going to do that if you could email it
to me within 48 hours please so i can go
over it it can then go to the clerk it
can hop its happy way forward whenever
we actually get to vote in the large
group
thank you mr chairman
so merchant will write the blurb thank
you
house bill
which is relative to cannabis during
pregnancy
it's representative marsha's bill
and i put a hold on to it until there
was an amendment coming forward from
representative canark which we now have
in hand so representative marsh um would
you be happy if we proceeded or would
you rather we wait a week uh mr chairman
i would like to proceed i move out to
pass on house bill 163 and i would also
move the amendment uh
which is zero two three eight h and
yield the florida representative kenner
to speak to that
represent well wow i mean
you're good at this representative marsh
moves otp i'm waiting for a second no no
we have to move the amendment first
second the amendment is representative
weber that's marsh yes and weber second
may i speak to his motion
you may speak to the motion on the
amendment and what it does
yes okay so again we processed this then
our therapeutic canvas medical oversight
board meeting last wednesday night
and if you pull out your amendment which
again is zero two three eight
and the way this works
everything in the bill is the same on
page one and the top of page two
this bill replaces sections three and
four
which begin
on the bill begins on page two
line four
so again if you were trying to follow
both the bill and the amendment you look
in those two places
the concerns
uh were a few and by the way at first i
should say
as i accommodated my testimony on this
tcmob had already processed the 1581 the
bill from last year no that was a
and we did jeff that was a good yawn but
can you mute yourself
please move during yawning
it is it is nap time
yes anyway but we process we i testified
and we had processed last year's bill
and we overall agreed with the concept
we just had a few little concerns so if
we look now
on the amendment
on so on the amendment it is line
six
the language changed before all it said
was
that counseling has been provided to all
women we added in by the certifying
provider
we did not feel that the atc was
qualified to necessarily provide that
type of counseling uh they aren't
trained for that
they are not medical providers it would
require them to be profiling people as
to gender and whether of child bearing
age
and so we felt it was much more
appropriate that the counseling be done
by the certifying provider so this just
simply puts that in
and on the next line
the next line when it says on page seven
and the parent or guardian of a patient
less than age 18 because the original
bill just said counseling anybody under
25 and children under 18 need to have a
parent or guardian present when talking
about any intervention
so that's the only words that are added
in there
and um
the way that this is going to work
likely the rules be promulgated there's
already a check box that they've
counseled on a number of other things
this language would be added in so it's
not an undue burden move down further
in the amendment
to pay to line 14.
the objection which i raised at the
hearing and mike holt from the
therapeutic cannabis also uh echoed and
we agreed with in our tcmob meeting is
that we should not be codifying what the
risks are in statute because statute
takes a long time to change medical
knowledge changes on occasion and so we
thought instead of having the words that
were there before which is the risks of
cannabis use during pregnancy and while
breastfeeding and it used to say
including the risk of low birth weight
and developmental issues strike that
language and we just say as outlined by
the therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board i'd already sent you
prior to the hearing
uh some of the work products we've
already developed in preparation to
comply with this bill anyway and so we
have already outlined those and actually
they're identical but this way if
something changes new issues come up or
issues are proven not to be true
that can be altered internally through
rules not having to go through statute
the next thing though on the next line
where it says on line 15 it used to say
a warning poster
we did not like the word warning we
certainly agree that warning is a good
thing to use when you're buying
cigarettes or alcohol but when you have
a
um an issue here where people are coming
in for a therapeutic material that
they've been certified to use warning we
thought might sound a wee bit harsh and
we said an informational poster so it
still gives the information it still
will be warnings and again i sent you
some um ideas of what that could be with
the slide deck that i sent um but the
point is we wouldn't use the word
warning we'd use informational because
we're giving information and the reason
party for that is there may be a very
rare time
when it actually is appropriate for a
pregnant woman to continue using
cannabis therapeutically
the ruling sorry the wording we have in
our work that we've done is that it
should not be used
if there is any other acceptable
alternative so in the rare situation
where somebody has let's say a totally
out of control ptsd and they will not
make it through their pregnancy perhaps
you might but that's going to be rare
so uh that was the addition we put in
there the reason for that informational
rather than warning
now drop down to uh
number nine which is uh
line 21 of the amendment
same principle here instead of the long
laundry list it was there of all the
changes that this are in the surgeon
general's advisory
begin their medical they might change
new things may come up things may be
proven not to be true
we have a default to being in
line number 21
and 22
as outlined by the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board
then if you slide on down to line 23
once again it becomes an informational
poster rather than a warning poster so
those are the only changes simply making
sure that we know that the certified
provider does the counseling that the
parent or guardian is there if you're
less than 18 that the tcmob has the
ability to be nimble and change these
issues as needed and that it's called
informational not warning those are all
the changes in the amendment any
questions
does anybody have any questions for
representative
representative marsh is waving his hand
representative marsh
yes i would like to thank representative
kenner for taking this on and doing the
hard work and making a good bill better
because we just got this today i'm not
going to
you go at my usual breakneck speed and
give us a few minutes just to read
anything and formulate a question and
so everybody will know that um
we've done all the looking we want to on
this
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
representative
marsh and
kanark whoever would like to answer does
this bill um just fill it correct me
let me know if i'm right in thinking
this is going to force say a provider
who doesn't agree with the risk
assessment
um presented by the surgeon general if
they have a differing opinion this will
force them to
may i answer the question mr chairman
yes sir
yes
the
question is whether counseling has been
given it does not ask about the content
or require any uh provider to
conform with any other provider's
opinions as we all know doctors are
prone to disagreeing about all sorts of
things as representative knurk and i
disagree about many things
not too often
may i answer also
go ahead
we have also in the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board spent months
this last year working on uh developing
a program of best clinical practices for
certifying providers and those do
include counseling um and again because
it is a moving target we didn't we don't
put that in as saying you must tell them
this or this or this but that you really
should counsel the patients about all of
these issues and that's the adolescence
regarding the that piece and the
pregnant and lactating females as well
and representative nelson had his hand
up representative nelson
yes i have a question i do not have the
amendment in front of me but could uh
representative knurk on page two of the
original number seven
just tell me the changes of that again
because i don't have a question for you
sure thing okay so you're on the
original bill line 13 i presume
that is correct okay all it is is the
the original it says
information about the risks of cannabis
use during pregnancy about breastfeeding
comma including the risk of low birth
weight and developmental issues period
we agree with those um that is in our
work that we've done but the issue is
that medicine can change so we changed
during pregnancy and well breastfeeding
as outlined by the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board that way we have
the ability to be nimble to change it
next year should something new be need
to be added or should something need to
be removed many of these findings are
relatively new also many of them are
based upon recreational use we may find
different issues with
therapeutic use so the point is we can
then be nimble and change it in rules
over the course of a year instead of
over the course of a couple years
and again the next section is just
changing from a warning poster to a
which is on line 15 of the original bill
to an informational poster
in our question and i do have a
follow-up question
go ahead
representative
thank you i'm sorry mr chairman uh
informational versus
what would that just say i mean would it
list
specific warnings because i think of a
woman or somebody went in there and they
saw very specific things it might
trigger something that it could affect
your memory
a whole bunch of other things throughout
the bill
rather than just putting you know a
generic word in there and you really
don't know which one they're talking
about
may i answer
go ahead please
well the the things that we have been
preparing already state things such as
there is no known safe amount of
cannabis to use during pregnancy and
breastfeeding that's pretty well agreed
upon by uh the surgeon general and
anybody else um that's why again well
you know actually i must say even even
though i was an orthopedic surgeon if i
had a patient who was pregnant and i was
considering an intervention or we were
talking about medicines i still would
like to get them off as much as i could
and i'm not an obstetrician but i just
simply knew that the cleaner that person
would be from anything and same with
alcohol cigarettes but the thing is on
occasion there are times when we need to
have somebody on a medication because
it's the appropriate thing for them to
be able to make it through so
um the we just would use factual
information
if you want to if you go back to the
email that i sent to before the hearing
on this i did have a slide deck and in
that there were a couple of uh
schematics a couple of diagrams of some
of the posters that are used one put out
by the cdc one by one of the other
states and they are you know eye catchy
they have the points about the impact
upon the mother the impact upon the
fetus um so that you can kind of know
what those are
thank you
sure
anything i think
representatives snow had his hand up yes
representative snow and then
can unmute
representative snow you need to unmute
good thing we couldn't hear that
[Laughter]
so we could stick it on the edge so just
remind where the button is oh no where'd
he go
he lost oh he hit the leave meeting
button
no no he's still there he's still there
with us he just he hit the video button
took the video off
yeah
so
try the space bar
it doesn't work with the it doesn't work
it doesn't work webinar okay click on
microphone in the lower corner
no there is no microphone yeah there you
go
anyway
the part in which you talk about
counseling to be provided by the
referring uh physician um
where is that because i can't find it is
it on page two
in that scene
in the original bill it is not there it
is there in the amendment and what it is
and the amendment on line six
that is where it is inserted that the
counseling will be provided by the
certifying provider
any other questions representative gay
good
chair
is he sir
representative schneider uh it sounds to
me please correct me if i'm wrong i'll
make a statement you tell me from right
or wrong it sounds like the change in
wording makes it better because you're
not being restricted to talk to the uh
the certified provider is not restricted
to the
uh points made by the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board
that's just that just gives a nice
general term in line 14
that
they can post
they can post those things as the as the
list changes by the therapeutic cannabis
medical board
you can post different lists as they as
they um evolve
so we're not this isn't restrictive
language it's actually allowing more
flexibility
yeah
may i answer
yes that is that is the intent of the
change is to keep it nimble because that
is the job of the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board is to review the
medical issues and we again have spent
the entire last year working on provider
education pieces
with slide decks handouts
and we were going to start a road show
but that's a little on hold for now and
then um
having also patient information things
that is our job to do it and to review
these things and that's why we felt uh
and with representative marsha's uh
blessings that it would be reasonable to
just let the tcmob do that job
you know hands up thank you seeing none
hearing none would the clerk please call
the roll on the amendment 0 2 3 8
h
representative marsh
votes yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative nelson
yes
representative acton
representative gay yes representative
cushman yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes
senator king yes representative kobalt
yes representative weber yes
representative mckay
yes
representative snow
representative
yes
representative soloway yes
representative cannon yes representative
neder upham yes
representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative merchant
yes
representative pearson
21 to zero and now i know representative
marsh is quite eager to move house bill
fn
amended and so i've read my mind mr
chairman i make that motion
and who has the second on this second
who was that
representative shapiro spiro marsh and
shapiro
any discussion now on this bill
fn
amended
i don't i have hands up mr chairman oh
no uh representative cofoult has his
hand up mr chairman
the chair calls representative cushman
um
i am going to um just
say that i i can't support this bill
um because i think it's too much
meddling in the
patient-client relationship
we don't mandate by separate rsa
counseling for the dangers of zofran
or other
anti-aemetics during pregnancy
feedback
and did some research on the benefits of
using cannabis for morning sickness
during pregnancy
and i think
that since the
the science is pretty um
you know i don't think that there's a
robust body of literature
on on pregnancy and cannabis use i know
there are a few studies but
um i don't think it's
reasonable to make a separate rsa to
require this counseling
i won't be supporting it
would either representative marshall
i would like to please did that
jerry
representative
that's the one
okay um yeah the difficulty though here
and this always makes it quite difficult
is to remember that cannabis continues
to be a schedule one
material which is why we do not talk
about prescribing it and we have to have
a whole set of rules about how we run
this program that are so vastly
different than how we do medicine in
general
because
physicians uh cannot well sorry
providers because other people can write
too
are not
really we don't have a proper standard
of care we don't have an fda rulings on
these things so we have to work in a in
a fashion that combines
a currently federally illegal material
with something that the state is
sanctioning to be used therapeutically
and well you there are points about
uh therapeutic cannabis may be helpful
for morning sickness the point of the
matter is so was thalidomide
yeah and so we have to remember that we
all medicines or all materials have
goods and bads to them and a patient
should be informed as to the importance
of the risks and the benefits
and i agree with you and i commented
before we don't have a lot of data from
the recreational sorry from the
therapeutic cannabis side it comes from
the recreational side currently and
that's why we're defaulting to tcmob so
we can take out some of these warnings
if it turns out that we have new data
that says hey it isn't so bad if it's
under a certain amount of control
therapeutically so that's the idea of
making this flexible so it can be
changed but the current information
would support being highly cautious in
mr chairman i saw representative kohful
put up a hand a while ago but it's down
again so i don't know if he is still
intending to talk or not it was not my
intention to put my hand down i'm not
sure how that happened before i call on
you representative do you have a
follow-up representative cushman yeah my
um
my statement is that
i well i understand that the
regulation mechanism is different and
it's kind of a roundabout way
it's and i understand there's some
wiggle room now with this oversight
board even if there is an oversight
board and standards of practice
you know established by that um it's
still the
the provider's prerogative in my view to
provide informed consent and their
responsibility under the law anyway
um so they will do that with their own
may i respond though hey representative
again as representative mark said this
bill does not state what they need to
say just that they have given the
counseling and as representative marsh
pointed out many physicians we often do
not agree about medical issues
and so if that particular physician
wishes to tell them that it is perfectly
fine
they can they still check the box if
they've counseled the patient i would
not personally agree with that
counseling but there's nothing that says
what that certifying provider has to say
to the patient
mr chairman i have my hand up as well
yes representative marsh
yes i thank you i would like to point
out to the committee that
most medications like zofran which was
given as an example are approved by the
food and drug administration and the
food and drug administration has warning
labels and package inserts included with
these products before they are
distributed to consumers so there is a
mechanism whereby the information that
consumers need is conveyed to the
consumers in the case of cannabis it has
not gone through that process
the legislature has determined that
cannabis is to be provided as a drug to
people in the therapeutic cannabis
program and therefore becomes incumbent
upon the legislature to make sure that
the people who are getting this drug get
the information they need to make an
informed decision just as the fda has
done on a national level for
other prescription drugs like zofran so
i think in this case we are just doing
the second half of our duty we've made
this drug available to the public and we
have a duty then to make sure that they
get the information to make an informed
decision uh so thank you very much
representative cofolt
yes uh thank you mr chairman um i am i
have to say i'm i'm kind of i've kind of
been on the fence on this one i i think
it makes good sense to uh to to
[Music]
inform people about risks um at the same
time i also
am concerned about codifying something
in the law which i think is is
ultimately
best handled elsewhere
and i recall if i recall correctly
somebody from dhhs had stated that it
was the department's intention to
produce
similar materials
so you know i as far as the the
availability of the materials are
concerned i feel like
codifying this in legislation is
um
is probably not necessary
and uh and i am a little bit concerned
about the
um the state of the of the
uh
relationship between the physician and
the patient so uh for that reason i am
anyone else
give it
may i actually answer back to
representative cole fault for a moment
yes you get in under my 20 seconds do it
okay and actually what i'm going to say
is very much what representative marsh
said when he presented this bill
sometimes
legislation helps to make sure something
really happens
and indeed um
you know we
are on board with this and are working
on it but it is helpful sometimes to
and let me
underscore that in that
i'm involved in something with one of
the departments where they had said that
they were going to do something
and they haven't done it in a few years
and so now there will be a bill that i
will be part of
for the same reason i'm sure they just
forgot having it in law will help them
remember
i don't see any hands mr chair the bill
is house bill 163 fn
as amended
moved by representative marsh
seconded by representative shapiro clerk
please call the roll representative
marsh
what's yes
representative mcmahon
yes
representative nelson
no
representative acton
yes
representative gay
representative cushman now
representative folsom yes
representative kelsey
yes
representative king
representative kobalt
no
representative weber
yes
representative mckay
representative snow yes
representative knark
yes
representative soloway
representative cannon yes
representative nutter upon yes
yes
representative woods
representative pearson yes 18 3
who is the third
no
thank you for correcting me and it will
not go on consent thank
you
oh that's correct
now representative marsh would you like
to write the majority report
uh yes mr chairman i'll have it to you
within a matter of minutes
[Laughter]
speed it up
gotta hit the send button
one amongst representatives nelson
cushman and cofault wish to write the
i'm not speaking once it is not
necessary but you may do it
and let us know why
all right representative cushman writes
the minority report tells us why they
are against the bill
and the majority report will take into
account
what the amendment
does
but
mr chairman i actually have a
piece that i wrote some time ago if i
can find it about how to write blurbs
which we don't call blurbs anymore we
just call committee reports but if you
would like me to send that around i
would be glad to do so i'll make a copy
of that for myself thank you and i'm
sure my colleagues would as well
now let me ask you representative weber
in the minority report
as i understand it it is simply saying
why
um they believe that this is not a good
bill to pass
they don't recommend any other
motion no the minority also does
actually select a different motion in
this case it would be an expedient to
legislate i think because
uh they want it
they simply don't agree with the bill
they could say that they wish the
committee had retained it
although maybe you can't do that one
because i don't think the house can tell
us to retain but
we often have them that
one report has ought to pass with an
amendment and another report is ought to
pass with a different amendment
well i learned something i think it's
relatively simple it just they don't
want the the people in the minority i
don't think wanted to pass at all so
that's itl for the recommendation
thank you i learned something from my
questions
okay good now under uh 350 which is
representative atkins um i don't have a
350 350.
i don't think i've seen an amendment
representative acton is there an
agreement
no there isn't there is not
no
okay
then
hey i'd like to make an emotional puzzle
you say again
uh can i do that mr chair
yes yeah that's usually
a custom is to give the bill sponsor
first whack at it
thank you
i'd like to move that we uh
vote ought to pass on house bill 350.
ought to pass representative acton is
there a second
second
and representative snow second set and
now we may discuss it
representative acton
okay so well you know we went through
this
pretty comprehensively and we've done it
a number of years in a row here
so i don't think we need to spend too
much time but i will certainly take any
questions um just
keep in mind that um
we really did spend
a lot of time going line by line through
this we made a lot of amendments last
year
and we did a lot of subcommittee work
that really went well a lot of input so
i think this is ready to go and um you
know we'll pass the house again i hope
and see what happens in the senate
i'm not ceo no representative nelson has
his hand representative how would you
thank you mr chairman just a question
what was the for the person that's
growing them for the caregiver how many
plants or how many people can they grow
for
and it's three mature plants three
immature plants and 12 seedlings thank
you
representative shapiro has a hand up
yes thank you mr chairman
um i don't have a question i just have
while i'm not somebody who thinks
marijuana use is benign i think in fact
it's a
problem for a lot of people especially
adolescents
i just think that prohibition of
marijuana has been a disaster
in so many ways
and that this is a vestige of
prohibition
and
if people are concerned about diversion
of this grown
cannabis
i think cannabis that is bought in a
in a dispensary can also be diverted and
i think cannabis is so
readily available to people
that to me it's not an issue i
wholeheartedly support this and i think
people should be allowed to be able to
grow their own
cannabis because it's cheaper because
because they have more choice and um
because it's about self-reliance so i
wholeheartedly support this bill
thank you
i have representative merchant with a
hand up and i have representative kelsey
with a hand up
representing thank you
thank you mr chairman and also
it's i'm trying to go through my notes
and i remember someone making a comment
that
it's not inexpensive to buy cannabis um
and for somebody who's
on it who needs it particularly chemo
patients
it can be a cost burden
so i was trying to go through my notes i
think i had somewhere around two or
three hundred dollars a month that would
cost them to go to a dispensary what i'm
trying to get to is this i think
minimizes the cost barrier to patients
getting their cannabis
to make the medical treatment that they
need particularly people with oncology
uh and the like so just want to clarify
my notes that it's like 300 per month i
believe is what they had is that correct
does anyone know
yeah i can take that one
the the cost of
one ounce of flour the the typical
bag of cannabis is uh about in in the
range of 360 dollars
so it depends on on your needs uh some
people could use that uh could go
through that every
uh two weeks if and if you're making
edibles maybe even more so so the cost
could
be double that up and upwards of a
thousand dollars
most people who are just using for
um pain and so forth would be less than
that so uh but but it is considerable
amount of money
in the to the tune of uh two to three
hundred
minimum i would say for
representative kelsey had her hand up
and i believe that representative canark
is now asking to speak after
representative kelsey representative
kelsey
thank you mr chairman um i guess my
concern with this is uh being a big
proponent of the second amendment um
is this not going to hurt somebody's
second amendment rights if the atf
were to find out that somebody was
cultivating
therapeutic marijuana
is it still the stance of the atf to
then come in
and be able to
a good question
representative canark would you answer
that care to answer that
actually
i'll give what my memory is but i think
perhaps representative acton may know if
i recall even just
being a certified
patient
has the same risk isn't that correct to
representative acton
yes it does because you have to fill out
the
on the form to purchase a firearm
you
it specifically uh states it it calls
out cannabis in in medical form
and uh so there is a prohibition on that
at the federal level
and um now the
so you get into that gray area of is it
enforced or not right now it's not being
enforced
uh so we look to the future and that's
the problem with this dubious status we
have of states approving it
in the status it has at the federal
level hopefully that'll change it i
don't think there'd be crackdown but who
even knows
follow up so yeah i mean
uh so representative kelsey yes that is
a valid concern
yes follow up please
okay so um then people would know
that they were putting their second
amendment rights
they were risking them by doing this
yes it's something that that the
community talks about
thank you
[Music]
anyone else representative kenner did
you wish to speak again i have a note
here that you do yes uh yes i'll
actually finish that last and the point
is that you've run that same risk just
being a certified patient whether you're
growing or not growing so that risk is
already there growing will not increase
it um the
point i wanted to make though is the
access issue is not just a financial
access issue that is a very important
point that representative merchant
brought up but it's also a geographical
access issue
because the dispensaries are rather
scattered
and if you are in the north country you
may have a very long drive to your
closest dispensary including those who
are in the southwest corner of the state
who may need to be crossing state lines
uh which is a problem as well uh so the
issue is it allows a geographic ease to
be able to grow and process your own
material
rather than having to drive somewhere to
get it so both
thank you anyone else uh representative
folsom
thank you mr chairman um
i normally am a big stickler about
marijuana
coming from colorado
um
but i actually in favor of this bill
and um
it's been touched on a little bit and
and the pricing is really what drove it
home for me
um and i've had conversations with
several people already
the numbers that i have gathered it's be
350 for an ounce in a dispensary 150 to
200 on the black market
and about 25
if you grow your own um
so i know people with a medical
marijuana card who are already doing one
of the two options
that aren't technically not allowed yet
um so
i'm going to i'm going in favor of this
bill
thank you representative
a representative nutter upham has her
hand up representative
um thank you i remember
uh distinctly the testimony from people
uh last year
um that said you can only when they go
to the dispensary to get their uh
prescription they're only allowed 10
days worth of product
which meant if you lived an hour and a
half from the dispensary you might have
to travel to that dispensary three times
in one month which there were some of
the people that testified in front of
our committee that um were in pain it
was it was very difficult for them to
travel at all
and that would mean they would have to
make you know six trips back and forth
back and forth so i just wanted to add
that in uh
as a consideration with the cost as well
so i'm definitely in favor of letting
people take care of themselves so i'll
be voting for this
the bill before us is house bill 350
permitting qualified patients and
designated caregivers to cultivate
cannabis for therapeutic use
moved by representative acton seconded
by representative snow would the clerk
please call the role representative
marsh
what's yes
representative mcmahon
yes
representative nelson
no
representative acton
yes
representative gay
yes representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes
representative kelsey
yes
representative king yes
representative cold falls yes
representative weber
yes
representative mckay
representative snow
yes
representative knurk
representative salloway yes
representative cannon yes
representative nataracam yes
representative shapiro
yes
representative woods yes
representative merchant
yes
representative pearson
to my great surprise yes
[Laughter]
and that will go on
consent
and representative nelson do you wish to
write a minority report
no no
i'm sorry
you cannot write a minority report it
doesn't go on consent if there's a
minority report very much representative
nelson is there any objection to go on
consent
no objection
then it's on consent and
representative acton
you may write the blurb
i will and let me just say uh thank you
all for the
approaching this with an open mind
and and
logic and reason and compassion is
really um it's something else to it's
quite an honor to be a part of this
thank you
well you know how the vote went last
time and it's
your good work and presentation
that uh carried the day for you pete you
did do a good job i'm sorry i'm one of
those ones who voted no but that's it
that's okay this is a tough tough topic
house bill 314
relative to homestead
food operation
licensure
representative herschel nunez is the
principal sponsor and representative
marsh
has a motion
uh thank you mr chairman i move that we
retain this bill because i think this
bill needs work
do we have a second i would second that
weber but i see a lot of other hands up
too
marsh moves weber seconds
and uh representative marsh please speak
to this
i think it's important to allow small
farms in the state of new hampshire to
be able to sell their goods directly to
the public i think there may be some
issues regarding internet and that sort
of thing in this bill
i don't think this is something we can
fix with a simple amendment i do think
it warrants looking at more closely and
therefore retaining the bill gives us
any other further discussion
uh representative weber has her hand up
representative webber please thank you
for recognizing this mr chairman um i i
concur with what representative marsh
said and
uh the other thing that we talked about
was perhaps involving a member or
members of the environment and
agriculture committee
who have also dealt with this issue
extensively in the past
to have their input
as well as ours because i think it
representative clerk has his hand up
representative
yes and i would uh echo that um peter
bitsby the vice chair at uh ena uh
contacted me about this and his comment
was that they actually just they did not
change other parts of the bill but they
did vote to increase the cap to 35 000
last year
and that
the dhhs was okay with that at that time
so this is one of those
interdepartmental things so we do
they've already processed it we
definitely want to get them involved
thank you
i just want to dig in representative gay
i just wanted to add that we were
appointed it was pointed out to us that
increasing the cap
meant we had to fix something another
limit and another another rsa are rule
so yes
i certainly support the goal
but it looks like it's going to take
anyone else
yeah i'd like to just uh
quickly say let me
raise my hand here
um yes please go ahead
yes uh
i really i wish we had the time to sub
go through subcommittee and get this
done in normal conditions i think we
could because i'm really worried to put
this out another year you know time is
of the essence to make these changes
because we could get them applied for
this harvest season
uh but there but i do agree that there
is some work that's needed to get this
right and um i'll certainly if needed
volunteer i'm a homesteader i i would
like to go down this road sometime so i
will volunteer
to make this a real um
retaining not just a death with dignity
type
representative gay
um
how
okay here's it bluntly why can't we have
the meetings why can't we have
subcommittee meetings because
we don't have to go anywhere we can do
them from home
it's just a matter of time first of all
the chair did not say we cannot have
subcommittee meetings
the chair said that we are being
encouraged to have fewer quite a bit
fewer of them because it has to do with
the staff on the fourth floor i have
asked the staff on the fourth floor
today for something and they said they
are massively short-handed today which
is why representative weber is doing the
part that often christina dyer did so
that is why we cannot have a lot of
subcommittee meetings so we're gonna
we will probably have a few but uh we're
not able to have a lot of them well i
realize their work
is often fitting from us it would be
helpful to know
all the i don't know
all the extra work they have to do to
can someone one of us do that or is my
statute
it's actually not quite that simple um
you know it has to be noticed in the
calendar
uh there has to be somebody monitoring a
dedicated number so that the public
can dial in or email ins and
let us know if they're having
difficulties
so some committee meetings have to be
made to the public too
absolutely every time we hold the
meeting it is a public meeting
it's not necessarily a public hearing
the public doesn't necessarily get the
right to speak but we all of our
meetings and all of our subcommittee
meetings must be open to the public and
are subject to the notice requirements
of the right to know law
okay
and none of us could uh host a zoo
meeting it has to be
um
hosted with staff from here
the i'm not going to answer for the
current administration but when i was in
the majority and working on this issue
these are not meetings that are set up
under anybody's 40-minute zoom use
meeting
these are webinars that are done on a
much higher level of licensing
and we do it that way to ensure things
like that
committee members can speak and members
of the public can't we do it to ensure
that we are not zoom bombed while we are
holding the meetings
uh each notice for a committee member is
set out separately in that case
i
we
when we were in the majority felt that
it was inadvisable to just have
people going off and having meetings at
any old time because the notice
requirements and other requirements
might get skimped on
and
i don't know what the current thinking
on it is but my guess is that they have
anyone else to the question of
homestead food operation licensure bill
retention and representative knurk waved
at the camera again representative
please i only wanted to say perhaps
representative webber this might be a
good time for you to give a reminder to
the whole committee that we likewise
cannot send an email to the whole
committee
regarding our deliberations on a bill uh
nor can we even be
calling a bunch of people or meeting
with them anything over outside of your
caucus or over the majority or the the
quorum plus one because we have to make
sure we all abide by 91a did i get that
correct
that's correct and the other part of 91a
is you cannot make 14 make 21 separate
phone calls either
um you cannot do in series that which
you could not do
all altogether so
um
you know if it's a caucus it's fine if
it's less than half of the committee
it's fine but when it goes beyond that
i do like the idea of homesteading
for food operation i made quite a bit of
money with a little vegetable garden as
a child so
this is just taking it to a bigger scale
and representative shapiro has a handout
representative shapiro
i just want to say that um
should we retain this bill another area
of the bill that we did talk about
working on was the addition of poultry
products and whether that was a
i can't remember the terminology but a
shelf safe product
so that would be another thing that
should be explored when it is worked on
and come summer i'm sure there'll be
numbers of people who will be
very willing to work with
um
each other
representative nerc has his hand up
again yes go ahead please
yes i just happen to know a bit about
this because of some of the work i've
done with ena there are there's a
separate whole program for poultry
allowing it to be done by the small
producer they have a bird limit
so that you don't have to go through a
federal slaughterhouse and so on so
that's already in statute for
um small farms anyway so again that's
why we want to get dna people here so we
don't do something redundant which
already exists in statute it's a rabbit
and poultry were brought in together a
number of years ago
seeing and hearing no one else
the motion relative to homestead
food operation
um
the motion was
was there a motion
yes yes mr chairman i moved to retain it
was second by representative weber okay
there it is oh i have my thumb offered
sorry guys um
move by representative martian seconded
by representative weber the clerk will
please call the roll
representative marsh
votes yes
representative mcmahon
yes
representative nelson
yes representative
yes
representative gay
reluctantly yes i wanted to discuss it
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king yes representative
kobalt yes representative weber yes
representative mckay
yes
representative snow
representative
yes
salloway yes
representative cannon yes
representative neder upon yes
representative shapiro
yes
representative woods
yes representative merchant
yes
representative pearson yes 21 21-0 it
goes in the later file retained
and uh
um i'm sorry what was the number on that
bill again please
314. thank you so much
wow
we just got representative marsh we just
got down here
the uh amendment to hb
220 that i believe you've sent to
everybody
um
are you of a mind to um
exec at this time
i believe that's your call mr chairman
but i am of the mind that this amendment
fixes the problems with the bill so that
we can actually affirm medical freedom
in the state of new hampshire without
interfering with the public health
operations of the department of health
and human services
i
i'm going to ask mr chairman we have not
seen that yet and that was a bill of
significant concern is there any
possibility
that those of us who already are using
up the screens of three different
devices and cannot
consistent with that look at the
amendment can we put this one off to
another time
we could do that yes
uh it is a brief amendment it's only 12
lines long but still
if that is your desire i could honor
that certainly
i would i would very much appreciate it
on behalf of myself at least um i'm
looking at my list and it may not be
appropriate but i thought that 131 might
be ready to go that's reporting of
healthcare associated infections
131 okay
i have that i do not see that in my okay
to exact folder
never mind sorry
um
words i have under 131 words considering
cushman's questions
about the word
measures
and have we gone anywhere with that are
you going to do an amendment or
oh sure
i'm asking representative cushman here
um i i will if i have an opportunity i
don't have one written up okay
representative what i believe i can't
find it but i think it's your bill
correct
actually my notes on this was
representative woods was one of your
research measures
would you representative king i think
has a has a good point would you say
that louder please yes my notes i had uh
representative woods was to research the
word measures
yes that's correct
i i did get a chance to talk with uh
representative cushman
uh
uh uh representative cool fault and i've
been playing telephone tag uh i did get
a chance to uh speak at link with dhhs
uh about both items i.e the vaccination
issue as well as the measures uh but if
there is a
amendment coming forward that would have
this was again number 131
in my wake file so anything we need to
do if that could be done in the next
week representative bushman
um i
i don't have an amendment to propose
personally i think the bill should be
itl
okay um
that having been said representative
cushman
says she thinks the bill should be itl
and so that
um i think representative woods you've
done some homework on this and
it's your bill would you
like us to execute now
uh that's fine with me i didn't get a
chance to connect as i said we played
telephone tag with representative
cofoult
if
he has any uh
reservations at this juncture i would
certainly be amenable to waiting but i
could go ahead
what's going on
[Music]
representative kofold good to go or wait
a week
um
i i actually i don't
well i i'm i'm happy to talk to uh
representative woods
um i i have serious concerns about the
language as it is currently
um open to hearing uh what you know
yeah i'm i'm open to listening i guess
my concern is that no matter
what answer comes back there's still a
um
still a problem with the fact that the
language is vague
um if
you know if if there were an amendment
to be proposed i i guess i would propose
striking the
language that has been added to section
three
um and simply uh
simply leaving the the language in uh or
the s simply leaving the strikeout uh at
the on in lines four and five
um you know i would have to review again
in detail but i i have serious concerns
about the inclusion of the language on
lines 18 to 20.
then i'm
ruled that it goes in my weight a week
file
and i would suggest that anybody with
questions or concerns
have uh a good conversation with the
sponsor which may result nothing or may
resolve something that's being the
time later
and
thank you
you're welcome
representative
marsh suggests
we take up house bill
157 which is repealing the state health
assessment and state health improvement
plan
council and boy did we have some
meetings on this one so representative
marsh you have the floor
thank you mr chairman
i will
point out to the committee that i just
sent out an amended amendment
the
department of health and human services
found a and told me to correct a
statutory reference on page 1 line 14
which is the only change between that
and the amendment which was uh
circulated uh previously so for the
purposes of discussion i will move ought
to pass on
before we go any further we're going to
have to talk about just that because not
everybody has everything so let's make
sure we have what we need
the correct amendment number is 0 2 7 0
h
can you say that again please
the correct amendment number is
zero
what zero two what
when should this have been sent to us
again mr chairman i'm going to ask your
indulgence that came in
according to my email 10 or 15 minutes
ago maybe it was a little longer than
that
um it is 3 30 and if there's anything
that has
a significant amendment i can't see the
amendments on my screen
and still participate in the meeting
and
i think other people are in that
condition as well
and given that we have to figure out
where the bill is in our filing system
and any previous amendments and this
amendment
i would be very appreciative if if
we could hold it for the next meeting we
will do that
that would be very much appreciated now
is there any other low-picking fruit
i'm going to hold the vulnerable adult
bill for a week
um and is there any low-picking
low-hanging fruit that we might i ask
could i ask one question
on 157.
he mentioned representative marsh
mentioned that there was a problem on
line 14. the bill i have in front of me
only has 13 lines
am i got an old version
uh
you're looking at the original bill
representative snow and not the
amendment that was circulated uh
previously there was a problem on line
14 of the amendment where uh a number 88
was written down as an eight so we
corrected that that's the only
difference that amendment has been sent
to us how long ago
uh yes representative weber said she
received it approximately 15 minutes ago
okay
i received the second amendment just
recently but there was an earlier
amendment that representative marsh
spent and i don't remember when that
came to us but the one that we have that
was at 3 40 friday afternoon
but the one we have to look at is the
one that came in today correct
yes there's that minor correction in
this one
okay thank you
okay that's off till next week
and the last one i'd like to do today
um is rep uh
house bill 185 footnotes
we concluded the hearing last monday
removing the work for tuesday
removing the work requirement of the new
hampshire grant granite advantage health
care program
and that representative shapiro is your
bill
[Music]
second
okay representative shapiro um
we recall the discussion but uh remind
us
okay um i didn't expect this one to come
today but i'll do my best um shapiro if
i think we could go through with it
your pleasure go ahead okay
um i think my testimony spoke in detail
to um
why i think it's a good idea to repeal
the work requirement slash community
engagement
um aspect of expanded medicaid
um
i can go through some of it again um
[Music]
abbreviate it
um
[Music]
well
so while i believe that
this was um
came into law in 2018 and that was
before my time in the house and i think
as i said in my testimony i think that
this was a
compromise made in good faith i believe
there was a democratic governor
and majorities in the house and senate
for the republicans and it was a
compromise made in good faith um
bringing together two different philos
philosophical points of view
so that in fact
expanded medicaid
could be renewed for five years and that
did happen and it was called the
granite advantage healthcare program
but since that time i think the
landscape has changed dramatically
[Music]
initially there were similar plans in
other states
that
specifically arkansas where that had
similar but less
work requirements
that intima implemented their plan
they had a similar waiver
and many many people lost their
insurance i think it was 18 000 people
lost their insurance in arkansas and
in new hampshire
health and human services attempted to
implement our version of the plan
and i believe this would have been 2019
and i had considerable difficulty
registering people
who would have qualified for the work
requirement so i believe it was out of
50 000 people that might have been part
of the program 20 000 of them
um were not able to be registered either
they couldn't be reached or
um they couldn't get them successfully
a considerable amount of money was spent
trying to roll out the plan and
considerable amount of effort from
health and human services was spent
trying to lay out the plan but governor
sununu
um
at a certain point acknowledged that it
hadn't been done
satisfactorily and they deferred it at
that point
in the meantime there's been a series of
both for kentucky and arkansas who had
similar plans and new hampshire
where federal courts struck down these
waivers
the core principle of medicaid is that
it is a health care program for
indigent people
and that it is not a work readiness
program or a character building program
so these
programs in arkansas kentucky and new
ruled unlawful by federal courts
at this very point
there is an appeal
and i believe it is the arkansas and the
new hampshire i know it's the arkansas
new hampshire
case combined
to the supreme court
that the former
trump administration
brought with the support of new
hampshire and arkansas
and
as henry lipman said during our hearings
they had just scheduled oral arguments
for the supreme court on
march 29th
but we shouldn't think in any way that
that means there'll be a ruling on march
29th
there's likely or will be a ruling weeks
or months later
possibly in june when many supreme court
rulings come out
in the meantime i'd say another factor
in terms of repealing this work
requirement is that
um
as all of us are having to deal with as
came to be
and i think
in light of covid the idea of
implementing this work requirement is
even less
viable
the idea of removing people from their
insurance which
actually would be impossible anyway
because the regulations don't allow it
during this health emergency
um
but the ethical considerations about
throwing people off their insurance
and the
public health considerations of having
people
having to go to
jobs and volunteer jobs and just going
out and being around when there's a
public health crisis and we're asking
people to
stay at home as much as possible is
another consideration
um
i understand that this is a very
emotional issue
and i understand that people on one side
a human right
and i would be count myself in that
group
because
[Music]
on some kind of principle or because
god says it's a human right it's a human
right if we make it a human right so
that's why we have to make decisions
like we're making today
um
we're about
two and a half years into the five years
have expanded
expanded medicaid
i do not think it's going to happen
i don't know if the new biden
administration is going to
what they're going to do in terms of
pursuing this case in the supreme court
i just think that this program has run
its course and we should repeal it
and
align new hampshire statute with the
federal reality
and i understand that that will be a
difficult emotional decision for some
people should not be dependent on
government subsidies and government
programs and this would
push people in the other direction
but i think it is time to repeal this
particular program
and i'm i'm glad to answer questions if
people have them well this is an exact
session and they may ask the sponsor
questions or they may wish to make a
statement
do we have hands up
uh yes you have representative marsh and
you have representative knurk
let's start with representative marsh
uh thank you representative shapiro you
and i have disagreed on this topic many
times in the past and as many of you
know uh i and several others in this
meeting
struck an agreement with
each other that we would include this
provision as part of the medicaid
expansion program and to me
it feels like
we are backing out of an agreement that
was sincerely made on everyone's behalf
um
i agree that this uh provision is not
being enforced at this time uh it may be
that repealing this would make the
question before the supreme court moved
although henry littman said it would not
save the state of new hampshire any
money
i i know certainly at this point in time
it is against uh the law with kova to
throw people off of the program uh who
may not be abiding by it by this
requirement but that being said we
aren't going to be in covet forever uh
and we make laws that last for a longer
time sometimes than we realize so i
cannot support removing this requirement
at this point in time
thank you representative marsh
representative
thank you very much one of those rare
places where marsh and canurk actually
disagree but in any case
when this did come through though uh
last
year
i did not support the bill to just
repeal and that is because i shared
representative marsha's feelings and
that is we made a deal we needed to
honor that deal because i had been you
know part of that agreement as well
but
things have changed and that is why i've
actually changed my mind about it first
of all we know that the majority of
people on medicaid already work anyway
secondly is we saw the shambles of
trying to begin to enforce it in this
state where we spent a lot of money and
were unable to even begin to get things
organized to do it and we have seen the
effects in other states the bill that i
actually supported back when this came
up the last time
um
was actually it was two years ago was a
bill
which was it was sb 290 which was a had
a metric that if a certain number of
people lost insurance that it would
suspend it and that was
you know kind of a stop gap and sort of
halfway between just repealing it and uh
and letting it go forward it was a kind
of a
harms limitation the thing is we've now
seen the disaster of trying to enforce
it we've seen the results in the other
states we've seen people lose their
insurance coverage and with all that in
mind and no compelling data that this it
was actually going to improve people's
health but actually more importantly we
need to keep people healthy to be able
to be at work
i have changed my mind from my
opposition to just repeal two years ago
and i now do support repealing but it's
anyone else
um representative weber
representative weber please thank you mr
chairman i i just want to second the
piece of representative knurk's
testimony which was that the enforcement
phase of this was very expensive
and was
a complete disaster
and it required the removal of workers
from other areas that they were working
in to go and search for people
to find out whether they were meeting
their work requirement or not so it had
consequences far beyond this particular
bill and i will end with that but i will
let you know mr chairman that both
representative acton and representative
shapiro have their hands up
thank you representative weber
okay
i
i was originally um
again against removing this um
and i've just i've been doing a lot of
soul searching on this one
um i've lived in in poverty in my life
and it wasn't
ages gone by it was fairly recently
where we
my family almost lost everything and we
would have been in the situation where
we needed to go on medicaid and one
thing i realized one thing i learned is
that
being broke is a is hard work i
i couldn't
i mean i had to do everything i could
just to keep the household together i we
were so broke at one point i had to go
and fill a five gallon diesel jug to
pour in the heating oil
i just scam up 20 bucks to fill the jug
and and that would be enough to get us
through a couple days it did the whole
winter
um
so i so i you know i i've been through
that and
the other the other issue i have is that
um i think we
we we've fallen into into a rut here
with with
medicaid where where we assume that we
have this assumption that everyone's
just sitting home doing nothing and just
in collecting
and i just don't think that i think
that's a myth and i i think it's time to
move beyond that
uh
secondly um or thirdly
um
you know
we're not just going to pull out of
coving this is going to be years
the economy is severely damaged
and there there's not many jobs
um we may we may go into it may take
years and years of of layoffs and
we got a foreclosure crisis coming
um
people are are going to need
medicaid and i i don't like the program
i wish i could rewrite the whole thing
but it's what we have right now i can't
vote
to throw people off of
medicaid healthcare
believing
what i believe is going to happen to
this country in the next couple years
which is a severe
recession
so uh
that's it i'm going to vote um
accordingly
thank you representative and
representative nutterappum has her hand
up in addition to representative shapiro
representative
uh i have a close family member who is
on medicaid
were she functional enough to work
10 hours a week 20 hours a week
she would not need to be on
medicaid she could hold a regular job
and maybe
have insurance through them
but she cannot
um she's receiving treatment now you
know each time she goes in we hope it
will be the last time
but
uh so there's a you know it's a personal
story it's a little hard because i i
know we're public but when somebody
needs medicaid like that and is unable
to
function well enough to do
you know 10 hours of volunteering at our
soup kitchen or whatever
they should be able to have the
treatment that they need so please vote
accordingly
anyone else before we go to the second
round representative representative
merchant also has his hand up is
representative gay thank you
uh when people are ill
and handicapped
doesn't that mean that they don't have
who is that address to
anybody who knows the answer because
this just sounds strange to say that
it's an excuse not to require working
if somebody i could answer that mr chair
if that's helpful
and his handicap i mean that's a form of
handicap
represent yes representative weber if
you wish
there are a number of exceptions in the
rule um
and and some of those are
very early child care and i can't
remember when that goes up to
and there are some
exceptions for
medical reasons um
both both
both
physical and uh behavioral
but
for
there are a lot of people who are on the
border lines of that um
and so no it was contemplated when the
statute was passed that there were
certain categories of people who simply
couldn't go to work and that was
recognized
the issue is all of the people
who are sort of sneaking up to that
borderline and they are also the very
people who have a great deal of
difficulty organizing themselves well
enough to fill out the paperwork to
justify or verify what they have or have
not done to
complete the requirements so
there are some provisions in the bill
it's not everybody who has to work but
there are gaps as well
and i will let the chair know that the
hands that i see now and i've lost all
control over the order
are
representative shapiro representative
i um while you are giving what i thought
was a very
fair answer to the question i was trying
to keep the order and representative
yes thank you mr chairman
um
several people have mentioned the amount
of money that it cost trying to roll out
the program a couple of years ago and so
i'll just
say that
the
federal government accounting office
said that 4.4 million dollars were spent
most of it in federal money
a little bit less than two hundred
thousand dollars in new hampshire
state money
was spent trying to roll out the program
that didn't get rolled out
i would like to
address the issue that representative
marsh brought up about on this going
back on an agreement that was made
and i'm very sensitive to that issue i
feel like in a sense he's correct
i would say that for myself when i first
was elected
and this
a similar bill was brought up i think in
2019 it was brought up by a also newly
elected representative and
one of the things i remember her saying
when she introduced the bill to repeal
the work requirement
was that
she had not been in the legislature when
the deal was made and therefore she was
not a party to the deal and that she
didn't have to um go by it
um
i disagreed
my my sentiments were really different i
had a hard time with that i felt a deal
was a deal whether i made it or whether
i didn't make it
um
so i'm sensitive to the idea that some
people might feel that we're changing an
agreement
i feel that we're changing an agreement
because the circumstances have changed
so dramatically
[Music]
not because
we had the majority the democrats had
the majority like we did the last two
years or not because we can just bring
up any bill we want i really think the
circumstances are dramatically different
for
representatives who were on the
committee
the last term
know that i have a daughter
with stage four cancer
and
that has changed my feelings
dramatically
about the idea of someone having
insurance or not having insurance
and the idea that we would take people
off their insurance especially people
who have a difficult time
negotiating
getting insurance
is just something i think we shouldn't
do
so
i would ask all of you to rethink this
idea about
a compromise made or a deal made
and try to think of this from the point
of view
of a family
or an individual
who has to face a serious illness
thank you representative
the chair recognizes representative
marsh
i did not have my hand up mr chairman
the chair recognizes representative
merchants
thank you mr chairman
a question to someone on the committee
could
looking for what percentage of the
population we're talking about now that
is not working that's causing the
problem is it is it a large percent just
one question the other one
information wise is how much this
program is paid by the federal
government versus the state government
i'm trying to understand the financial
side of the equation because it is only
three or four percent of the population
out there that's really at risk of
enforcement
that's one thing versus saying 30
percent and the other of course is how
much money the state's putting into the
can anyone answer that
part of that representative shapiro can
probably answer part of it
yes i'm not sure when we're talking
about cost i'm not sure if we're talking
about cost of insurance or cost of
running
the
work requirement program
in terms of the insurance in terms of
of the cost of
expanded medicaid is borne by the
federal government 10 percent by the
state
um
in terms of
in terms of rolling out a work
requirement and running that program
i just know from
you know past information that the
federal government paid for a lot of
that
i don't assume that they would be
responsible for for paying
for that
i assume that it would come out of the
budget of health and human services
if i could just
add something to that um representative
snow representative wood is next and
i'll put you on the list
mr chairman if i may
yes sir follow up follow up
to uh representative superior thank you
for the information
in regards to the
other question
what percentage of the population
covered through this program
is a questionable
amount that needs to be enforced as far
as the work requirement is it a small
percentage of the pie are we talking
about a large percentage because
i'm looking at saying there's only three
percent of the population that's really
a foul the work requirement is that kind
of what we're talking about or is it
greater than that it's more like 30 40
percent
where are we in that spectrum
um
i
i could
speak to that or
or anybody wants to speak to that
this is representative weber and i
noticed that representative knight is
also waving his hand
my recollection from the last time we
went through this was that there was a
concern that there were about 17 000
people who were at risk
and i'm not a hundred percent certain of
that so if somebody else had
better information i would yield to them
i i believe
i believe that there were
um
over 50 000 people on the expanded
medicaid program but that has been
inflated with covid and with people
losing their employee-based health
insurance and now it's up to
um
in the mid 60 thousands
and if you remember correctly we talked
about that with a dental benefit because
they wanted to wait till covid
resolved somewhat because the cost of
implementing that program they expect to
be less eventually
so i'm not really sure
as
representative weber said before
there are
a number of exceptions to the work
program that people can get waivers from
the work program that people can get who
are on expanded medicaid i don't know
what percentage that represents of the
over 60 000 people that are
that receive expanded medicaid right now
and representative knurk i think also
had um an addition to that
yes i mean i think here's the the issue
is that we heard the testimony back
before that it was roughly about 75
percent of people on medicaid work
anyway so we're looking at maybe about
25 percent the number of people on
medicaid is i think and this is real
back of the envelope but somewhere about
150 000 or you know if you look at it
about
uh you know ten percent of the
population so if you have a quarter or
ten percent we are indeed looking at
about two to three percent of the
population but then with the exemptions
that gets us down to representative
weber's comment because if you have
about 17 000 out of the one and a half
million we have roughly you're talking
about a percent so we are talking about
a very small number of people and that
was one of the questions is
is it worth the amount of enforcement uh
money that would be done to try to do
this to actually achieve anything and
would we
i would actually circle back to
representative gay's question
in this in sb 313
it's important to realize that went
through hhsea first representative marsh
edwards and kinorks sat down and came up
with 10 different amendments for the
program and these were had to do a lot
of them with her exemptions
we actually passed in five of them went
through the house the first committee
finance of course and their ultimate
wisdom
totally went back to the original bill
and got rid of all of our policy
recommendations so none of those got in
there as a result what we're left with
just out of curiosity is it is a
caretaker of a child under age six as
exempted that means your seven-year-old
can be home alone
that doesn't usually work well for most
people
likewise the uh
the way that it's worded does not work
well for seasonal employees we have
people up in my neck of the woods that
work for
you know 80 hours a week for a couple of
months in the summer um doing
landscaping and then work running lifts
for a couple of months but have a few
months they don't they're going to be
then going into and out of the program
back and forth and back and forth and
that is very disruptive to medical care
and it increases the administrative
costs uh so these were all things that
again martian edwards and kirk dealt
with and put in his amendments but got
lost as the bill went through finance
and then ultimately was passed so there
are some exemptions but some of them are
a little strange i think most of us
wouldn't leave our seven-year-olds home
alone
i would like to move towards closure on
this we do have representative wood
who had his hand up
just very briefly uh just to
make my uh
uh position known
uh i too uh felt this was a commitment
and before i was uh in the legislature i
worked through the medical society to
get this passed uh with the
understanding that there was a a
compromise
uh by the same token has been pointed
out this the situation is dramatically
changed
uh and as commissioner myers at that
time said the implementation is just a a
headache as we've pointed out
and just to get a little bit into the
weeds on that you had to re renew it
every month
and some people who don't know how to
get online and couldn't get the phone
number
couldn't get it so they were then kicked
off
which really
was
a complete antithesis of the whole
program
and just from an overview
the whole concept
is is is a little bit fallacious from
the standpoint of medicine
medicine is meant to make you healthy
so you can work
not make you work
so you can get health care
it's just the reverse
thank you
and thank you representative and
representative we have representatives
with the hand up representative as i was
saying representative has snow is called
on oh i'm
sorry yes thank you mr chairman just to
expand a little bit on what
representative shapiro said the typical
federal state split for
medicaid
other than the new innovative programs
is a 50-50 split 50
federal 50 state
under the expanded medicaid he is
correct that some of the programs is a
90 federal 10
spread and how much all of that is worth
i don't have that information in front
of me i would also just like to say it
seems to me that this bill is sort of
backwards
when i was working in mental health i
started a large sheltered workshop and
also a supported employment program
using the regular competitive job market
to place patients to work and one of the
things that we discovered rather quickly
is when you got people jobs even in a
sheltered environment
their medicaid would cover them until
they earned a certain amount of money
and suddenly they were cut off
and i thought the sensible way to deal
with that is if they reached a certain
level and moved ahead and were doing
well
don't cut them off instead keep them on
and begin to charge a graduated uh
fee or premium for them to stay on which
made a lot of sense and they actually
did it as a trial though i don't know
whatever happened for that trial because
i've since retired but the the fact of
the matter is that gets people used to
the idea that is insurance is not
something that they give you
insurance is something that you earn
now that's not done
but the opposite of that is to take
people's insurance away because they
haven't met some other standard and just
to give you a little idea
if people are involved in
community activities of one kind or
another if they're in some kind of a
treatment or training program
the training programs that automatically
lead to employment and so forth you can
get around this community but you know a
lot of the people that are on medicaid
don't want to listen to a lot of this
and that's one of the reasons they had
so much trouble with trying to roll this
program out because you're talking about
people that have never been treated
particularly well by the system
takes care of them to me it's ridiculous
to threaten people with the medicaid
being taken away and if this goes out of
the way we're going to see lots of
people dropped off the rolls and it
makes that's inhumane as far as i'm
concerned so i'm strongly in favor of
this particular bill and
anyway i'll apply it at this point
thank you representative snow
for myself
all my adult life i've been to some
degree or other responsible
for people
many of whom have had serious genuine
needs
but i lay alongside that
numbers of working class people that
i've known and many in my district today
who
are having to
pick up an extra shift or work a second
job
and who can tell me and point to me
people who could work
but are not working and are getting a
check
i had a family member
exactly like that she could have worked
she should have worked if she wasn't a
relative i would have turned her in
and she got her check and refused to
work
and what this does to many people who
are just getting by
is compassion
fatigue
they've cared a lot about people but
there's a point at which they stop
because this is what they see
and i understand their concern as well
i do know that there are numbers of
safety nets and waivers in this program
i'm conflicted this there's different
i vote one way i'm affirming one part of
who i am and violating another i vote
the other way i'm doing the same in
reverse but i just wanted to bring this
part of it up that there's people out
there right now who um
who are angry i am trying to encourage
them in the various compassion things i
put forward and when they see somebody
who could work but won't work it makes
my job to do this very difficult
um
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
for the first time because we need to if
you've spoken before you've had i think
you've had you say but uh is this
anybody who hasn't spoken and wishes to
see no further hands mr chairman thank
you and i want to be very sensitive to
the fourth floor they are very
short-handed today and they've been
doubling up and they want to go home
so if anybody has not spoken on this and
wishes to please signify
and you will be recognized to speak
i see no further hands mr chairman thank
you
representative and
hearing that then i will ask the clerk
on house bill 185 fn
removing the work requirement for the
new hampshire granite advantage health
care program
ought to pass
moved by representative shapiro and rep
and seconded by representative snow
with the kirk clerk please call the role
representative marsh
vote snow
representative mcmahon
no
representative nelson
oh
representative acton
yes
representative gay
no
representative cushman no
representative folsom no
representative kelsey
now
representative king no
representative kobalt
no
representative weber
yes
representative mckay
representative snow
yes
representative
representative soloway
yes
representative cannon yes
representative nutter upcom yes
representative shapiro
yes
representative woods
11 to 10 it passes it passes 11 to 10.
represent chairman
yes
i would like to file a minority report
representative shapiro will you file the
you need to unmute representative
shapiro i'm unclear did it pass or did
it not yes it has 11 to 10 that's why
you get the chance to file the majority
parking okay so it was 11 to 10 to
what the pass what's the pound you won
i'd be glad to write the majority report
thank you representative marsh the
minority report uh yes i will mr
chairman
and
with that
we are adjourned
and it seems like we're 95 sure we will
meet again
is it going to be just the one day mr
uh that's all i can get out of them at
the moment one day next week um
i'm trying to get another day we we did
exec a bunch of bills today which really
clears up next tuesday afternoon
but that's the best we've got at the
present
and mr chairman just so i know that day
we are going to have to do the first
committee bills that remain it's the
second yeah the first committee bills
that remain right any remaining bills
that go to another committee will be out
the door
next tuesday so if anybody has
amendments or what have you
this is it
next tuesday is it on the one or two
bills that are still remaining which two
are did you have a list of which the two
numbers of those are that are short
i will email everyone a list of
what i will be having us do next tuesday
and with that a list of the bills
remaining afterwards there's a lot of
that lindsay just sent us a flow chart
um
and is that is is what's an early bill
and not an early bill is that listed in
that flowchart
no
yes it is yes it is because if you look
at the second column
the second column is the due date and
most of them are march 11th but some of
them you will find the due date is
february 18th so those are those are the
early bills take care of sorry having
and what lindsay sent out will not
incorporate anything that we did today
so
that is correct any uh other procedural
questions
hearing none thank you everybody
thank you very much